THE ON GOVERNANCE AND FINANCE
WILL COME TO ORDER. GOOD MORNING
EVERYONE AS WE CONTINUE TO TAKE
PRECAUTIONS TO MANAGE ONGOING
COVERT NINETEEN RISKS THE SENATE
CONTINUES TO WELCOME THE PUBLIC
AND HAS PROVIDED ACESS TO BOTH
IN PERSON AND TELECONFERENCES
PATIENT FOR PUBLIC COMMENT.
INDIVIDUALS WISHING TO PROVIDE
PUBLIC COMMENT VIA THE
TELECONFERENCING SERVICE THE
PARTICIPANT TOLL FREE NUMBER AND
ACCESS CODE IS POSTED OUR ON OUR
COMMITTEE WEBSITE AND I WILL
ANNOUNCE IT NOW. TODAY'S
PARTICIPANT NUMBER IS TWO IS.
877-226-8163 AND THE ACCESS CODE
IS SEVEN SIX TWO. TWO FOUR SIX
TWO. I WILL OF COURSE MAINTAIN
DECORUM DURING THE HEARING AS IS
CUSTOMARY AND ANY INDIVIDUAL WHO
IS DESTRUCTIVE MAY BE REMOVED
FROM THE REMOTE MEETING SERVICE
OUR HAVE THEIR CONNECTIONS MUTED
HAVE TO SAY I'VE NEVER HAD TO DO
THIS SO I DON'T EXPECT ANY
PROBLEMS TODAY BUT- YOU ARE
ADVISED. WE ARE HOLDING OUR
COMMITTEE HEARINGS HERE IN THE-
STREET BUILDING ASK ALL MEMBERS
OF THE COMMITTEE TO BE PRESENT
IN ROOM TWENTY TWO HUNDRED SO WE
CAN ESTABLISH OUR QUORUM AND
BEGINNER HEARING. WE HAVE
SIXTEEN BILLS ON TODAY'S AGENDA
WITH TWO BILLS PROPOSED FOR
CONSENT. THE CONSENT ITEMS ARE
ITEM NUMBER TWO SB TEN FORTY ONE
BY SENATOR ATKINS FOR. PRO TEM
ATKINS AND ITEM NUMBER FOUR S.
B. ELEVEN THIRTY BY SENATOR
MCGUIRE. BEFORE WE HEAR
PRESENTATION ON THE BILLS WERE
GOING TO ESTABLISH A QUORUM
CONSULTANT PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
SENATORS CAMBIADO HERE CAMBIADO
PRESENT NIELSEN. NIELSEN
PRESIDENT DORADO. DORADO PRESENT
HERTZBERG. HERTZBERG PRESENT
WINNER. YOU HAVE A QUORUM. WE DO
HAVE A QUORUM NOW LET'S HEAR
FROM OUR FIRST AUTHOR WELCOME
SENATOR AND MEMBER GET PUSHY YOU
SHOWING UP PERCENT PRECISELY ON
TIME AND YOU MAY PRESENT YOUR
BILL SB EIGHT SIXTY TWO. THANK
YOU MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS SB EIGHT
SIX TWO SIMPLY EXTENDS THE
EXEMPTION FOR PERSONAL PROPERTY
THAT CURRENTLY EXISTS IN
CONNECTION WITH SPACE ACTIVITIES
ALSO WILL EXPAND THIS EXEMPTION
INCLUDE GROUND SUPPORT TEST
EQUIPMENT THAT'S USED FOR SPACE
FLIGHT ACTIVITIES I KNOW THIS
SEEMS HARD TO BELIEVE BUT IF
THIS SHOULD EXPIRE WE WOULD.
ACTUALLY BE EVEN EVEN TAXING-
ITEMS THAT ARE IN SPACE OUR
REACH EXTENDS QUITE BROAD QUITE
FAR. WE SHOULD EXTEND OUR
PERSONAL PROPERTY TAX TO
MATERIALS THAT ARE IN SPACE. THE
SPACE FLIGHT ECONOMY IS AN
IMPORTANT PART OF CALIFORNIA'S
ECONOMY IT BOASTS OVER FOUR.
FOREIGN FOURTEEN BILLION IN
ANNUAL GLOBAL SPENDING AND
PROVIDES A NUMBER OF JOBS IN MY
DISTRICT IN THE SURROUNDING AREA
SO FOR EXAMPLE I RECENTLY. MET
WITH THE IN A TOOL AND DIE HAD
COURT IN SANTA ANA. SMALL
COMPANY MANUFACTURES PRECISION
DEVICES THAT ARE USED IN SPACE
FLIGHT- AND AS THIS INDUSTRY
CONTINUES TO GROW ITS ONE THE
GROWING INDUSTRIES IN CALIFORNIA
IT'S APPROPRIATE THAT WE- CENTER
VISES GROWTH BY EXPANDING. IN BY
RENEWING THIS TAX CREDIT
ORIGINAL VOTE. I HAVE WITH ME ON
THE PHONE MISTER JIM SIMPSON C.
STRATEGY OFFICER FOR VIRGIN
ORBIT. VERY GOOD WE'LL HEAR
FROM- JEAN SIMPSON JIM. OKAY IF
YOUR CALL WE ARE OUT BY TERMINAL
MEMBERS MANY BEHALF THE WILL BE
AN ARCANE THANKS FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK WITH YOU
TODAY I'M NAME IS SHEILA AND
THEN HE GRABBED THE ODDS WERE
VERGE. YES TRIPS YES APPARENTLY
MR SO. IN SPACE. SO MISTER
SIMPSON I APOLOGIZE BUT YOUR-
YOUR- INTO THE HEARING ROOM. WE
CAN'T READ IT IT'S A IT. IT
THEY'LL WORK IN A CALL THAT DOT
IT'S IT MAY MAKE SENSE TO CALL
BACK AND SEE IF WE HAVE WE CAN
GET ANOTHER LINE IN. I WILL DO
SO. WE'LL GIVE HIM A MINUTE TO
DO THAT. THOSE.
VENTURA RIGHT YES I'M SORRY GO
AHEAD MR SIMPSON ARE YOU THERE.
SOMEBODY ELSE. NO THAT'S THE
MAIN THAT'S THE AT WITNESSES FOR
ONLY ONE. YES IF I WAS GONNA ASK
VENTURE IF WE MIGHT TAKE OTHER
WITNESSES IF THERE ARE ANY IN
SUPPORT ON THE ME TOO LINE OKAY
AND COME BACK TO HIM WHEN HE
GETS BACK IN THAT SOUNDS LIKE A
GOOD IDEA- LET ME CHECK AND SEE
IF MR SIMPSON HAS- CALL BACK IN
AGAIN. NOT YET MADAM CHAIR OKAY-
WERE. YOU DISCONNECTED HE'LL
PROBABLY DIAL BACK IN SHORTLY
HERE OKAY IT'S NOT A TERRIBLE ON
OUR INTO. OKAY WHAT WE'RE GONNA
DO IS WE'RE GONNA SEE IF THERE'S
ANYBODY IN THE ROOM THAT WOULD
LIKE TO TESTIFY ROOM TWENTY ONE
HUNDRED. PLEASE COME FORWARD AND
TEST FIND SUPPORT. THANK YOU HE
DIDN'T WANT TAKE TOO MUCH TIME
NOW UNFORTUNATELY A PRESS THE M.
FOR THE CALIFORNIA CHAMBER OF
COMMERCE HERE IN SUPPORT. THANK
YOU. VERY GOOD IS THERE ANYONE
ELSE. THAT WOULD LIKE TO TEST
RENNSPORT. WE'RE GONNA MOVE ON
TO THE TELECONFERENCE LINE IS OR
ANYONE ON THE TELECONFERENCE
LINE THAT WOULD LIKE TO TESTIFY
IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU ARE
MANAGER COULD YOU REITERATE
WHICH BILL WE ARE PLEASED YES WE
ARE ON THE FIRST BILL WHICH IS
S. B. EIGHT SIX TWO. EIGHT SIX
TWO THANK AS ONE TO VERIFY THAT
LAYS GERMAN IF YOU WOULD LIKE TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT FOR. AB AT
EIGHT SIX TWO PLEASE PRESS ONE
FOLLOWED BY ZERO SB ONE EIGHT
SIX TWO PLEASE PRESS ONE
FOLLOWED BY ZERO AT THIS TIME.
AND MEDICARE NOBODY IS GIVING UP
VERY GOOD WE'RE GONNA MOVE ON TO
THOSE IN OPPOSITION IS THERE
ANYONE IN ROOM TWENTY ONE
HUNDRED IN OPPOSITION. PLEASE
COME FORWARD SAYING NO ONE WAY
TO MOVE ON TO THE TELECONFERENCE
LINE AND SEE IF THERE'S ANYONE
ON THE TELECONFERENCE LINE THAT
LIKE WOULD LIKE TO TESTIFY IN.
OPPOSITION. IF YOU ARE IN
OPPOSITION TO- SB EIGHT SIX TWO
PLEASE PRESS ONE FOLLOWED BY
ZERO ONE FILED BY ZERO. AND
NOBODY IS QUEUING UP AT THIS
TIME. I LET'S SEE IF- MISTER
MISTER SIMPSON HAS BEEN ABLE TO
CALL BACK IN.
IS MR SIMPSON ON THE LINE. YOU
GOT THE HIM YEAH THAT MADAM
CHAIR THIS IS VERY URGENT I'VE
CENTER- I WAS ALSO VERY GOOD
WE'RE GONNA BRING IT BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE ARE THERE ANY
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS MOVE THE
BILL I HAVE A THERE IS A MOTION
WELL WELL WE HAVE A MOTION BY
SENATOR HERTZBERG CENTER YOU'RE
AWESOME YES- A QUESTION- CENTER.
NUMBER- OBVIOUSLY THESE ARE TAX
DOLLARS THAT ARE REALLY PRECIOUS
TO US EVEN IN THESE- AND FORCING
TIMES. IT'S COULD YOU EXPLAIN A
LITTLE BIT MORE ABOUT WHY YOU
THINK A TAX CREDIT. IS SO
IMPORTANT TO THIS INDUSTRY
BECAUSE ON THE ONE HAND IT IS A
AND A GLAD TO HEAR IT'S HIGHLY
SUCCESSFUL IS CREATING THOUSANDS
OF JOBS. SOMETIMES OUR TAX
CREDITS AIMED AT AND IN. THAT WE
MAY BE LOSING OR IS GETTING
ATTRACTED FROM TAX CREDITS LIKE
THE FILM TAX CREDIT IN ANOTHER
PART OF THIS. COUNTRY SO COULD
YOU EXPLAIN MORE ABOUT WHY AND-
SOMETIMES THERE'S A THRESHOLD AS
TO BUSINESSES UNDER CERTAIN
AMOUNT OR BUSINESSES- OF THAT
REACH THAT THRESHOLD COULD. YOU
EXPLAIN A BIT MORE ABOUT THAT
WOULD EXPLAIN WHY. WE WOULD E
GIVING A TAX CREDIT TO OUR
SUCCESSFUL INDUSTRY BUT- THERE'S
TWO REASONS THAT I CAN THINK OF-
THE FIRST REASON IS IT IS IT IS
A HIGHLY COMPETITIVE INDUSTRY-
ALTHOUGH IT IS GROWING HERE IN
CALIFORNIA- THERE'S NO. SORT OF.
INHERENT REASON WHY IT SHOULD BE
HERE IN CALIFORNIA EXCEPT FOR
HUMAN INFRASTRUCTURE AND THE
OTHER- INCENTIVES THAT REMAIN
HERE IN CALIFORNIA THE COULD
MOVE THE TAXES THAT COULD MOVE
THE NUMBER OF OTHER. OTHER
AREAS- THE SECOND REASON IS THIS
IS AN EXISTING TAX CREDIT BY
BASICALLY DISALLOWING IT ONE IT
CREATES CONFUSION. BUT TO IT
SENDS A VERY STRONG MESSAGE THAT
TELL. IS ANTAGONISTIC IF WE IF
WE BASICALLY REVERSAL DONE THE
PAST WE DEMONSTRATE THAT WERE
ACTUALLY ANTAGONISTIC. TO THE
INDUSTRY AND SO- RATHER THAN
SEND THAT MESSAGE I SUGGEST THAT
WE- EXTEND THE CREDIT THAT
CURRENTLY EXISTS. AND IT'S
RELATIVELY LIMITED EXPANSION AS
TO- FACILITIES ARE ON THE GROUND
IN THIRDLY I SUPPOSE- IT WOULD
SEEM A BIT BIZARRE IF WE START
TAXING THINGS IN SPACE AND
ABSENT I AM INFORMED ABSENT THIS
TAX CREDIT WOULD ACTUALLY BE.
TAXING PERSONAL PROPERTY ONCE
FROM CALIFORNIA THAT'S IN SPACE
. THIRTY NIELSEN. WELL YOU KNOW
THIS STATE PRIDES ITSELF WITH
BEING AT THE VANGUARD AND
CERTAINLY THIS IS AN AREA WHERE
WE HAVE BEEN AND SHOULD REMAIN
THE VANGUARD. AND I'M NOT THE
GREATEST FAN OF TAX CREDITS. BUT
THEY HAVE THEIR PLACE. AND THIS
IS MORE THAN SYMBOLIC I
CONSIDERED SUBSTANTIVE. THE COST
OF THIS INDUSTRY ARE INCREDIBLE
. AND THE RISKS THEY TAKE ARE
LIKEWISE INCREDIBLE. BUT THEN SO
ARE THE BENEFITS I THINK OF A
HOLE IN THAT INDUSTRY BASED IN
THE STATE. CONTINUE OUR
LEADERSHIP POSITION. NOBODY FROM
THE CALIFORNIA TEACHERS
ASSOCIATION SHOWED UP THERE TO
TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION BUT I'M
INCREDULOUS THAT THEY OPPOSED
THIS. AND I'D LIKE THEM TO COME
AND EXPLAIN WHY IN THE WORLD.
THEY HAVE AN INTEREST. IN THIS
OPPOSING THIS BILL. CENDRILLON
BURKE I HAVE DELIGHTED TO
SUPPORT YOUR LEGISLATION THANK
YOU SIR. WELL I JUST HAVE TO-
AGREE THAT- YOU KNOW CALIFORNIA
HAS BEEN ON THE VANGUARD MY
FATHER WORKED IN THE AEROSPACE
INDUSTRY AND SO I REMEMBER WHEN-
THEY WERE MAJOR- COMPANIES THAT
HIRED ENGINEERS THAT DID THE
WORK HERE. AND THAT ALSO DID
THAT THE TESTING RIGHT OUT ON
THE AIR AIRFORCE BASE- AND A LOT
OF THAT LEFT WHEN WE LEFT THERE.
THE SPACE RACE- I DID HAVE A
OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK WITH THE
COMPANIES THAT ARE DOING THIS
WORK AND MY ASK THE SAME
QUESTIONS WHY DO YOU NEED THIS.
I'M QUITE FRANKLY THERE BEING-
ENCOURAGED TO MOVE TO OTHER
STATES WHERE THEY'RE THEY'RE
BEING GIVEN- CREDITS BENEFITS-
MONEY AND- AND I THINK THIS IS
ONE OF THE INDUSTRY'S WE REALLY
NEED TO KEEP HER BECAUSE- THEY
HAVE THE DATE ALTHOUGH IT'S
LOCATED IN SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA-
THAT THE LIST OF SUPPLIERS. IS
STATEWIDE AND THEY'RE JUST AS
MANY- SUPPLIERS OF TALENT AND
EQUIPMENT FROM NORTHERN
CALIFORNIA IS THERE FOR SENATE
FROM SAID FROM SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA SO I THINK THIS IS
ONE OF THOSE- TAX CREDITS TO
MAKE SENSE- AND DIE WILL BE
VOTING IN SUPPORT OF THIS THE
BILL TODAY AND I THANK YOU FOR
BRINGING IT FORWARD IT'S
SOMETHING THAT HAS KEPT THEM
HERE AND I THINK IT'S A GOOD.
IDEA TO- TO CONTINUE DOING THAT
SO THAT WE DO HAVE A MOTION BY
SENATOR HERTZBERG- THE MOTION IS
TO PASS BUT FIRST BE REFERRED TO
THE COMMITTEE ON ON APPROACH
KINS PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
SENATORS CAPITO HI CABALLERO I
NIELSEN AYE NIELSEN AYE DOURADO
ROSATO I HERTZBERG. HERTZBERG
FIVE WINNER. BORDER ZERO THE
BILL HAS FOUR VOTES WE WELL KEEP
IT OPEN THE ROLE OPEN FOR THE
MISSING SENATOR THANK YOU VERY
MUCH THANK YOU THANK YOU
MANAGER- I WOULD LIKE TO TAKE UP
THE CONSENT AGENDA IF- WE COULD-
THERE IS A MOTION. TO PASSED THE
CONSENT AGENDA. PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL SENATORS CAPITO HI
CABALLERO HI NIELSEN. NIELSEN HI
DURAZO. TERRAZZO HI HERTZBERG.
HERTZBERG HI WIENER. BORDER ZERO
FOUR EYES NOSE NO ZERO WE WILL
LEAVE THAT THE ROLE OPEN. I'M
GOING TO MOVE ON TO THE NEXT
BILL CENTER MCGUIRE S. B. TEN
SEVENTY FOUR. WELCOME. GOOD
MORNING AT VENTURE MR BY SHARE
IS IT ALL RIGHT TO PROCEED YES
YOU MAY LONG TIME NO TALK
MANAGER YES- WOULD LIKE EVERY
COUPLE OF HOURS THAT'S WHAT I'M
SAYING HOW DO. I WOULD LIKE TO
BEGIN BY AYE THINKING ABOUT HIM
CHAIR- AND YOUR STAFF FOR THE
INCREDIBLE WORK ON THE BILL.
THAT YOU HAVE BEEN I SINCERELY
ENGAGING I'M GRATEFUL. AND I
TRULY WANT TO SAY THANK YOU TO
THE STAFF AS WELL WELL WE HAVE
COURSE WILL BE ACCEPTING THE
COMMITTEE. AS OUTLINED IN THE
ANALYSIS. VENTURE SB TEN SEVENTY
FOUR IT'S GONNA LUMINATE THE
EXISTING WEIGHT BASED CANNABIS
CULTIVATION TAX. IN ROLE THE
GOLDEN STATE'S CANNABIS TAXES
INTO A SINGLE PERCENTAGE BASED
EXCISE TAXES WOULD BE TIME TO
SAIL. THE BILL HAS BEEN A LONG
TIME COMING AS CALIFORNIA HAS A-
STORAGE IN CHALLENGE HISTORY ON
CAMPUS WHICH WE DON'T HAVE TIME
TO GET INTO BUT THE BOTTOM LINE
IS THIS IN TWO THOUSAND SIXTEEN.
CALIFORNIA VOTERS APPROVED PROP
SIXTY FOUR WHICH LEGALIZED
COMMERCIAL DUAL USE CANNABIS FOR
FOLKS OVER THE AGE OF TWENTY
ONE. THE ACT ALLOWS FOR THE
LICENSE. REGULATION OF BOTH
COMMERCIAL ADULT USE IN
MEDICINAL USE CANNABIS
ACTIVITIES- BUT- THE CHALLENGE
WITH PROP SIXTY FOUR IT PUT THE
STATE UNDER SOME RIDICULOUS.
TIME LINES TO BE ABLE TO
IMPLEMENT. THIS IS LITERALLY
MEET MEANT THAT THE STATE HAS TO
BUILD THE PLANE. AS WE ARE
FINDING. A WHILE WE'VE TRIED TO
FIX ALL THE ISSUES WERE PROP
SIXTY FOUR SINCE HIS PASSAGE. OF
ONE OF THE BIGGEST REMAINING
CHALLENGES IS THE TAX STRUCTURE.
THE PRODUCTS A SIXTY FOUR
CONTAIN TO SPECIFIC TO THIS.
ADDRESS THE EXCISE TAX IS WELLS
THE CULTIVATION TAX. AND THE
EXCISE TAX IS AT A SEPT FIFTEEN
PERCENT. OF THE GROSS RECEIPT OF
ANY CANNABIS OR CANNABIS
PRODUCTS. AT THE TIME OF SALE.
THE CULTIVATION TAX IS WEIGHT
BASED ITS CHARGE PER OUNCE ON
HARVESTED CANNABIS. SO CURRENTLY
THE CHALLENGE. WITH THE
CULTIVATION TAXES. IT DOESN'T
ACCOUNT FOR WHEN PRICE OF
CANNABIS. IN PRICES HAVE DROPPED
CONSIDERABLY MORE THAN HALF IN
THE LAST FEW YEARS. IN THE
CULTIVATION TAX PER WEIGHT
REMAINS THE SAME REMAINS FIXED
WHICH IS CAUSING AN ENORMOUS TAX
BURDEN- IN REGARDS TO SMALL
FAMILY GROWERS. IN THIS
SITUATION DOESN'T HAPPEN WITH
THE EXCISE TAX BECAUSE IT'S A
PERCENTAGE OF THE SALES PRICE.
SO CULTIVATION TAXES ARE
CRUSHING SMALL FARMERS
THROUGHOUT THE STATE. THE SMALL
GROWERS HAVE TRIED TO COME INTO
THE REGULATED MARKET THEY'VE
DONE EVERYTHING RIGHT. AS SET UP
IN PROP SIXTY FOUR WELL
COMPETING AGAINST THE BLACK
MARKET. THE BLACK MARKET ISN'T
FOLLOWING THE ENVIRONMENTAL
HEALTH AND SAFETY RULES AS
ESTABLISH PER CALIFORNIA VOTERS.
AND UNLIKE ANY OTHER
AGRICULTURAL CROP IN CALIFORNIA
CANNABIS IS EXTENSIVELY TAX AT
THE FARM HE MATCHING IF WE HAD
TO PAY THIS FOR TOMATOES OR A-
HEAD OF LETTUCE OR CARROTS. THIS
IS CREATING A DOWNWARD TREND OF
CANNABIS FARMERS BECAUSE TEY
SIMPLY CAN'T COMPETE WITH THE
BLACK MARKET IN COMMERCIAL
CANNABIS. THE TAX BURDEN IS
GROWING DISPROPORTIONATELY.
INVEST PRICE COLLAPSE AND IT'S
SIMPLY NOT SUSTAINABLE FOR THE
VAST MAJORITY OF CANNABIS
FARMERS OUT THERE WHO ARE SMALL
FAMILY FARMERS. SB TEN SEP.
EIGHT EXISTING WEIGHT BASE CAMP.
FISHING TAX IN ROLE THE
CANNABIST A STATE CANNABIS TAXES
INTO A SINGLE PERCENTAGE BASE
EXCISE TAX. SO THIS KEEPS IT
ESSENTIALLY WHERE THE- SAID- AT
THE SAME TAX RATE. SB TEN
SEVENTY FOUR ALSO TEMPORARILY
SUSPENDS THE CULTIVATION TAX.
FULLY UNTIL JULY FIRST TO THE
TWENTY. IN TOUCH FOR TWENTY SIX
IF THE LEGISLATURE. MONEY AS PER
OF THE BUDGET PROCESS THE TAX
REDUCTION IS PART OF BUDGET
CONVERSATIONS EVEN AS WE SPEAK
IN ITS ONGOING WITH THE
ADMINISTRATION I DON'T THINK I'M
LETTING THE CAT OF THE BAG IS.
AT THIS IS BEEN ONGOING FOR
WEEKS NOW AND I AM HOPEFUL THAT
A DEAL WILL BE REALIZED IN THE
COMING FEW WEEKS. NOW I WANT TO
CLARIFY THAT A COUPLE OF ITEMS
THAT YOU MAY HAVE HEARD ABOUT
THE BILL WHICH I WILL
CHARACTERIZE IS A BIT OF HOG
WASH. OUT FIRST- THAT I'VE HEARD
SOME SAY THAT IF THERE WILL BILL
PASSES THE STATE IS GOING TO
HAVE TO CUT PROGRAMS SUPPORTED
BY CANNABIS TAXES. THIS IS NOT
TRUE. SO IT IS ALWAYS BEEN OUR
INTENTION TO MAKE SURE THAT
THOSE PROGRAMS WERE NOT
IMPACTED. AND TO MAKE IT SUPER
CLEAR WE'VE AMENDED THE BILL TO
MAKE SURE. THAT ANY REDUCTION IN
TAXES CAN ONLY OCCUR IF THE
LEGISLATURE APPROPRIATES AS PART
OF BUDGET CONVERSATIONS. ABOUT
TO. BEGIN ADMINISTRATION RETURN
GRATEFUL FOR. IS ENGAGING ON THE
SUBJECT EVEN AS WE SPEAK. NOW IF
NO FUNDS ARE APPROPRIATED. THE
CANNABIS TAX INSULT
CONSOLIDATION GOES INTO A
SINGLE. STATE EXCISE TAX WHICH
WOULD BE REVENUE NEUTRAL. AND
THE REASON FOR THAT IS THE
CULTIVATION TAX WOULD GO TO
ZERO. IN THE EXCISE TAX IS
ADJUSTED TO BRING IN THIS EXACT
SAME TAX REVENUE BUT IT TIME TO
SAIL. AT THE RETAIL SIDE. WE
WOULD NOT SEE A REDUCTION IN
TAXES COMING IN CONSUMERS WOULD
NOT BE PAYING MORE IN TAXES THEY
IF WE DON'T SEE THE BACKFILL.
SECOND WE'VE ALSO HEARD A
CONCERN THAT THERE SHOULD BE IN
L. L. A. O. STUDY IMPACTS. I
FOCUS ON THE IMPACTS OF ANY TAX
CHANGE. I WILL BE I AM BIASED.
THERE HAVE BEEN STUDY AFTER DAM
STUDY AFTER STUDY ON CANNABIS
TAXES IN CANNABIS IN THE STATE
OVER THE YEARS IN ON EVERY MAJOR
CANNABIS POLICY. IN CANDIDLY WE
GOT TO IMPLEMENT WITH THE VOTER
SAID WE NEEDED EMPLOYMENT BACK
IN TWO THOUSAND SIXTEEN LASTLY
WE'VE HEARD THAT ANY TAX CHANGES
SHOULD BE TEMPORARILY. AND WHILE
THE BILL OUTLINES A TEMPORARY
FRAMEWORK FOR REDUCING OVERALL
TAX BURDEN I HAVE TO DISAGREE
THAT WE WOULD ONLY TEMPORARY GET
RID OF THE CULTIVATION TAX
FRAMEWORK IF YOU TAKE A LOOK AT
STATES THAT ARE NOW
IMPLEMENTING. A CULTIVATION
TAXES AS WE SEE NOW OVER HALF OF
ALL STATES IN THE UNITED STATES
AMERICA EITHER RECREATIONAL OR
MEDICINAL USE. THEY ARE NOT
LOOKING AT A WEIGHT BASED
CULTIVATION TAX BECAUSE IT
SIMPLY DOESN'T WORK IN IT
CRUSHES A SMALL FAMILY FARMERS.
FINALLY HOW TO SAY THIS. SB TEN
SEVENTY FOUR USES THOSE
RECOMMENDATIONS TO PROPOSE
REVISING CANNABIS TAXES TO A
SINGLE PERCENTAGE BASE EXCISE
TAX. IT SUPPORTED BY RURAL
COUNTIES THROUGHOUT THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA IN NOT A PROP SIXTY
FOUR REQUIRED US TO LITERALLY
BUILD THIS PLANE IS WERE FLYING
IT. AND THAT IS WHY WE'RE
BRINGING THIS FORWARD GIVEN
ENTER THANK YOU SO MUCH WE HAVE.
WITH US TODAY WE HAVE EIGHT
PIECE IS A SMALL FARMER FROM
TRINITY COUNTY IN WITH
SUPERVISOR REX BOHN FROM HUMBLE
COUNTY TO TALK ABOUT THE IMPACTS
THAT WE'VE HAD IN RESPECTFULLY.
ASK FOR IN IBM. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH CENTER. WE WILL NOW MOVE ON
TO THOSE THAT WOULD LIKE TO
TESTIFY. DUE TO CONSTRAINTS
REGARDING THE LENGTH OF THE
HEARING AND TECHNOLOGY
CONSIDERATION. THE CHAIR WILL
INSTITUTE TIME LIMITS ON
TESTIMONY. HE SAID I WILL BE
PERMITTED IN EQUAL AMOUNT OF
TIME- AND WHAT WE TRADITIONALLY
DO HERE IS TWO MINUTES EACH. AND
ALL OTHERS WISHING TO TESTIFY
MUST LIMIT THEIR COMMENTS TO
THEIR NAME AFFILIATION AND
POSITION ON THE MEASURE SO WE'RE
GONNA START WITH THE TWO
IDENTIFIED. LEAD WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT. BOTH WHO ARE ON THE
PHONE AND WE'LL WE'LL START WITH
THEM. THAT THEY'RE TO SO IT
TUMBLED COUNTY SUPERVISOR REX
BOND. AND ADRIN KEYS WHO'S A
SMALL HOME STATE CANNABIS FARMER
FROM TRINITY COUNTY- WILL START
WAS SUPERVISOR BOND. MORNING AT
NPR MEMBERS YOU HEAR ME WE CAN
HEAR YOU FINE. GREAT THANK YOU-
THANK YOU FOR THIS OPPORTUNITY
ALTHOUGH AFTER NOBLE COUNTY- MY
NAME A TRACK PHONE I'M UP TO
SPARK THERMOPLASTIC BY YOUR
NUMBER COUNTY. AND I'M HERE TO
SUPPORT IT AND SEVENTY FOUR ADD
UP AND THEN FILTER MCGUIRE SAID
HE'S BEEN A GREAT PARTNER WITH
THE STUFF YOU'RE ALL THE WAY
THROUGH TWO THOUSAND SIXTEEN. I
TALKED WHEN ASSEMBLY HEARING
AFTER THE PROP ABOUT. THE
APPROVAL AND- PROP FIFTY FOUR
AND IT WAS IT WAS A OUT ASSEMBLY
HEARING ON WHAT WAS GOING TO
HAPPEN FOR COUNTIES. NOW WITH
LEGALIZATION. WELL SIX YEARS
LATER I BY A MILE. UNDER THE
SMALL AND THEN DEPEND AGAIN
FARMERS CURRENTLY FACES RESTIVE
STATE FORCED OUT THE FLIGHT
MARKET. THE FEAR OF PORTABLE
LIGHTER MARKET IS THEY CAN GO IN
THE BLACK. IT'S DUE IN LARGE
PART A CLASS WHOLESALE MARKET
PRICES FOR CANNABIS FLOWER
COMPOUNDED BY LAST WEEK LAST
WEEK FACEBOOK BASIC FACT. WHAT
REPORT REMAINS THE SAME
REGARDLESS OF MARKET CONDITIONS.
BUT LIKE THE FEATHER- ALLUDED
TO. THE CHALLENGES ARE
PARTICULARLY HARD FOR OUTDOOR
CANNABIS FARMERS WHO TYPICALLY
HAVE LOWER YIELDS. AND SELL
PRODUCTS FOR LOWER PRICES. WHAT
MARKET CONDITIONS OF HIGHLIGHTED
HIGHLIGHTED THE INEQUITIES OF
STUFF THE BASIC FACT. MANY THE
CULTIVATION TAX LIMITATIONS-
JERICHO FAR BASED THAT. ON AN
AGRICULTURAL PRODUCTS A SINGLE
WEIGHT FACT AND NOT ACCOUNT. FOR
WIDELY- RIGHT VERY GREAT A
FLOWER WHICH CAN VERY BASED ON
CULTIVATION ABOUT THAT. BUT ALSO
EVEN IN THE CANNABIS. DESPITE A
SINGLE PLANT. MANY OF ALMOST
PULLED THE- A LONG PART OF OUR
BETTER 85% OUR- LIE. EXTEND
THOUSANDS EVEN. OUR HOMESTEAD
PARK ANIMALS DOES NOT THE BILL
AFTER. IF THEIR LIVES. AND IN
TWO THOUSAND. THE APPS AND COME
OUT OF THE STORE IF WE WORK WITH
THEM AND THAT'S WHAT WE'RE
ASKING TODAY. SB KILLED SEVENTY
FOUR WOULD ESTABLISH A MORE
SENSIBLE TAX STRUCTURE. FOR LIKE
THIS CANNABIS THE BOOK PROVIDED
THAT'S A LIFE BY FOR CRAP LIKE
IF YOU FOR DESSERT. CHOSEN TO
STEP FORWARD IN THE LEGAL MARKET
AND REGULATED CANNABIS MARKET
AND A FAIRFAX. WE MAKE A BETTER
CALIFORNIA AND I THANK YOU FOR
THIS TIME. I THANK THAT ARE
REQUIRED RIGHT. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. NEXT WITNESS ADRIN KEYS.
THANK YOU- GOOD MORNING I
APOLOGIZE FOR NOT BEING ABLE TO
BE THERE IN PERSON BUT
MAJESTICALLY FINANCIAL REASONS
ADMITTED THAT A POSSIBLE FORTY
TODAY MY NAME IS ADRIAN KEYS I'M
A LICENSED SMALL OUTDOOR
CULTIVATOR IN TRINITY COUNTY
BEFORE. I AM ALSO THE PRESIDENT
OF THE COUNTY AGRICULTURAL LANDS
AND SERVE AS A REGIONAL CHAIR TO
THE ORIGINS COUNCIL WHICH
REPRESENTS NEARLY NINE HUNDRED
INDEPENDENT SMALL LICENSED
CANNABIS BUSINESSES STATEWIDE.
THE CULTIVATION TAX IS A BURDEN
TOO GREAT TO BEAR FOR MANY OF
CALIFORNIA SMALL CALL TO SLOWLY
GET THE CULTIVATORS AND
EXCESSIVE TAXATION IS DRIVING
FORCE BEHIND. REGULATING SALES.
PROPOSITION FOUR. THAT IT. THE
TRANSITION EXISTING MEDICAL
INDUSTRY INTO. PROVIDE
REASONABLE ACCESS TO REGULARLY
CANNABIS FOR CONSUMERS AND TO
ALLEVIATE THE IMPACTS OF THE AN
UNREGULATED MARKET I SEE NO
EVIDENCE OF THIS HAPPENING IN
FACT ALL AROUND ME WEISS'S
CULTIVATORS RUN THEIR LAST LEGS
WE ARE THE VERY PEOPLE REFER TO
IN PROPOSITION SIXTY FOUR AND
ARE BEING LEFT BEHIND. PRESENTLY
A TREATY COUNTY ONLY ABOUT HALF
OF PREVIOUS LICENSE SITE HAS
SUBMITTED RETOOL FOR THE COUNTY.
HISTORIC LEVEL OF ELITE FIFTEEN
AREAS OF ABOUT THREE THOUSAND
SMALL PRODUCERS WERE REDUCED TO
A HANDFUL OF LICENSEES AND A
THRIVING ON REGULATED MARKETS.
IF NO ACTION TAKEN. FAILED TO
THE REGULATED MARKET WILL
CONTINUE TO DECLINE LICENSE
LEGACY CULTIVATORS WILL CONTINUE
TO LOSE THEIR BUSINESSES AND
THEIR HOMES. AND ILLICIT MARKET
WILL CONTINUE TO DOMINATE.
RESHAPE THE BENEFITS CANNABIS
TAXES PROVIDED. DRUG PREVENTION
AND ENVIRONMENTAL PROGRAMS IN
FACT MY NEIGHBORHOOD IS THE
RECIPIENT OF THE CDFW WATERSHED
ENHANCEMENT GRANT AND I AM
GRATEFUL FOR THAT. PLEASE
SUPPORT THE PERMANENT
ELIMINATION OF THE CULTIVATION
TAX. AND OVERALL KILLER THIS TAX
REDUCTION AND THE LEGISLATION
LEGISLATIVE APPROPRIATIONS TO
BACK FILL TAX REVENUE LOSSES TO
THESE BENEFICIAL AND EFFECTIVE
PROGRAMS. THE CULT OF THE FLAT
RATE CULTIVATION TAX STRUCTURES
DOES NOT WORK FOR AGRICULTURAL
PRODUCTS. DROP IN THE VALUE OF A
WHOLESALE POUND OF CANNABIS FROM
ONE THOUSAND DOLLARS IN TWENTY
TWENTY ONE TO THREE HUNDRED AND
TWENTY TWENTY TWO WITH A HUNDRED
SIXTY DOLLARS WITHOUT GOING
TOWARDS THE CULTIVATION TAX. IS
A RECIPE FOR FARMERS GOING OUT
OF BUSINESS WHICH IS WHAT IS
HAPPENING TO SMALL HOSTED
FARMERS ALL OVER THE STATE RIGHT
NOW. THE BEST WAY TO GENERATE
TAX REVENUE IS TO INCREASE
CONSUMER PARTICIPATION. AND
PRESENTLY LESS THAN HALF THE
CANNABIS CONSUMING CALIFORNIA'S
PURCHASED IN THE REGULATED
SYSTEM. LEAVING A FAST ON TOUCH
POOL OF POTENTIAL TAX REVENUE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR YOUR
TIME I APPRECIATE IT VERY MUCH.
THANK YOU THANK YOU BOTHFOR
YOUR TESTIMONY HERE TODAY
APPRECIATE YOU CALLING IN- AND
THIS WORKS- IT'S A WAY TO BE
ABLE TO PARTICIPATE IN A
DEMOCRACY EVEN THOUGH YOU'RE-
YOU'RE WAY FAR. THE BILL IN ROOM
TWENTY ONE HUNDRED ENCOURAGE YOU
TO PLEASE COME FORWARD MADAM
CHAIR THE MEMBERS POPULAR HERE
TODAY ON BEHALF AND THAT NEVADA
COUNTY BOARD OF SUPERVISORS IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
LYNSEY ROBINSON WITH THE
CALIFORNIA CANNABIS INDUSTRY
ASSOCIATION AND ON BEHALF OF OUR
FOUR HUNDRED MEMBERS WE SUPPORT
THIS BILL IN CONCEPT AND THANK
THE AUTHOR FOR HIS LEADERSHIP.
THANK YOU. BRECKLAND THIRTY WITH
APEX GROUP ON BEHALF HERE RELIEF
AND SO FORTH. THANK YOU. I'M
SURE MEMBERS RANDY MARTIN ON
BEHALF OF THE PARENT COMPANY IN
SUPPORT IF THE BILL IS AMENDED
TO NOT DRIVE MORE CONSUMERS INTO
THE LOOK ILLEGAL MARKET BY
RAISING THE EXCISE TAX. THANK
YOU THANK YOU VERY MUCH. GOOD
MORNING AMY JENKINS ON BEHALF OF
SPARK AND CAN ACROSS BOTH CINEMA
COUNTY BASED COMPANIES
SUPPORTING CONCEPT. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. SEEING NO OTHER
INDIVIDUALS THAT WISH TO TESTIFY
IN THE ROOM WE'RE GOING TO MOVE
ON TO THE TELECONFERENCE LINE
MISTER MODERATOR IF YOU COULD
PLEASE QUEUE UP THOSE THAT WISH
TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF SB TEN
SEVENTY FOUR. THANK YOU. LAYS
DOWN ON THE PHONE LINES IF YOU
WISH TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT TO
FOR SB TEN SEVENTY FOUR PLEASE
PRESS ONE FOLLOWED BY ZERO TWO.
ONE FILED BY ZERO AND WILL BEGIN
WITH LINE SEVENTY FOUR YOU ARE
OPEN. SEVENTY FOUR. PLEASE GO
AHEAD SEVENTY FOUR. BUT IT TO
CONSULT IF YOU'LL GO TO LINE
EIGHTY PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
MORNING MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS
JASON BRYANT ON BEHALF OF THE
CANNABIS DISTRIBUTION
SUBSTATIONS WERE IN SUPPORT OF
THE BILL THANK YOU. WHY EIGHTY
FIVE PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
MORNING MADAM CHAIR MARK SMITH
ON BEHALF OF ORIGINS COUNCIL
WHICH REPRESENTS THE LEGACY
REGION'S UP TRINITY WHO YOU JUST
HEARD FROM. MENDOCINO SONOMA
NEVADA COUNTIES AND THE BIG SUR
REGION OF MODERATE IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF THE BILL THANK CENTER
MCGUIRE WHO BRING YOU BESTIVAL.
THANK YOU NINE SEVENTY NINE.
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO NARDELLA
BACH ON BEHALF OF BERKELEY
PATIENTS GROUP SUPPORT AMENDED
TO DECREASE THE EXCISE TAX THAT
THE CONSUMER IS ALSO GIVEN TAX
RELIEF. MY FOURTEEN YOUR- YES
ENDS BURKE WE MY PARTNER
CHOOSING HAVE BEEN WE ARE-
BECAUSE CALLED ME AND TO HELP-
LOVINGLY IN. AND PROUD MY OF-
YOU DON'T OR- FOR THAT MATTER
THANK YOU SIR NEXT. THANK YOU
WILL GO- CAN YOUR. YEAH THIS IS
BUSH A BUSH FAMILY WERE AFTER MY
ALL. VETERAN OWNED SOFTWARE DOES
FARMING MENDOCINO COUNTY AND WE
HAVE THE BILL. THANK YOU. AND
WE'LL GO TO LINE TWO YOUR- HI MY
NAME IS VENTURE. HI MY THE PRESS
OF THE HOUSE FORMER GRAIN-
CALIFORNIA STATE GRANGE YOU WERE
AND CAL STATE GRANGE AG. ON I
MEAN SUPPORT OF THIS THANK YOU
VERY MUCH THANK YOU. AND WE WILL
GO TO YOUR OPEN. HI HI ALEXA
WALL OWNER OF THE CALIFORNIA
FARM TO TEN THOUSAND FEET SMALL
OUTDOOR SONOMA COUNTY AND
PRESENT A OF THE MECHANIC WORK
ON MY AND WE ARE IN. THANK YOU
THANK YOU. NEXT PLEASE. THANK
YOU ALL EIGHTY ONE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. YEAH I AMERICA'S GOT
RATHER FOR WE CALL. IT ABOUT A
COUNTY WOULD YELL THE WORD L. L.
P. REMEMBERS THAT ABOUT A COUNTY
CANNABIS ALLIANCE AND RESULTS
THEIR OF THE ORIGIN COUNCIL WE
TRONGLY SUPPORT THIS BILL.
THANK YOU. I TWENTY FIVE PLEASE
GO AHEAD. HI MY NAME IS DEVIN
OKEAN IN TREATY COUNTY MY
LICENSED FARMER IN ASSOCIATED
WITH PC EIGHT EIGHT AND I
SUPPORT THIS BILL. THANK YOU.
FIVE EIGHTY SEVEN IT'S GOING.
GOOD MORNING BEAUTIFUL TRINITY
COUNTY I AM A SMALL LICENSED
CULTIVATOR AND A BOARD MEMBER OF
THE TRINITY COUNTY AGRICULTURAL
ALLIANCE AND I SUPPORT THIS%
BILL. THANK YOU. TWENTY
SEVENTEEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI MY
NAME IS DREW BARBER- WHEN
OPERATOR THE SNOW CREEK FARMS
AND CO FOUNDER OF UP WITH
CANNABIS COOPERATIVE I SUPPORT
THIS BILL. THANK YOU. FINAL
REMINDER YOU WOULD LIKE TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT TO S. B. ONE
ZERO SEVEN FOUR PLEASE PRESS ONE
ZERO AT THIS TIME AND LINE
THIRTY THREE YOUR UP. I THIRTY
THREE PLEASE GO AHEAD. THIRTY
THREE ARE YOU MUTED. I'M NOT
SURE IF I'M IF I GET YOUR POINT
THIRTY THREE OKAY MY NAME IS
PATRICIA ROCKWELL ANNA MY
FOUNDER PREVIOUS GARDENS A SMALL
FAMILY OWNED CANNABIS FARM IN
NEVADA COUNTY BOTH A MEMBER OF
THE NEVADA COUNTY FIVE FIVE
CANDIDATES ALLIANCE AND WE
SUPPORT SB TEN SEVENTY FOUR.
THANK YOU. NEXT PLEASE. ONE
NINETY YOUR OPEN. GOOD MORNING
THIS IS ROSE MOBERLY WITH
HUCKLEBERRY HILL FARMS AND- JOHN
KASAULI WITH HUCKLEBERRY HILL
FARMS IN SOUTHERN HUMBOLDT AND
WE SUPPORT THE SPELL THANK YOU.
THANK YOU NEXT PLEASE FIND THANK
YOU MEDICARE FORTY SEVEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. FORTY SEVEN YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. FORTY SEVEN WOULD YOU
LIKE A FIGHT- MOVING ONLINE
NINETY SIX. DARREN'S STORY WITH
COASTAL SUNFARMS. WE ARE IN
SUPPORT OF THE BILL AS AMENDED
THANK YOU. THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR
WE HAVE EXACTLY THE QUEUE VERY
GOOD WE'RE GONNA MOVE ON TO
THOSE IN OPPOSITION WE HAVE ONE
LEAD OPPOSITION WITH WITNESS LEN
SILVER WHO'S FROM THE PUBLIC
HEALTH INSTITUTE AND SHE'S ON
THE PHONE. WELCOME THANK.
MORNING THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR
CAN YOU HEAR ME. WE CAN HEAR YOU
. THAT DOCUMENT OVER
PEDIATRICIANS AND PUBLIC HEALTH
INSTITUTE ALSO A MEMBER OF THE
PROPOSITION SIXTY FOUR BY YOUR
GROUP. TO THE DEPARTMENT OF
HEALTH CARE SERVICES BOB. SB TEN
SEVENTY FOUR IS WELL INTENTIONED
BUT I'M WHY. Y. WE APPRECIATE
SENATOR MCGUIRE'S AMENDMENTS TO
ASSURE THAT THEY ARE NOT CUTS TO
SERVICES TO CHILDREN AND YOUTH.
THIS BILL WILL NOT SOLVE THE
PROBLEM THAT EXPLAINS TO
ADDRESS. LIKE A TAX CUT
BENEFITING LOCAL. IN REDUCING
THE EXCISE TAX WILL NOT SOLVE
THE PROBLEM OF ILLICIT MARKET
DRIVEN BY A LOT OF OVER
PRODUCTION MUCH BEEN EXPORTED.
INDEED THEY MAY EXACERBATE OVER
PRODUCTION. I TARGETED BREAKS
FOR EQUITY LICENSEES ARE SMALL
PRODUCERS MAY MAKE SENSE THIS
DOES NOT. SECOND BECAUSE IT ROBS
PETER TO PAY PAUL BUT SHORTENED
VERSION OF GENERAL FUND FOR AT
LEAST THREE YEARS TO SUBSIDIZE
CANNABIS INDUSTRY PROFITS. OTHER
PERSON SOCIAL NEEDS MANY
AFFECTING CHILDREN IN USE AND
FALL OUT OF THE PANDEMIC WILL.
FAIL TO BE MET. THIRD BECAUSE
LOWERING. TAXES WILL IN HARM
USED YOUNG AT THE- THIS IS NOT
BETTER WE HAVE ALREADY SEEN HER
OF HARMFUL BILL USE FOR IN BASED
. INCREASES IN USE DURING. AND
KIND OF THE SUPPOSED THAT YOU'RE
VISITS ROSE 23% IN JUST THREE
YEARS. SHORT YOU CAN SEVENTY
FOUR VIOLATE THE PUB TRUST. WITH
PROPERTY SIXTY FOUR PACK WITH
FIELD WITH THE- THAT PRACTICE
NOT RESPECTED. LEGAL NOW SHOULD
BY MICHAEL CULLEN CHU NORTH
RIDGE. PUBLIC LAW FOR. BETWEEN
CONCLUDED THAT. ONE OF THE KIND
TAX REGIME ARE ADMIT CRY TO
TWENTY TWENTY EIGHT. AND THAT
THE PROPOSED MODIFICATIONS ARE
INCONSISTENT WITH THE INTENT AND. PURPOSE TO PROPOSITION SIXTY
FOUR. STARTED OUR OWN NIH FUNDED
RESEARCH SHOWS THAT TODAY 60% OF
CALIFORNIA RESIDENTS LIVE IN
JURISDICTIONS THAT ALLOW SOME
FORM O LEGAL RETAIL SALES LEGAL
ADULT USE SALES HAVE NOT FALLEN
THEY HAVE RISEN STEADILY BY TWO
HUNDRED FORTY NINE PERCENT. TO
TWENTY EIGHTEEN AND EIGHTEEN
FOUR HUNDRED FIFTY TWO MILLION
DOLLARS JUST LAST MONTH. IF THE
SPICES TAX CHANGES IN BANDS THEY
SHOULD AT A MINIMUM BE REVENUE
NEUTRAL FROM DAY ONE. MAINTAIN
FUNDING FOR THE REQUIRED
DEDICATIONS WITHOUT READING THE
GENERAL FUND AND REDUCE HARM BY
TAXING BY PHD AS NEW YORK AND
CONNECTICUT ARE DOING AND AS OUR
LEGISLATIVE ANALYST PROPOSED AS
THE SENATORS BOOKER AND
WIDENING- AND SCHUMER. FEDERALLY
INSURED THIS BILL IS AN
INADMISSIBLE AMENDMENT TO
PROPOSITION. BEFORE OUR STATE
AND OUR TO OF OUR NEEDED. TO
SUBSIDIZE THE CAN IN THE- WHAT
WE ASK FOR YOUR NAME VOTE ON
THIS TO TRY TWO WRIST THOSE. OF
REVENUE. IF YOU UP PERCENT
CHANGES IN THE MACHINE. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. THANK YOU. WE'RE
GONNA NOW MOVE ON TO OPPOSITION
. TESTIMONY IN ROOM TWENTY ONE
HUNDRED IS THERE ANYONE WHO
WOULD LIKE TO COME FORWARD AND-
REGISTER YOUR OPPOSITION. GOOD
MORNING CENTERS MY NAME IS CHLOE
FERGUSON PRESENT FOR THE NOT A
CORE ALLIANCE LOCAL EQUITY
NONPROFIT HERE IN SACRAMENTO WE
OPPOSE THIS BILL. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. HELLO MY NAME IS KEVIN
HOOKS- SOCIAL EQUITY OPERATOR
HERE IN SACRAMENTO AND BECAUSE
IT DOESN'T TAKE A HOLISTIC
APPROACH TO THE PROBLEMS I
OPPOSE IT. THANK YOU. GOOD
MORNING SENATORS MY NAME IS TODD
ALLEN AYE AND THE LEGISLATIVE
CHAIR FOR THE LEGISLATIVE.
COMMITTEE ON THE BLACK CAUCUS
AND WE OPPOSE THIS BILL. GOOD
MORNING SENATORS MY NAME IS
BRANDON BOLDEN THE MUSCLE SO
EQUITY ENTREPRENEUR IN RETAIL
OPERATOR BASED OUT OF SACRAMENTO
AND OPPOSE THIS BILL. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH IS THERE ANYONE ELSE-
IN ROOM TWENTY ONE HUNDRED THING
NO ONE WE'RE GOING TO MOVE ON TO
THE TELECONFERENCE LINE IF YOU
COULD QUEUE UP THOSE INDIVIDUALS
WHO WOULD LIKE TO TEST TEST
FIGHT IN OPPOSITION SB. TEN
SEVENTY FOUR THAT WOULD BE
TERRIFIC. THERE IS A BILL THAT
YOU WOULD LIKE THAT THAT'S THE
BY AN OPPOSITION TO S. B. ONE
ZERO SEVEN FOUR PLEASE PRESS ONE
ZERO AT THIS TIME. ONE FILED BY
ZERO. AND WE WILL GO TO A- LINE
FORTY OF YOUR OFFICE. THANK YOU
OUT WIMMERA THE HALF OF. PRODUCT
THE DAY THE NATURE CONSERVANCY
CALIFORNIA TROUT. CALIFORNIA
PLANT SOCIETY DEFENDERS OF
WILDLIFE THE CROP PROJECT. MORE
IMPOSE MUCH MEDITATION- I'LL
MAKE THIS QUICK BECAUSE IF.
ANYONE ELSE AKHTAR POINT. I'M
SORRY BUT WE'VE ALREADY- TAKEN
THE. LEAD WITNESS AND IN
OPPOSITION. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
IF IT HAPPEN. NEXT PLEASE
MEDICARE NOBODY ELSE WILL QUEUE
UP. VERY GOOD WILL BRING THE
DISCUSSION BACK TO THE COMMITTEE
CENTER WIENER WITH I. THANK YOU
. THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR AND I
WANT TO THANK THE AUTHOR FOR
HIS- FOCUS AND LEADERSHIP ON
THIS ISSUE- WE ARE- AS CENTER
ABOUT SAID BUILDING PLAN WHILE
FLYING ADAM THAT DEFINITELY DID
HAPPEN AND- YOU KNOW THE INTENT
OF THE VOTERS- ON MULTIPLE
OCCASIONS BACK IN THE NINETIES
NINE TWENTY SIXTEEN WAS TO STOP
CRIMINALIZING CANNABIS. AND THEN
TO HAVE LEGAL AND REGULATED AND
SAFE MARKET SO THAT PEOPLE CAN.
PURCHASE CANNABIS- BE CONFIDENT
THAT THE PRODUCT IS SAFE- AND
HAVE ACCESS TO IT UNFORTUNATELY
AND UNINTENTIONAL. THAT THE
VARIOUS ASPECTS OF OUR
LEGALIZATION- BOTH ALLOWING
CITIES TO BAN CANNABIS CELLS SO
THAT ALMOST TWO THIRDS OF CITIES
CATEGORICALLY BANNED CANNABIS
ALSO IT'S QUOTE UNQUOTE LEGAL
BUT YOU CAN'T LEGALLY BUY IT
ANYWHERE. AND THEN IMPOSING 25%
AND STATE TAXES AND THEN
WHATEVER LOCALS DECIDE TO DO SO
THIRTY THIRTY FIVE PERCENT. HAS
MADE TEN OF US NOT JUST HARD TO
ACCESS BUT HAS MADE IT VERY
EXPENSIVE. TO PURCHASING LEGAL
CANNABIS IS WAY TOO EXPENSIVE-
SO IF YOU- LOW INCOME- YOUR GOOD
LUCK TRYING TO FIND LEGAL
CANNABIS THAT YOU CAN AFFORD IT
SO NO WONDER THE ILLICIT MARKET
IS ABSOLUTELY THRIVING. IN
CALIFORNIA WE ARE STRANGLING THE
LEGAL MARKET- WITH TAXES WITH
WITH WITH SOME OF THE REGULATION
AND WITH THE- BROAD BANDS-
THROUGHOUT CALIFORNIA WAS
STRANGLED IN THE LEGAL MARKET-
AND WE NEED TO STOP DOING THAT.
ZACKS RELIEF IS PART OF THAT AND
I SAY THAT AS A PROGRESSIVE
DEMOCRAT WHO- YOU KNOW BELIEVES
THAT YOUR TAXES ARE REALLY
IMPORTANT FUNDING GOVERNMENT-
BUT WE WENT TOO FAR HERE AND SO-
THERE ARE VARIOUS BILLS ONE OF
MINE WILL BE HEARD. LATER TODAY
TO TRY TO PROVIDE- TAX RELIEF TO
THOSE INDUSTRIES THAT WE STILL
HAVE. WE TAXES ARE IMPORTANT IN
THE CANNABIS INDUSTRY BUT WE ARE
WITH OVER DONE IT WITH OVERSIGHT
AND WE NEED TO TAKE. A DEEP
BREATH AND RESTRUCTURE HOW WE
TAX CANNABIS- AND SO I'M GOING
TO SUPPORT THIS BILL TODAY I
ASSUMING THIS IS ALL GOING TO
RESULT IN THE BUDGET. WITH ALL
OF OUR VARIOUS- BILLS AND I LOOK
FORWARD TO BEING PART OF THAT
CONVERSATION- AND I'LL MOVE THIS
BILL FORWARD I WILL SAY THAT I%
AM SUPPORTIVE OF WHAT THE
AUTHORS TRYING TO BUT STILL
TRYING TO THE CULTIVATION. TAX I
WILL BE VERY CLEAR I DO NOT
SUPPORT INCREASING THE EXCISE
TAX- BUT I WAS IN THE AUTHORS
DOING THAT. TRY TO MAKE IT
REVENUE NEUTRAL AND NOT OR SOME
DIFFERENT TEMPTATIONS. PROP
SIXTY FOUR AND WE CAN AND CAN'T
DO. ABOUT ON THE CRIED DO NOT
SUPPORT RAISING EXCISE TAX OF
MEL B. HARMFUL. TO RETAILERS IN
PLACES LIKE SAN FRANCISCO- AND
YOU COULD END UP. REALLY MAKING
A PROBLEM IN SOME WAYS WORSE IN
TERMS OF TRYING TO REDUCE THE
COST OF RETAIL CANNABIS OF THE
STOP GOING WAS A MARKET. SO THIS
IS PART OF THE CONVERSATION I'LL
BE SUPPORTING THIS TODAY- BUT I
DID WANT TO JUST PUT ON THE
RECORD THAT I'M ABSOLUTELY
OPPOSED TO INCREASING. THE
EXCISE TAX. I'M HAPPY TO MOVE
THE- MOTIONS BEEN MADE A SENATOR
WIENER CENTER RAZA THANK YOU. I
KNOW THE AUTHOR WORKS REALLY
REALLY HARD AT WHAT YOU DECIDE
TO JUMP INTO SO I REALLY
APPRECIATE NOT BEING IN THE
MIDDLE OF THAT DEBATE AND THOSE
KINDS OF- BILLS AND LEGISLATION
I COUNT ON YOU DEPEND ON YOU A
LOT YOU HAVE ENORMOUS
CREDIBILITY- JUST SOMETHING
THAT- SENATOR WINNER JUST
MENTIONED WHICH I WAS GOING TO
ASK. IS WHAT DO ALL THESE BILLS
. IN THE COMING TOGETHER. AWARE
ARE THEIR DIFFERENCES THAT NEED
STILL NEED TO BE RESOLVED I KNOW
THERE'S ONE ABOUT- REDUCING THE
EXCISE TAX FROM FIFTEEN TO FIVE
PERCENT. HOW DO THEY ALL FIT
INTO JUST. YOU KNOW IN YOUR
OPINION WE JUST APPROVED THE
MALL AND THEN LEAVE IT UP TO
SOME YOU KNOW SOME OF THE GROUP
TO ADDRESS IT- IS A LEGAL ISSUE
COULD YOU JUST DESCRIBE THAT
MORE BECAUSE WE DO HAVE A NUMBER
OF BILLS TODAY ON. THANK YOU SO
MUCH WHEN SENATOR AND- IF IT'S
THROUGH THE CHAIR- YEAH SO. LOOK
I THINK BIG PICTURE ON A LOT OF
THE ISSUES IN REGARDS TO REVENUE
IN TAXES IT'S GOING TO BE
RESOLVED IN THE BUDGET. SO THERE
HAVE BEEN AND WILL CONTINUE TO
BE ON GOING DISCUSSIONS BETWEEN.
THE AUTHORS OF THESE INDIVIDUAL
BILLS. ESPECIALLY FOCUS ON
REVENUE IN TAXES. IN THE
ADMINISTRATION. I THINK A LOT OF
THIS IS GOING TO NEED TO BE
RESOLVED WITH IN THE BUDGET. AND
THAT'S WHERE IT WOULD BELONG. ON
THE BIG PICTURE OF TAXES AND I'M
GONNA GIVE YOU MY OWN EDITORIAL
I THINK EVENTUALLY WE'RE GONNA
NEED TO BE ABLE TO GO BACK WHEN
I SAY WE EAT THE STATE TO BE
ABLE TO. GO BACK TO THE VOTERS
SO WHAT WE SEEN IN EARLY ADOPTER
STATES ACROSS THIS NATION WHO
HAVE LEGALIZED RECREATIONAL
CANNABIS I'M GONNA USE OF THE
TERM THAT CENTER WIENER. I SAID
IS THEY OVERSHOT ON TAXES ON TO
HIGH SO WE HAVE. SOME IN THE
OPPOSITION YOU HEARD TODAY SAID
THAT THERE IS- THE CHALLENGES
DON'T EXIST I WELCOME. THE
OPPOSITION TO COME TO THE NORTH
COAST. THE VAST MAJORITY ARE
SMALL FAMILY FARMERS THEY'VE
LITERALLY BEEN FARMING CANNABIS
FOR DECADES LONGER THAN I'VE
BEEN ALIVE. AND THEY ARE DYING
ON THE VINE. WE HAVE A MAJOR
ISSUE WHEN IT COMES TO THE ISSUE
CULTIVATION BUT ULTIMATELY
AMOUNT OF CENTER WE'RE GOING TO
NEED TO BE ABLE TO- WORK THIS
OUT IN THE BUDGET. AND THEN I
THINK A BIG PICTURE WE MAY NEED
TO GO BACK TO THE VOTERS HERE AS
THE INDUSTRY MATURES. THAT'S WHY
I THINK WE'RE GONNA NEED TO BE A
CAUGHT MY OWN EDITORIAL LONG
TERM. SENATOR NELSON. THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR. I'M A FAN OF THE
AUTHOR. IN THE AREA THAT HE
REPRESENTS PARTICULARLY BECAUSE
I REPRESENTED A GOOD PORTION OF
IT MYSELF. I'VE NOT BEEN A FAN
OF CANNABIS IN FACT IN THE
EIGHTIES- AUTHORED THE CAMP
PROGRAM TO STAMP OUT MARIJUANA.
THE TRAIN'S LEFT THE STATION.
WHAT HAS NOT LEFT THE STATION IS
THAT BLACK MARKET THAT INSIDIOUS
BLACK MARKET. VERY DANGEROUS
BLACK MARKET. AND I DO HAVE
SYMPATHY FOR THOSE WHO ARE
LEGITIMATELY TRY. STRIVING. TO
GROW THE MARKET MARIJUANA. THEN
I STIPULATE THE MERIT OF. THE
USE OF MARIJUANA FOR CERTAIN
PURPOSES. SO WITH KIND OF
SETTING ASIDE MY HISTORIC IN THE
BIASES I BELIEVE THAT THIS IS A
GOOD STEP FORWARD FOR THE TIMES
THAT WE ARE EXPERIENCING NOW I
THANK THE AUTHOR AND I WILL
SUPPORTERS GO. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH- I AM I WANT AGREE WITH MY
WITH MY COLLEAGUES I THINK THIS
IS- TO TAX. CULTIVATION DOESN'T
MAKE ANY SENSE- BUT- WE ARE
BUILDING THIS AIRPLANE AS AS WE
FLY IT AND THAT'S THE DIFFICULTY
AND I DO THINK WE'RE PROBABLY
GONNA HAVE TO GO BACK TO THE
VOTERS AND ASK THEM FOR
PERMISSION TO CHANGE SOME OF
THE- ELEMENTS OF. THE ORIGINAL-
OF THE ORIGINAL- PROPOSITION I
IT'S PART OF THE PROBLEM WITH
PROPOSITIONS IS THAT ONCE YOU
GET IT. ONCE YOU PUT IT DOWN ON
PAPER. IF THE REALITY CHANGES-
AND SOCIETY CHANGES YOU GOT TO
GO BACK TO THE VOTERS AND YOU'RE
SO YOU'RE STUCK WITH THE DETAILS
AND SO. WE'RE LEARNING AND I
THINK- BECOMING A LITTLE BIT
WISER AND DOES THIS MAKE SENSE
AND I APPRECIATE THAT THIS IS
GOING TO GET TAKEN CARE OF IN
THE BUDGET AND- YOUR FOCUS ON.
MOVING AWAY FROM TAXATION AT THE
POINT OF- AT THE END OF A
CULTIVATION SEASON MAKES A LOT
OF SENSE TO ME SO MANY SUPPORT
THIS TODAY AND I LOOK FORWARD TO
SEEING MORE WORK ON IT CLEARLY
MORE WORK NEEDS TO BE DONE SO WE
DO HAVE A MOTION BY SENATOR
WIENER DO PASS AS AMENDED BUT
FIRST AMEND AND RE REFER TO THE
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS.
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. NO EXCUSE
ME OUTLET YOU'VE CLOSE MY
APOLOGY OUR CENTER IS GOING TO
SAY THANK YOU SO MUCH- WE HEARD
FOLKS WHO ARE RIGHTFUL CONCERNS
REGARDS TO. EQUITY WHO CAME HERE
TODAY- IN REALLY GRATEFUL FOR
THE FEEDBACK I DO THINK THAT
THERE WILL ALSO. BE A
SIGNIFICANT DISCUSSION THE
BUDGET AS WELL. IN REFER FOR
THEIR FEEDBACK IS THERE RIGHT
THAT NEED TO BE A FOCUS AREA. OF
THE STATE NO LASTING OF THE SAY
IS. THE STATE IS NOW STARTED
FINDING. OUT WHERE- PRICE YOUR
NIELSEN WAS JUST DISCUSSING-
THERE'S ONE POINT FIVE MILLION
FOR HIGH IMPACT- CANNABIS
COUNTIES. ONE POINT FIVE MILLION
FOR LAW ENFORCEMENT TO START
FOCUSING ON UNLICENSED- LARGE
SCALE FARMERS. WHO ARE IMPACTING
WATERSHEDS ENDANGERED SPECIES
BECAUSE THERE IS NO SILVER
BULLET IN THIS ISSUE WE HAVE TO
HAVE MULTIPLE TOOLS ON THE
BALLOT. AND THAT'S WHAT. INTO
WHAT VICE CHAIR WE HAVE TO START
INTO LARGE. AND ADDRESS SUCH
WELL THANK YOU TO RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR AN IPHONE THANK YOU LATE
LATE ENTRY INTO THIS. JUST A
POINT PERSON PROVISIONAL IT'S
MY- RECOLLECTION IS COMMITTEE
THAT. ANYTIME THAT A FORMER
CHAIR COMES TO PRESENT A BILL
THAT WE- ALL WAS VOTED DOWN JUST
ARE THERE OR JUST. THE UNIT TO
BE HAD. OKAY IN THIS NOBODY TELL
ME ABOUT THAT TODAY. KNOWN AND
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL- THE MOTION
IS TO PASS AS AMENDED THE FIRST
AMENDED AND RE REFER TO THE
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS
SENATORS CAPITO I GOT THE AUTO
HI NIELSEN HI NIELSEN HI DURAZO.
TERRAZZO HI HERTZBERG AYE
HERTZBERG BY WIENER. WIENER HI
THANK YOU SO MUCH RECUPERO THE
BILL IS OUT FIVE ZERO. ONE NO
ANDREA DID YOU SO- WE DO. CENTER
GROVE. WELCOME EUROPE ON S. B.
ELEVEN FIFTY SIX. THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR I AM I AM HONORED TO
PRESENT SB ELEVEN FIFTY SIX ALL
OF OUR CONSTITUENTSWE KNOW ARE
HURTING RIGHT NOW FROM THE HIGH
COST OF GASOLINE COLLEAGUES IN
THE INFLATION RATE IS THE
HIGHEST IT'S BEEN IN FORTY YEARS
AS OF APRIL TWENTY NINTH YEAH
AUSTIN GASOLINE IN CALIFORNIA
HAS JUMPED TO FIVE DOLLARS AND
SEVENTY CENTS A GALLON ON
AVERAGE. COMPARED TO THE
NATIONAL AVERAGE OF FOUR DOLLARS
AND FIFTEEN CENTS PER GALLON
THAT'S A DIFFERENCE OF A DOLLAR
FIFTY FIVE PER GALLON FOR WATER
CONSTITUENTS FOR POINT WHERE
PAIN JUST LAST YEAR. WELL THIS
IS NOTHING NEW FOR CALIFORNIANS
TO BE THE HIGHEST GAS TAX PRICES
IN THE NATION CAN IT STILL.
PANDEMIC SIMPLY CANNOT CONTINUE
TO SUPPORT THE TAX THE GAS TAX
IMPOSED BY CALIFORNIA'S
GOVERNMENT. EVEN THOUGH MANY ARE
STRUGGLING TO MAKE IT THROUGH
THE MONTH ON JULY FIRST OF THIS
YEAR JUST A FEW MONTHS FROM NOW
THE GAS TAX WILL GO EVEN HIGHER-
IT'LL BE AN INCREASE ON THE
GASOLINE EXCISE TAX OF FIVE
POINT SIX PERCENT. THAT'S AN
ADDITIONAL TAX INCREASE ON GAS
FOR FIVE AT FIVE POINT 6% WELL
JUST BECAUSE A MORE DETRIMENTAL
TO FAMILIES NEEDING TO PUT FUEL
IN THEIR CAR TO GO TO WORK. LIKE
THAT. CURRENTLY REQUIRES.
DEPARTMENT AND FEE
ADMINISTRATION TO ANNUALLY
ADJUST THIS TAX ON GASOLINE AND
DIESEL FUEL BASED ON THE
CALIFORNIA CONSUMER PRICE INDEX.
TO THE GVERNOR'S CREDIT THIS
PAST YEAR HE IDENTIFIED THIS
INFLAMMATORY- THIS INFLATIONARY
PRESSURE AS A PROBLEM IN THE
JANUARY BUDGET IN HE PROPOSED A
ONE YEAR SUSPENSION OF THE GAS
INCREASE. UNFORTUNATELY THE
DEADLINE TO STOP THE ADJUSTMENT
JUST PASSED THIS SEND. OUR
CONSTITUENTS TO BE WONDERING WHY
THIS LEGISLATURE WOULD ALLOW
TAXES TO BE INCREASED ON
GASOLINE WHEN THE PRICE PER
GALLON RECENTLY RE REACH
HISTORICAL HEIGHTS. WE NOW KNOW
THAT THIS YEAR'S INCREASE WHAT
IF THIS YEAR'S INCREASE LOOKS
LIKE BUT NEXT YEAR IT COULD BE
EVEN WORSE IN MARCH IN THE
INFLATION RATE WAS EIGHT POINT
FIVE PER CENT CALLS THAT'S THE
HIGHEST IT'S BEEN SINCE NINETEEN
EIGHTY ONE. IF PLACE IN STAYS
HIGH OUR CONSTITUENTS WILL FACE
ANOTHER INFLATIONARY INCREASE
NEXT YEAR I AGREE WITH THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL TO SUSPEND
THE DEBT GAS TAX INCREASE BUT I
DO BELIEVE THE PUBLIC WANTS US
TO TAKE A STEP FURTHER. AND GIVE
THEM THE REAL HELP THAT THEY
NEED AT THE GAS PUMP. SB ELEVEN
FIFTY SIX WILL STOP THE GAS TAX
AND- BY PERMANENTLY ENDING THE
ANNUAL INFLATION ADJUSTMENTS IN
BOTH THE GASOLINE TAX IN THE
DIESEL FUEL EXCISE TAX. THIS IS
THE ONLY LEGISLATIVE PROPOSAL TO
OFFER A PERMANENT HELP FOR THE
TAXPAYERS AT THE PUMP. AND WHO
DESPERATELY NEED IT. SB ELEVEN
FIFTY SIX IS MUCH NEEDED TO STEP
TO BE IN A MUCH NEED TO STEP TO
PROTECT FAMILIES FROM THE
GROWING PRICE OF GASOLINE AND I
RESPECTFULLY URGE AN AYE VOTE.
WITH ME TODAY TO TESTIFY ON THE
PHONE IS THE MAYOR OF TAFT A
SMALL BUSINESS OWNER AND SOMEONE
WHO WORKS IN THE OIL AND GAS
INDUSTRY. AND HE'S JUST AN
INCREDIBLE INDIVIDUAL THAT
REALLY CARES ABOUT PEOPLE OR
SOME OF THE POOREST PEOPLE IN
OUR COMMUNITY. DAVE NOR. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH- HE ADDED M. THE
MAYOR DO- IT NOR- ARE YOU ON THE
PHONE. YES MADAM CHAIRMAN OF THE
FLOOR IS YOURS. THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR ALTHOUGH THE IDEA BEHIND
AUTOMATICALLY INCREASING EXCISE
TAX ON GAS AND DIESEL BASED ON
THE CPI IS LIKE A GOOD IDEA. IN
REALITY IT SERVES THE INCREASE
THE TAX BURDEN ON CALIFORNIANS
AUTOMATICALLY EVERY TIME THEY
CAN LEAST AFFORD IT. BUT SOME
FOURTEEN MILLION ONE IS 36% OF
THE POPULATION CURRENTLY LIVING
NEAR OR BELOW THE POVERTY LEVEL
AND CURRENTLY PAYING YOUR THE
HIGHEST RATES FOR BOTH
TRANSPORTATION ENERGY GAS AND
DIESEL AS WELL AS IN HOME
ENERGY. ANY ADDITIONAL FINANCIAL
BURDEN SERVES TO DESTROY THE
ABILITY AT THE SAME FAMILIES
WORKING FAMILIES. PAGE NEEDS A
CALL OF LIFE. BUT IT THE CURRENT
FUNDED BY MANY OF THE SAME
WORKING TAXPAYING FAMILIES THAT
PROVIDE FINANCING OPPORTUNITIES
FOR THE FINANCIALLY FORTUNATE BY
NEW PLUG ANY NEEDS. YOU TO THE
EVER WIDENING HEALTH GAPS THAT
EXIST IN THE STATE. TWENTY
TWENTY TWO THE AVERAGE HOUSEHOLD
INCOME OF THE TESLA BUYER WITH A
HUNDRED FORTY SIX THOUSAND
DOLLARS A YEAR. MORE THAN TWICE
THE NATIONAL MEDIAN INCOME
PLUGIN EDIE OWNERS PAY
ABSOLUTELY NO STATE OR FEDERAL
HIGHWAY TAXES OR SALES TAXES
BECAUSE THEY DON'T PURCHASE GAS
OR DIESEL. WITH THE ANNUAL CPI
INCREASE ON FUEL AND THE VALUE
OF THE TAX HOLIDAY FOR THE
FORTUNATE FEW. INCREASES WELL
THE CRUSHING COST OF HIGHWAY
MAINTENANCE AND FUNDING LOCAL
GOVERNMENT. AGAIN LANDS ON THE
BACK TO THE UNDERSERVED THE
LOWER INCOME POPULATION. THIS
SOCIAL INJUSTICE THE BY PRODUCT
OF MULTIPLE STATE POLICY THAT
AGAIN ABANDON THE NEEDS AND
CONCERNS OF A GROWING SECTION OF
OUR POPULATION. CAN BE PARTIALLY
DRESSED BY THE PASSAGE OF SENATE
BILL ELEVEN FIFTY SIX THEREFORE.
I URGE YOUR AYE VOTE ON THIS
BILL THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR YOUR
TESTIMONY. WE MOVE ON TO THOSE
INDIVIDUALS IN SUPPORT OF THE
BILL HERE IN ROOM TWENTY ONE
HUNDRED PLEASE COME FORWARD.
MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS TULARE
COUNTY SUPERVISORS DENNIS TOWNS
IN LARRY MCCARTY SUPPORT THIS
BILL THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. SENIOR FOR THE TESTIMONY
IN THE ROOM I'D LIKE TO MOVE ON
TO THE TELECONFERENCE LINE IF%
YOU COULD PROMPT THOSE WHO WOULD
WISH TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT.
MISTER MODERATOR IF YOU COULD
PROMPT THOSE ON THE
TELECONFERENCE LINE THOSE IN
SUPPORT OF SB ELEVEN FIFTY SIX.
SOUNDS LIKE WE MAY HAVE LOST THE
MODERATOR. MISTER MODERATOR.
THANK IT IT MY FAULT THE
PROBABLY THAT MY FATHER WAS
INJURED AND- IF YOU LIKE PLAYING
PRESS ONE FOLLOWED BY ZERO ONE
FIVE ZERO WE WILL GO TO LINE
WHEN OH NINE YOU ARE OPEN. ONE
OH NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD. WHEN
ONE OH NINE WOULD YOU LIKE TO
TESTIFY. I WILL NO LONGER LINE
ONE TWENTY. I'M SORRY- GOOD
MORNING SENATOR NUMBERS THIS IS
JAMES DIRECTOR OF THE CALIFORNIA
STATE COUNCIL LABOR'S ENOUGH
ACTUALLY TRYING TO FALLING IN
OPPOSITION TO ELEVEN FIFTY SIX
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. THE FINAL
REMINDER PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO.
AT THIS TIME IF YOU WOULD LIKE
TO TESTIFY. AND MEDICARE NOBODY
ELSE'S QUEUING UP. OKAY THESE
WERE THESE WERE WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT. CORRECT YES AND ONE OF
ONE MORE IS TESTIFYING IN
SUPPORT ACTUALLY- THERE WITH AN
OPERATOR SHOULD BE WITH HIS ANY
SECOND. THANK YOU. ANYBODY ELSE
ATTACHED FIND SUPPORT PLEASE
PRESS ONE ZERO. AND WE'RE GONNA
GO TO LINE ONE ZERO SEVEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD ONE SEVEN. HI THIS IS
LISA WALSH THE CHAIRMAN OF THE
VICE ANY ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT
CORPORATION. AND DIRECTOR OF THE
SOUTH VALLEY INDUSTRIAL
CORPORATION. I AM IN FAVOR OF
ASKING ONE ONE FIVE SIX. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. ANYONE ELSE.
NOBODY ELSE IS QUEUED UP AT THIS
TIME THANK YOU VERY GOOD WE'RE
GOING TO MOVE ON TO THE
OPPOSITION WE HAVE ONE LEAD
OPPOSITION WITNESS WHICH IS MARC
WATTS FROM THE TRANSPORTATION
CALIFORNIA AND HE'S HERE IN
PERSON. WELCOME EIGHT. HI MARC
WATTS HAS WAS JUST EDUCATED ON
BEHALF OF TRANSPORTATION
CALIFORNIAN ALLIED MEMBER
ORGANIZATIONS. REPRESENTING THE
TRANSPORTATION INDUSTRY
WORKFORCE OF BILLS REPAIRS THE
CALIFORNIA STATEWIDE MULTI MODAL
TRANSPORTATION SYSTEM. WE ARE
DEFINITELY OPPOSED TO HAS GIVEN
FIFTY SIX. HAS BEEN EDUCATED
ELIMINATES THE ANNUAL
INFLATIONARY ADJUSTMENT. FOR
BOTH MOTOR FUEL VEHICLE FUEL AND
DIESEL FUEL EXCISE RATES. AND AS
A RESULT IT COSTS. REVENUE IN
THE YEAR OF- ON THE ORDER OF
ABOUT A HALF A BILLION DOLLARS
IN THE FIRST YEAR IT WOULD HAVE.
AND IT WOULD COST EVEN MORE IN
THE SECOND YEAR OF
IMPLEMENTATION AND GO ON A RUN.
OUR INDUSTRY FOUGHT. INCLUDE THE
ADJUSTMENT TO THE X. TAX RATES
WITHIN AS FEW ONE SO THAT STATE
AND LOCAL AGENCIES WOULD BE ABLE
TO MAINTAIN AN ADEQUATE PACE OF
IMPROVEMENTS. TO OUR THEN
BELEAGUERED SYSTEM THAT'S COMING
AROUND AT THIS POINT TIME. THE
TAX IT JUST MEANT. IS TARGETING
OUR BACKLOG. TO MAINTAIN AS WELL
AS MAINTAINING PACE WITH
INCREASING COSTS OVER TIME OUR
INFRASTRUCTURE BOB IS GOING I
DON'T WANT TO DELIVER THE POINT
WE ARE DEEPLY CONCERNED THAT OUT
RIGHT LIMITATION OF THE
ADJUSTMENT BY SPLM FIFTY SIX WE
GUARANTEE THE STATE AND LOCAL
AGENCIES WILL CONTINUE TO FALL
BEHIND IN CRITICAL SAFETY WE
HAVE RECONSTRUCTION AND
MAINTENANCE PROJECTS ROUTE
CALIFORNIA. WITH NEARLY SIXTEEN
BILLION TO HAVING FLOWN INTO OUR
TRANSPORTATION SYSTEM SINCE SB
ONE PASSED EVEN WITH THE OBVIOUS
SYSTEM IMPROVEMENTS WE'VE SEEN
UNDER WAY TODAY WE KNOW THAT WE
WILL BE SEEING A GROWING GAP IN
RESOURCES TO ME ROADWAY AND
LOCAL REPAIR NEEDS. IN CLOSING
ADJUSTMENT IT IS WOULD- SEE.
WHAT ONLY ACCELERATED
DETERIORATION OF THE STATE'S
TRANSPORTATION SYSTEM AND I
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR YOUR
TIME. THANK YOU FOR YOUR
TESTIMONY HERE TODAY. IS THERE
ANYONE ELSE IN ROOM TWENTY ONE
HUNDRED IN OPPOSITION. GOOD
MORNING MADAM CHAIR MIKE MONEY
GOING TO BE HALF THE CALIFORNIA
STATE BUILDING AND CONSTRUCTION
TRADES COUNCIL IN OPPOSITION.
THANK YOU. MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS
THE BIG WEATHER AND REDUCES FITS
FOR THE PROFESSIONAL ENGINEERS
IN CALIFORNIA GOVERNMENT IN
OPPOSITION. THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR TODD BLOOM STEIN FOR THE
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA CONTRACTORS
ASSOCIATION A MEMBER OF
TRANSPORTATION CALIFORNIAN
RESPECTFUL OPPOSITION THANK YOU
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. SENIOR
FURTHER TESTIMONY IN THE ROOM
WHEN I MOVE ON TO- TESTIMONY IN
OPPOSITION ON THE TELECONFERENCE
LINE MISTER MODERATOR IF YOU
COULD PLEASE PROMPT. THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR IF YOU ARE IN
OPPOSITION TO SB ELEVEN X.
PLEASE PRESS ONE FOLLOWED BY
ZERO THIS TIME WHEN FALL BY ZERO
. NINE SIXTY TWO YOU ARE OPEN.
GOOD MORNING MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS
OF THE COMMITTEE KIANA VALENTINE
ON BEHALF OF UNITED CONTRACTORS
FOR ALL THE REASONS STATED BY MR
WHAT'S IN OPPOSITION THIS
MORNING TO SB ELEVEN FIFTY SIX.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. AND FOR
ANYBODY ELSE PLEASE PRESS ONE
FOLLOWED BY ZERO TO TESTIFY IN
OPPOSITION TO SB ELEVEN FIFTY
SIX WE HAVE ONE MORE WITH AN
OPERATOR BETTER SURE ONE MOMENT
PLEASE. ONE ONE HUNDRED NINETEEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. THE MANAGER
MEMBERS TYLER FUNDING ON BEHALF
OF THE AMERICAN COUNCIL OF
ENGINEERING COMPANIES IN
OPPOSITION FOR ALL THOSE
INGREDIENTS ACROSS BY A MISTER
MARK THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
NOBODY ELSE IS QUEUED UP AT THIS
TIME MADAM CHAIR VERY GOOD GOING
TO BRING IT BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE. SENATOR WIENER. I
DON'T KNOW SOMEONE SERVICES FOR
CENTER NIELSEN. THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR AND THEN EARLIER. YOU KNOW
I CONSIDER IT. RATHER SADLY
USING. THE OPPOSITION TO THIS
BILL. THIS ISN'T A SAVE ALL BY
ANY MEANS. AND THESE GAS PRICES
ARE STRICTLY AN ABSOLUTELY
DRIVEN BY FEDERAL POLICY OVER
THE LAST TWO YEARS. WHICH HAVE
INHIBITED SUPPLY WE WERE. NOT
DEPENDENT ON FOREIGN NATIONS ON
OUR ENEMIES. FOR FUEL TWO YEARS
AGO AND FOR SEVERAL YEARS. NOW
WE ARE AT THE MOST PERILOUS TIME
. THOSE WHO OPPOSE THIS SHOULD
FOCUS THEIR ENERGIES ON THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT AND FEDERAL
POLICIES. NOW AS WELL REGULATORY
POLICIES IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA. YOU CANNOT CONSERVE
YOUR WAY INTO THE FUTURE. FOR
OUR GRANDCHILDREN THEN EITHER
ENERGY. OR IN TERMS OF WATER WE
NEED TO BE COGNIZANT OF THAT.
THIS BILL. IS A MINOR HELPING
HAND THE MILLIONS OF
CALIFORNIANS- DRIVE BY THOSE GAS
STATIONS LOOK AT THOSE PUMP
PRICES. AND WONDER HOW THEY'RE
GOING TO GET TO WORK THE PICKED
THE KIDS UP AT SCHOOL. IT'S
SCARY TO SEE OUR COUNTRY COME TO
THIS I WILL MOVE THE BILL THANK
YOU THERE IS A MOTION BY SENATOR
NELSON THIRD WIENER I THANK YOU
CENTER GUERRERO- I'M- NOT
SURPRISINGLY I THINK THE AUTHOR
I'M EXTREMELY OPPOSED- TO THE
SPELL OF HIS BILL WOULD BE
ABSOLUTELY DISASTROUS FOR
CALIFORNIA'S- EFFORT TO-
ACTUALLYTAKE CARE OF OUR ROADS-
TO REBUILD OUR DILAPIDATED STATE
HIGHWAY SYSTEM TO SUPPORT PUBLIC
TRANSPORTATION THIS IS A VERY
EXTREME. MEASURE THIS ISN'T EVEN
MORE I MEAN I DON'T LIKE TO
THINK IT WAS PROPOSING WHICH IS
A ONE YEAR- THE LADY OF THE- OF
THE INFLATION ADJUSTMENT THIS IS
A PERMANENT ELIMINATION OF- THE
INFLATIONARY- COST OF LIVING
ADJUSTMENT- FOR THE GAS TAX AND
SO WHAT THAT MEANS IT'S A HALF A
BILLION THIS YEAR. CLOSE TO A
DEAL NEXT AND NOT WILL COMPOUND.
OVER TIMES OVER THE NEXT DECADE
DISABILITY BILLIONS AND BILLIONS
AND BILLIONS OF DOLLARS. THAT
WOULD HAVE BEEN INVESTED IN
RESURFACING ROADS IN FIXING
STATE HIGHWAYS AND IN SHORING UP
OUR PUBLIC TRANSPORTATION
SYSTEMS MEMBERS WE'RE TALKING
OVER TIME TENS OF BILLIONS OF
DOLLARS. JUST SUCKED OUT OF THE
INFRASTRUCTURE OF THIS STATE AND
THAT MEANS ROADS WILL BE BUMPIER
MORE. OUR CARS WILL BE DAMAGED
BY KREDI ROADS- WE WILL HAVE
MORE OF THOSE HORRIBLE POTHOLES
ON THE STATE'S HIGHWAYS THAT
CALTRANS WON'T HAVE THE
RESOURCES AFFECTS. AND PEOPLE
WHO RELY ON BUS SERVICE OR
SERVICE OR TRAIN SERVICE TO GET
TO WORK OR WHEREVER THEY'RE
GOING WE'RE GONNA HAVE TO WAIT
LONGER I HAVE BY. WORSE
EXPERIENCES- AND SO THIS IS NOT
JUST SOME MINOR TEN. PIECE FOR
WHILE WE HIKED GAS PRICES THAT
SEEM TO BE. USING A MAYBE COMING
DOWN THIS IS NOT TEMPORARILY.
THIS IS A PERMANENT WRECKING
BALL TO OUR ABILITY AS A STATE
TO. WE ARE. DR SYSTEM ARMS THIS
IS A VERY SEVERE VERY HARMFUL
WHY ARE TRANSPORTATION SYSTEMS
AND SUCH ABOUT **** BAD SHAPE
PEOPLE GET VERY FRUSTRATED AND
LIKE- WE WILL PASS THE GAS TAX
INCREASE IN TWENTY SEVENTEEN AND
WE STILL HAVE ROADS THAT ARE IN
BAD SHAPE AND HIGHWAYS SO YOU
MUST NOT BE DOING ANYTHING THE
REASON IS BECAUSE FOR THIRTY
YEARS THIS STATE WAS DENIED
BUDGETS GET PASSED TAX AND-
THIRTY YEARS AT THE CLUB. IN
REAL VALUE ABOUT 50% DIDN'T GO
UP BY INFLATION FROM THE EARLY
NINETIES UNTIL YOU KNOW ABOUT
FIVE YEARS AGO- AND SO WE REALLY
ALLOWED ARE TRANSFERRED TO HAVE
A STRUCTURE TO DETERIORATE AND
WE ARE DIGGING OUT OF DEEP OR
NOT YOU CAN'T DO IT TO YOUR IT
TAKES TIME THE LAST THING WE
SHOULD BE DOING IS SHOOTING
OURSELVES BUT BY SUCKING
ALTERNATELY TENS OF BILLIONS OF
DOLLARS OUT OF OURS. PREDATION
BOND- I ALSO THINK IT'S REALLY A
MA'AM OF THE TO DOWN THERE'S A
OF MESS. GOING NOT NOT JUST IN
THIS HEARING BUT FROM YOU KNOW
I'M NOT JUST FROM REPUBLICANS.
ODDS THE TRAGICALLY FROM SOME
DEMOCRATS TO- DIED- IF WE TRUST
THE SPENDER LOWER THE GAS TAX
YOUR GAS PRICES ARE GONNA GO
DOWN I DON'T THINK THAT'S TRUE.
GAS GAS TAXES ARE NOT BEING
DRIVEN ACHIEVEMENT GAS PRICES
ARE NOT BEING DRIVEN BY WEATHER
YOU KNOW WE HAVE THIS OR THAT
GAS TAX. IS BEING DRIVEN BY THE
OIL COMPANIES. I'M TO BLAME THE
BITE IN ADMINISTRATION FOR YOU
KNOW SOME OF CONSTRAINING OIL
SUPPLY AND WE HAVE SO MANY.
FEDERAL GAS LEASE OR WILL WE
SAYS IT WILL COMPANIES AREN'T
EVEN USING Y. FOR THEIR OWN
BOTTOM LINE BECAUSE THEY THEY
DON'T WANT TO HAVE AN OVER
SUPPLIED DATA WILL COMPANIES
BENEFIT. FROM HAVING HIGH GAS
PRICES AND SO THEY DON'T HAVE AN
INCENTIVE TO TRY TO CONSTRAIN
THAT- AND TO MAKE PEOPLE PAY
MORE THE GUY AT THE PUMP. THAT
IS IT WILL COMPANIES CATERING TO
THEIR SHAREHOLDERS THEY DON'T
CARE ABOUT THE PEOPLE CALIFORNIA
WILL COMPANIES DON'T CARE. IF
SOMEONE WHO IS LOW INCOME HAS TO
PAY MORE AT THE PUMP TO GET THE
WORK BUILT COMPANIES COULD CARE
LESS ABOUT THAT. THEY CARE ABOUT
PLEASING THEIR SHAREHOLDERS AND
THAT'S WHY THEY ARE KEEPING THE
PRICES HIGH. AND WE COULD
ELIMINATE THE STATE GAS TAX
TOMORROW AND THAT IS NO
GUARANTEE BUT GAS PRICES WILL GO
DOWN AT ALL. AND THE DEBT WILL
COMPANIES ARE JUST AS LIKELY TO
STOP POCKET THE DIFFERENCE. AND
WE WILL BE SUBSIDIZING THE OIL
COMPANIES SO THIS IS I THINK A
MISREPRESENTATION OF THE PUBLIC
TO SAY THAT DO THAT PASSING THIS
BILL OR LOWERING GAS TAXES. IS
GOING TO LOWER YOUR GAS PRICES
PROBABLY WON'T. BUT WHAT IT WILL
DO IS MAKE YOU HAVE TO GO TO MY-
MORE. WHEN YOUR CAR GETS DAMAGED
BECAUSE WERE SUCKING TENS OF
BILLIONS OF DOLLARS OUT OF ROAD
RESURFACING HIGHWAY REPAIRS. AND
BUS AND TRAIN SERVICE SO I AM
OPPOSED TO THIS BILL I'M VOTING
NO. THANK YOU VERY MUCH- YOUR
EYES ON. IT WE'RE GOING TO GO
THROUGH THE COMMENTS AND THEN
WE'RE GOING TO GIVE YOU AN
OPPORTUNITY BECAUSE WE COULD.
SENATOR EYES THANK YOU- I DO-
NUMBER A COMMON THE AUTHOR FOR
RAISING THE ISSUE OF WHAT. IT IS
THAT POOR AND MIDDLE INCOME
PEOPLE ARE GOING THROUGH WITH
GAS PRICES- I THINK IT'S
TERRIBLE THAT THE GAS PRICES ARE
BEING INCREASED AS MUCH AS THEY
ARE. MY PROBLEM WITH WITH THE
BILL IS THAT THERE IS NO
GUARANTEE THAT THOSE PRICES WILL
GO DOWN. IF WE ELIMINATE THE AND
INFLATION IN THE GAS IN THE GAS
TAX THAT'S THE REAL PROBLEM AND
I DON'T WANT TO REPEAT
EVERYTHING THE CENTER WIENER
SAID BUT- IF THERE WAS RELIEF
AND IT WAS SIGNIFICANT ENOUGH. I
WOULD COUNTERBALANCE THAT WITH
OKAY WE WILL BE LOSING FIVE
HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS THE
FIRST YEAR ALMOST BILLION
DOLLARS THE NEXT YEAR- WHAT DOES
THAT MEAN IN TERMS OF LOSS OF
JOBS. LOST TO BUSINESSES THAT
RELY ON THESE ON ON THIS-
INVESTMENT. THROUGH IN BALANCING
THE TWO I DON'T SEE ONE THAT
THE- REGULAR WORKING PEOPLE.
NEED TO GAS UP THEIR CARS AND
TRUCKS TO GET TO WORK I DON'T
SEE HOW THEY GET THE RELIEF SO
THAT'S THE PRIMARY REASON. THAT
I WILL BE SUPPORTING THE BILL
THANK YOU. VERY GOOD- TO SAY
THAT THAT- THAT MANY OF THE
THINGS MY COLLEAGUES HAVE SAID-
RIGHT IBM. ARE TRUE ABILITY I
GUESS I SEE THIS A LITTLE BIT
DIFFERENTLY AND- TO THE EXTENT
THAT- THE GOVERNOR'S TALKED
ABOUT. GAS TAX RELIEF THE
PRESIDENT HAS TALKED ABOUT GAS
TAX RELIEF I THINK IT'S
IMPORTANT TO HAVE THE
CONVERSATION CONTINUE UNTIL WE
FINALLY ADOPT BUDGETS AND WE CAN
FIGURE OUT WHAT KIND OF RELIEF
FOR GONNA. GIVE TO THE
TAXPAYERS- BUT ALSO I THINK
THERE THERE ARE ALWAYS SEE
ISSUES POLICY POSITIONS THAT WE
TAKE HERE IN THE LEGISLATURE.
THAT THAT MAKE IT DIFFICULT FOR
PEOPLE TO TRAVEL THAT HAVE
NOTHING TO DO WITH THE TAP THAT
THE TAX BEING THERE THE TAX NOT
BEING THERE WHEN WE START-
FOCUSING ON- ELECTRIC VEHICLES
WERE IGNORING THE FACT THAT THEY
USE THE ROAD THE CLOG THE
HIGHWAYS BUT THEY DON'T PAY INTO
A SYSTEM- AND WHEN WE START
LOOKING AT VEHICLE MILES
TRAVELED WHICH IS- PENALTY ON
COMMUNITIES THAT ARE THING
HOUSING- AND THEY'RE TRYING TO
BUILD HOUSING FOR THEIR
WORKFORCE BUT ACTUALLY ARE
BUILDING HOUSING FOR SOMEONE
ELSE'S WORKFORCE WHO'S TRAVELING
LONG DISTANCES WE DON'T
RECOGNIZE IT. THOSE INDIVIDUALS
THAT ARE TRAVELING THOSE REALLY
LONG DISTANCES WHAT BETTER ROADS
AND THEY WANT WIDER ROADS AND
BIGGER ROADS AND WE'VE MADE THE
COMMITMENT IN CALIFORNIA NOT TO
WIDEN OUR FREEWAYS SYSTEM ON THE
- I WON'T REALLY TAKE ROADS AND
SO. ON THE SOME REALLY. SYSTEM
OF- OF DOING THINGS WITH ONE
HAND AND NOT DOING IT WITH THE
OTHER AND I THINK THIS THIS
WHOLE ISSUE I HAVE TO AGREE THAT
I'M NOT SURE THAT REDUCING THE
TAX. IS GOING TO BENEFIT THE
INDIVIDUALS THAT WE THINK IT'S
GOING TO BENEFIT BUT THERE'S A
DISCUSSION GOING ON RIGHT NOW
AND THERE'S A BUDGET GOING ON
THAT TO BEING CREATED AND-
WILLING TO SUPPORT THIS AS PART
OF A DISCUSSION BUDGET
DISCUSSION THAT'LL BE- THEY'LL
BE CONCLUDED IN A MONTH- WELL
I'LL BE VOTING ON A BUDGET. AND
HOW WE HOW WE HELP. OUR CITIZENS
THAT ARE A RESIDENTS THAT ARE
REALLY STRUGGLING IS IT'S GOT TO
BE PART OF THAT BUDGET AND- AND
I KNOW THAT- THAT ALL PARTIES AT
THE TABLE WILL HAVE THAT
DISCUSSION AND SO I'M- WILLING
TO SUPPORT IT TODAY
UNDERSTANDING THAT YET- PROBABLY
WON'T GET THE VOTES. THAT IT
NEEDS DOWN THE ROAD BUT- BUT I
DO THINK THAT- I DO APPRECIATE
THE WORK THAT YOU'RE DOING ON
THIS AND- AND- AND I THINK THAT
THAT LOOKING AFTER THE PEOPLE
THAT ARE THE LEAST THE LEAST.
ABLE TO PAY THE HIGH PRICES IS
REALLY IMPORTANT IN THE STATE
ITSELF I WANT TO THANK YOU FOR
THAT SO THERE IS A MOTION BY
SENATOR NELSON THE MOTION IS. TO
PASS BUT FIRST BE RIVER RE
REFERRED TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS- YOU MAY CONCLUDE
THANK YOU THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR
FOR YOUR SUPPORT IN THIS BILL-
TO MOVE FORWARD I WOULD
APPRECIATE IT I DON'T THINK
THAT'S GOING TO HAPPEN SOME JUST
GONNA RESPOND TO A COUPLE OF.
COMMENTS THAT WERE MADE TO TRY
TO CORRECT THE RECORD SO
OBVIOUSLY MY COLLEAGUE FROM LOS
ANGELES IS TAKING THEIR CUES
FROM MY COLLEAGUE FROM
SACRAMENTO. AND I WANT YOU TO BE
REASSURED THAT OPEC SETS THE OIL
PRICE RIGHT TEXAS AT SOME RANDOM
OIL COMPANY IN KERN COUNTY OR
ANYWHERE ELSE DOESN'T JUST
RANDOMLY GO ON MEDICAL CHARGE
THIS AMOUNT OF MONEY SO OPEC ON
A WORLD VIEW SETS THE OIL PRICES
AND THEN THAT'S FILTERED DOWN
THE UNITED STATES- IN EVERYWHERE
THAT USES OIL. THE SECOND THING
IS THAT OIL COMPANIES SELL TO
REFINERIES THAT REFINE OIL THE
CELL GET. THAT GASOLINE IS
RETAILER LIKE A VALERO OR A
CHEVRON GAS STATION MUCH LIKE
WE'RE EITHER ANY OF PERSON ON
THE DIESS WOULD GET THEIR GAS IS
THAT GAS RETAILER IS NOT
REQUIRED TO PAY THE ADDITIONAL
TAX TO THE CITY CALIFORNIA EVERY
GALLON OF GAS THAT THEY SELL.
THE PRICE WILL AUTOMATICALLY
DROP FOR EVERY GALLON OF GAS
IT'S KIND OF LIKE AS AN EMPLOYER
EVERY QUARTER W HAVE TO FILL
OUT A D. E. SIX WE TAKE TAXES
OUT OF AN EMPLOYEE'S CHECK. WE
BALANCE THAT WITH R. D. E. SIX
WE MATCH ON SOME OF THOSE TAXES
AN EMPLOYER TAX MATCHING THE
RECENT A FORM. YEAH THE STATE.
IS IT PLAYER I WOULDN'T HAVE TO
TAKE THE- OUT OF MY EMPLOYEES. I
WOULDN'T TAKE THE TAXES OUT OF
THE EMPLOYEES CHECKS. BECAUSE
WHEN I SET MY FOR MEN TO THE
STATE THAT THEY VERIFY IN
BALANCE. THEY WOULD SHOW THAT I
JUST PAID MY PORTION AND NOT THE
EMPLOYEES PORTION. SO I THINK
YOU'RE YOU'RE- KIND OF. I WE
HAVE READ THE BILL NOPE. MY
COLLEAGUE FROM SAN FRANCISCO.
AND I ALSO WANT TO CLARIFY THE
OTHER POSITION THAT YOU MADE YOU
ALSO SAID THAT THIS IS
CATASTROPHIC AND IT WOULD
ELIMINATE ROAD CONSTRUCTION
DOLLARS. THE OPPOSITION'S OWN
TESTIMONY SIXTEEN BILLION
DOLLARS HAS FLOWED INTO THIS
ACCOUNT. THIS BILL BEFORE YOU IS
ONLY THE INFLATIONARY INCREASE
THAT IS AUTOMATIC EVERY SINGLE
YEAR. IT'S NOT GOING TO STOP
THAT SIXTEEN BILLION DOLLARS.
THAT ALREADY EXISTS FROM FLOWING
INTO THE ACCOUNT. THAT MANY
STILL GOING TO BE THERE FOR
ROADS AND INFRASTRUCTURE. THAT'S
NOT GOING TO STOP THIS IS THE
FIVE POINT 6% INCREASE STARTING
JULY FIRST THAT WILL INCREASE
THE COST OF GAS. FOR PEOPLE IN
OUR COMMUNITIES INNER CITY LOS
ANGELES THE CENTRAL VALLEY. THAT
DRIVE MILES AND MILES AND MILES
JUST TO GET THE FEEL TO PICK THE
FRUIT THAT WE EAT. AND THEY ARE
GONNA HAVE TO PAY THAT INCREASE.
THIS YEAR HI I'M GOOD LET'S JUST
BE HONEST EVERYONE OF US WILL
PAY THIS GAS TAX INCREASE. IT
WILL GRIPE AND COMPLAIN ABOUT IT
YOU KNOW I POSTED A PICTURE THE
OTHER DAY I DRIVE A FORD EDGE IN
MY GAS WAS A HUNDRED SIX DOLLARS
TO FILL UP A FORD EDGE. I HAD A
AND SIX DOLLARS I'M A GREAT
ABOUT IT. BUT THERE ARE A LOT OF
PEOPLE IN MY COMMUNITY AND THE
CENTRAL VALLEY IN EVEN IN LOS
ANGELES IN THE INNER CITIES IN
PROBABLY IN SAN FRANCISCO. AND
DATA THAT CAN'T TO PAY THAT
HUNDRED SIX DOLLARS TO FILL UP
THEIR GAS TAX. THIS IS AN
IMMEDIATE RELIEF AGAIN WE DON'T
SET THE OIL PRICES. OPEC DOES
AND IF YOU DON'T HAVE TO PAY THE
TAX THE RETAILER THE CHEVRON GAS
STATION THE MINI MARKET THE
SEVEN ELEVEN. THAT SELLS GAS
WILL NOT CHARGE THAT GAS AT THE
PUMP IT'S NOT GONNA BE RETAINED
BY WHAT YOU CALL THESE EVIL OIL
COMPANIES. THAT ARE TAKING THIS
MANY AND POCKETING IT THAT'S NOT
GONNA HAPPEN. THEY REFINED OIL
AND REFINERIES LIKE I SAID IT
GOES TO THE RETAILER THE
RETAILER SELLS THE GAS AND
DOESN'T APPLY THE TAX. TO THE
GAS PER GALLON. THE OTHER THING
IS MY COLLEAGUE. IS THE THIRD
TIME YOU'VE DONE THIS TO ME AND
I KNOW THIS BILL DACA PASTIMES
GONNA SAY IT. YOU TURN
EVERYTHING POLITICAL. EVERYTHING
I'D A BILL THE OTHER DAY. THAT
WAS ABOUT STOPPING HUMAN
TRAFFICKING PERPETRATORS. FROM
AND- TO GO TO JAIL FOR A LONGER
PERIOD OF TIME DID THEY SELL.
LGBT KIDS TRANSGENDER KIDS THEY
BRUTALIZE WOMEN ANY PRODUCT
RHONDA SANDERSON SOMETHING GOING
ON THE FLORIDA. CAPITOL THERE
HAS NOTHING TO DO WITH RUN TO
AND DOES IN THIS BILL HERE HAS
NOTHING TO DO. WITH ANYTHING
GOING ON IN WASHINGTON DC- OIL
COMPANIES THIS BILL IS BEING.
BROUGHT TO YOU GUYS TO GIVE
IMMEDIATE. RELIEF MEDIA RELEASE
. WHEN THE GOVERNOR MAY THAT
DOES. TO SEE. THE GAME TAX HE-
IT WAS RELIEVED. AT THE GAS PUMP
WE DIDN'T HAVE THAT INCREASE IT
WAS SUSPENDED FOR ONE YEAR SO
THE INCREASE IS NOT THERE. DID
THE OPPOSITION STILL GET THEIR
SIXTEEN BILLION DOLLARS FOR
ROADS AND INFRASTRUCTURE WHICH
IS MORE THAN WE'VE EVER SPENT.
IN THE HISTORY PROBABLY OF
CALIFORNIA. ABSOLUTELY THIS BILL
JUST IT GETS THE GAP. THEY'RE
STILL GONNA GET THE FIFTY ONE
CENTS A GALLON. FOR THE GAS TAX
SO THAT THEY CAN DO ROADS AND
INFRASTRUCTURE WHICH AGAIN IS
SIXTEEN BILLION DOLLARS. THEY'RE
JUST NOT GONNA GET THE FIVE
POINT 6% EXCISE INCREASE
STARTING JULY FIRST. WHICH WILL
GIVE US. A RELIEF AT THE GAS
PUMP I RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE
BUT- REMATCH WE DO HAVE A
MOTION. MOTION IS DUE PASSING BE
REFERRED TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. SENATORS CAPITO HI
SANTIAGO HI NIELSEN HI NIELSEN
HI DURAZO. THE ROSEAU NO
HERTZBERG. WIENER WIENER NOW. TO
THE MAKING MEDICARE'S NOT PASS.
WOULD YOU. IF THERE IF THERE IS
NO OBJECTION- WE CAN GRAB
RECONSIDERATION THANK YOU FOR
GOOD US SENATOR YOU HAVE SB
FOURTEEN EIGHTY FOUR I DO
HOPEFULLY I'LL HAVE BETTER LUCK
WITH THIS BILL I AM SO GOOD
MORNING MANAGER MEMBERS I HAVE
S. B. LOOK FOURTEEN EIGHTY FOUR
WHICH IS A HOMELESS FOSTER YOUTH
AND FOSTER YOUTH EMPLOYER TAX
CREDIT- I. E. I APPRECIATE TO
LIVE BY SAYING THAT I'M
ACCEPTING THE COMMITTEE MEMBER
TODAY AND I APPRECIATE COMMITTEE
STAFF WORKING WITH MY OFFICE ON
THE BILL BUT I DO NEED TO MAKE A
VERY IMPORTANT CLARIFICATION. A
LOT OF OUR FOSTER YOU ARE
HOMELESS THEY ARE- THE BILL
FIRST INCLUDED HOMELESS AND
FOSTER YOUTH BUT A LOT OF OUR
FOSTER YOUTH ARE HOMELESS THERE
THE SILVER SURFER KIDS THAT STAY
ON OUR NEIGHBORS COUCHES ARE ON
OUR COUCHES THE E. R. YOU KNOW
THEY SPEND SOME NIGHTS WITH SOME
FRIENDS AND SOME LIKE TO THE
OTHERS I JUST WANT TO MAKE SURE
THAT IF AN EMPLOYER IS ABLE. F.
YOU. R. S. B. CONSIDERED A
FOSTER YOUTH BE THE HOME AT IF
THAT MAKES SENSE LIKE I DON'T I
WANT LET ME EXPLAIN IT BETTER I
GUESS BECAUSE THE AMENDMENTS
WERE UNCLEAR AND SO MY
CLARIFICATION IS IF AN EMPLOYER
HIRES A HOMELESS FOSTER YOUTH
WILL THEY STILL GET THE TAX
CREDIT BECAUSE THERE ARE
FOSTERING BUT BECAUSE THERE ARE
HOMELESS FOSTER YOU SINCE WE'RE
ELIMINATING THE WHOLE. WELL THAT
THE REASON FOR ELIMINATING IT
WAS THAT IT ALREADY IS IN
STATUTE AND SO THE IDEAS THEY
CAN PICK WHATEVER CREDIT IT IS
THAT- MEETS THEIR NEEDS GREAT
OKAY I JUST WANTED TO MAKE SURE.
OKAY SO LET ME START BY SAYING
I'M ACCEPTING THOSE AMENDMENTS I
THINK THE CHAIR AND THE
COMMITTEE STAFFER WORKING WITH
MY STAFF. SB FOURTEEN EIGHTY
FOUR WILL ALLOW PRIVATE SECTOR
EMPLOYERS TO OBTAIN A TAX CREDIT
MODELED AFTER THE CURRENT
FEDERAL WORK OPPORTUNITY TAX
CREDIT TO PROMOTE HIRING. OF AN
INDIVIDUAL WHO'S A FOSTER YOUTH
OR FORMER FOSTER YOUTH. THE
MAXIMUM CREDIT ALLOWED PER YEAR
PER EMPLOYEE IS TWENTY FOUR
HUNDRED DOLLARS NOT PER YEAR.
TOTAL TWENTY FOUR HUNDRED
DOLLARS. CURRENTLY CALIFORNIA
ALLOWS EMPLOYERS TO OBTAIN
VARIOUS TAX CREDITS FROM HIRING
SELECT QUALIFIED FULL TIME
EMPLOYEES INCLUDING VETERANS.
DISABLED PERSONS LONG TERM
EMPLOYMENT RECIPIENT. SECOND
CANCERS AMONG THESE- WHO WOULD
BENEFIT FROM THIS TAX CREDIT OR
FOSTER YOUTH WHO FACE SEEMINGLY
IMPOSSIBLE ODDS. AND ARE OFTEN
AMONG THE MOST SEVERELY IMPACTED
BY EVERY INCREASE EVER
INCREASING COST OF THE BASIC
FOOD AND HOUSING. CHILDREN IN
FOSTER CARE OFTEN STRUGGLE WHEN
THEIR LIFE- WHEN LIKE CRISIS IS
HAPPEN TO THEM THEY HAVE
DRAMATIC LOST NEGLECT ABUSE.
NGUYEN M. D. X. OF THE FOSTER
CARE SYSTEM THEY MAY EVEN LIKE
NECESSARY NETWORKS OR RESOURCES
LEAVING THEM WITH LITTLE SUPPORT
IN THAT NEGATIVELY IMPACTING
THEIR OVERALL MENTAL HEALTH AND
OUTLOOK ON LIFE. IT'S CLEAR
STUDENT EMPLOYMENT LEADS TO
GREATER SELF SUFFICIENCY AND
DISCIPLINE IT REDUCES THE TIME
THAT YOU SPEND. I'M ON THE
STREETS IT TEACHES THEM HE JOB
SKILLS AND SOCIAL SKILLS AND
PROVIDES INCOME STABILITY
NECESSARY TO FIND IN MAINTAINING
HOUSING. AND I'VE OFTEN SAID AS
A JOB CREATOR IN THIS STATE FOR
THE LAST THIRTY YEARS I REALLY
DO BELIEVE THAT THE MOST
IMPORTANT. AND SOLUTION TO
POVERTY IS A JOB. TOGETHER THESE
FACTORS REDUCE THE LIKELIHOOD
THAT FOSTER YOUTH WILL BECOME
STUCK IN A CYCLE OF POVERTY-
HOMELESSNESS AND DEPENDENCY ON
PUBLIC BENEFITS AND SERVICES. SB
FOURTEEN EIGHTY FOUR TAKES A PER
IN IF APPROACH INVESTS. IN YOU
SUPPORTING THEM WITH GAINFUL
EMPLOYMENT AND OFFERING THEM A
BETTER CHANCE AT A SOLID START
IN LIFE IT ALSO SUPPORTS THE
BUSINESSES. THAT ARE WILLING TO
TAKE NOT A RISK BUT A CHANCE ON
SOMEBODY THAT POSSIBLY- MAYBE A
HIGHER RISK OF EMPLOYMENT AND I
DON'T MEAN THAT NEGATIVELY I'M
JUST SAYING THAT. WHEN PEOPLE
COME TO AND GET EMPLOYED AND THE
EMPLOYER GOES WILL WHERE DO YOU
LIVE THEY'RE NOT INTERESTED YOUR
ADDRESS THEY WANT TO KNOW IF
YOU'RE GOING TO GO TO WORK SO WE
COUNSEL PEOPLE TO COME FROM THE
HOMELESS CENTER. WE TELLING
COUNTY. I LIVE DOWNTOWN. IT'S
NOT THAT THE EMPLOYER ISN'T SO
MUCH WORRIED ABOUT BUT WHEN
YOU'RE THE WORD HOMELESS CENTER.
THE EMPLOYER MICHAEL HI HOW ARE
THEY GOING TO GET TO WORK YOU
KNOW THEY DON'T HAVE A PHONE I
CAN'T REACH AND IF I NEED TO. SO
THERE'S A LOT OF IT NEGATIVE
IMPACTS THAT GO AROUND HOMELESS
INDIVIDUALS AND SPECIFICALLY OUR
FOSTER YOUTH. SO I WOULD JUST
APPRECIATE I VOTE WITH ME TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF SB
FOURTEEN EIGHTY FOUR TODAY IS-
MICHELLE A COP CASH. SHE'S THE
AREA NEEDS AND COMMUNITY
PARTNERSHIP DIRECTOR FOR THE
ALLIANCE WHO WORKS EVERY DAY
WITH FOSTER YOUTH AND FAMILIES
HERE IN SACRAMENTO. THANK YOU
MISS COPPERS GO HEAD THE-
MORNING. THANK YOU SENATOR GROVE
AND SENATE COMMITTEE FOR THE
PRIVILEGE OF WORKING WITH YOU
TODAY.MY NAME IS MICHELLE
CAUGHT CASH AND THE IRANIANS
DIRECTOR FOR THE ALLIANCE
DEFENDING THE CONSECUENCIA WE
WERE NONPROFIT THAT SUPPORTS
OVER FIFTY AGENCIES AND
NONPROFIT GREATER SACRAMENTO
REGION THAT ARE DEDICATED TO
PROTECTING CHILDREN. AND
STRENGTHENING PLEASE. HOW MAY OF
YOU HAVE THAT GIVEN A JOB
RECOMMENDATION SOMEBODY WITHIN
YOUR CIRCLE. OR HOW MANY OF YOU
KNOW THAT IN AMERICA ON AVERAGE
24% OF YOUNG ADULTS ARE
FINANCIALLY INDEPENDENT FROM
THEIR PARENTS AT THE AGE OF
TWENTY TWO. OR THE IN SIX IN TEN
PARENTS SAY THAT THEY'VE GIVEN
SOME FINANCIAL HELP TO THEIR
ADULT CHILDREN IN THE PAST YEAR
. MEANWHILE IN CALIFORNIA
THEY'RE OVER SIXTY THOUSAND
FOSTER YOUTH IN THE SYSTEM WHO
OFTENTIMES LACK THE SUPPORT
SYSTEMS COMMUNITY CONNECTIONS.
MEANING THAT FOR THEM THERE
WITHOUT THE JOB RECOMMENDATION
WITHOUT A CIRCLE OF SUPPORT
WITHOUT PADDING FALL BACK ON. WE
INVEST SO LITTLE IN THEM YET
EXPECT SO MUCH OF THEM BY THE
TIME THAT THEY AGE OUT OF THE
SYSTEM. ONE OF THE SIXTY
THOUSAND FOSTER YOUTH ONLY 45%
OF THESE CHILDREN WILL EVER BE
ADOPTED. THAT MEANS ABOUT FOUR
THOUSAND CHILDREN WILL AGE OUT
OF THE SYSTEM ANNUALLY IN
CALIFORNIA. AND AROUND HALF OF
THESE WILL END UP HOMELESS OR
INCARCERATED AT SOME POINT. LAST
SCHOOL YEAR THERE WERE OVER
THIRTY TWO THOUSAND SCHOOL AGE
CHILDREN ENROLLED IN THE
CALIFORNIA SCHOOL SYSTEM. AND TO
GIVE YOU A VISUAL OF THAT AND
THAT'S ABOUT ENOUGH TO FILL
FIFTY TWO CALIFORNIA PUBLIC
SCHOOLS. IN THE GREATER
SACRAMENTO REGIONAL LOAN THERE
ARE ABOUT TWENTY SEVEN HUNDRED
FOSTER YOUTH WHICH WOULD BE
ABOUT. A HALF TO FILL SIX
ELEMENTARY SCHOOLS. ONLY ABOUT
HALF OF OUR FOSTER YOUTH IN OUR
SCHOOLS WILL GRADUATE FROM HIGH
SCHOOL ON TIME. AND DURING THEIR
SCHOOL YEARS THE AVERAGE FOSTER
YOUTH WILL BE MOVED ON AVERAGE
TO BETWEEN THREE TO FIVE
DIFFERENT PLACES HOMES. WITH
EACH MOVE ANY SEMBLANCE OF A
SUPPORT SYSTEM THAT THEY'VE BEEN
ABLE TO BUILD WILL BE BROKEN
ONCE AGAIN. DURING THEIR
TRANSITION AGE TWO YEARS. MANY
MAY ENTER INDEPENDENT LIVING
PROGRAMS AND MOVE INTO
UNFURNISHED APARTMENTS WHERE
THEY'LL GET HELP FROM NON
PROFITS LIKE MIND HELPED HOUSE-
AND FURNISH THEIR- THEIR SPACES.
YES AT TIMES THEY MAY HAVE TO
CHOOSE BETWEEN A CAN OPENER AND
CAN. FORCE SILVERWARE OR TOILET
PAPER. AND IT'S NO WONDER THAT
WHEN A TEEN OR YOUNG ADULT AGES
OUT OF THE FOSTER CARE SYSTEM
ABOUT 50% OF THEM WILL BE
WITHOUT A JOB IN FOUR YEARS.
ABOUT 25% OF THEM THE
INCARCERATED. OVER ONE IN FOUR
SOMETIMES UP 231% OF TRANSITION
AGE TEENS WILL EXPERIENCE
HOMELESSNESS. IN THE GREATER SEX
CRIMINAL REGION ONE THIRD OR 34%
OF HOMELESS PEOPLE REPORTED THAT
THEY'VE BEEN IN FOSTER CARE. AND
A TWO THOUSAND AND NINETEEN
STUDY BY THE CALIFORNIA STATE
UNIVERSITY OF SACRAMENTO. ASKED
HOMELESS AND TRANSITION TO EASE
AGE YOUTH WHAT TWO THINGS COULD
SACRAMENTO DUE TO HELP PEOPLE
BETTER AND- WHAT TWO THINGS
COULD SACRAMENTO DO BETTER TO
HELP PEOPLE WHO ARE EXPERIENCING
HOMELESSNESS. 48% OF THE
HOMELESS YOUTH ANSWERED PROVIDE
MORE JOBS AND TRAINING FOLLOWED
BY 44% WINS OR MORE AFFORDABLE
HOUSING. THIS JOB CAN PROVIDE
MORE OPPORTUNITIES TO CURRENT
AND FORMER FOSTER YOUTH AND
PRIORITIZES IMPORTANT
DEMOGRAPHIC. THANK YOU WE HAVE
ONE MORE WITNESS IN SUPPORT THAT
IS THAT CORRECT YES SIR MISS
MACLAINE SHE'S ON THE PHONE SIR
OKAY CAN YOU PUT IT THROUGH
MODERATOR. YEAH GO AHEAD. HELLO
AND THANK YOU SENATOR GROW FOR
THE OPPORTUNITY TO CALL IN FOR
IN YOUR DISTRICT AND REGION- THE
FOR THE SPEAKER RIGHT BEFORE ME
DID A GREAT JOB OF TELLING YOU
THE STATISTICS THAT SURROUND AND
CHILDREN THAT ARE AGING OUT OF
FOSTER CARE. WE KNOW THAT THE
PIPELINE TO THEM MAJORITY OF OUR
MAJOR SOCIAL ISSUES THAT WE HAVE
BIG OPINIONS ABOUT AND STEM FROM
FOSTER CARE. WHAT HE MENTIONED
50% OF OUR HOMELESS POPULATION-
AND SPENT TIME IN FOSTER CARE.
BEDI SHOW ANYWHERE FROM 4280% OF
OUR PRISON POPULATION HAS THE
BRIDGE IN THE FOSTER CARE
SYSTEM. WE KNOW THAT 70% OF.
GIRLS AGED OUT OF FOSTER CARE
WILL BE PREGNANT BY THE AGE OF
TWENTY ONE. ONLY 50% WILL
GRADUATE FROM HIGH SCHOOL. AND
EVEN MORE SHOCKINGLY ONLY 3%
WILL GRADUATE FROM COLLEGE
DESPITE THE FACT THAT IS- ACCORD
TO THE STATE THEY RECEIVED A
FREE RIDE TO ANY STATE SCHOOL.
YOU HAVE A SAYING THAT SAYS
THERE COMES A POINT WHERE WE
ADEQUATE PULLING PEOPLE OUT OF
THE RIVER AND WE HAVE TO TRAVEL
UPSTREAM AND FIND OUT WHY
THEY'RE FALLING IN. AND THE
REALITY IS- BUT IT MAJOR SOCIAL
ISSUES IF FOSTER CARE. TODAY
BEFORE YOU SENATOR GROW HIS
PROPOSED A BILL THAT IS AN
UPSTREAM BELL. KERN COUNTY WE
HAVE OVER TWO THOUSAND KIDS IN
FOSTER CARE- I AM ALISON MACLEAN
THE EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR AT
BAKERSFIELD ANGELS WHICH IS A
NON PROFIT- THAT EXISTS TO WRAP.
RELATIONAL AND RADICAL SUPPORT
AROUND OUR USE THAT ARE AGING
OUT OF FOSTER CARE. WE CURRENTLY
HAVE A HUNDRED AND EIGHTEEN AND
KIDS AND YOUTH IN FOSTER CARE
ARE COUNTY. AND THAT ARE MATCHED
IN OUR PROGRAMS. AND WE DO WHAT
THE THING EVERY DAY SUPPORT
THESE KIDS TO HELP LAUNCH THEM
FOR THE FUTURE THAT WE DO FOR
OUR OWN CHILDREN. AND SO WE DO
THINGS LIKE HELP THEM- I APPLIED
FOR COLLEGE BEFORE WE HELP THEM.
AND GET THEIR FIRST JOB OR WE
HELP THEM OBTAIN A DRIVER'S
LICENSE. WE HAVE TWELVE YOUTH
GRADUATING THIS MONTH FROM HIGH
SCHOOL TWELVE OUT OF TWELVE. SO
THAT THAT SHOWING US THAT WE CAN
USE A RADICALLY SUPPORTED THE
OUTCOMES CHANGE. THE REALITY THE
WE HAVE A OF LOCAL BUSINESSES
THAT WE PARTNER WITH TO GIVE
ARGUES SHOT. AND TO GIVE THEM
LIKE. BETTER ROADS BETTER CHANCE
AT A JOB BUT WE ALSO KNOW THAT
THEY DON'T ALWAYS NECESSARILY
MAKE THE VERY BEST EMPLOYEES AT
FIRST. THEY TEND TO BE
UNRELIABLE AND INCONSISTENT
BECAUSE THEY MODELED MODELED THE
ADULTS THAT THEY'VE HAD IN THEIR
OWN LIVES WHICH ARE UNRELIABLE
AND- INCONSISTENT. AND WHAT IS
IMPORTANT ABOUT THIS BILL IS
THIS IS A SENSE OF I MEAN.
BUSINESS IS TO GET THESE KIDS A
HAND UP NOT A HAND OUT. BECAUSE
WE KNOW WHEN WE HAVE TO BUILD AT
THE STATE LEVEL TO GIVE KIDS FOR
MONEY. IF YOU HAVE MORE MONEY.
FOR HAVING CHILDREN OR WHATEVER
IT MIGHT BE AND THEY DON'T
ALWAYS MAKE THE BEST DECISIONS
WITH THE MONEY WE HAND THEM OUT
OF MY FOR TEENAGE CHILDREN WOULD
NOT BY EITHER. AND SO RATHER
THAN USING IT TO PAY RENT OR
WHATEVER THEY'LL PROBABLY GO OUT
AND BUY THE LATEST IPHONE. AND
IT'S REALLY IMPORTANT THE BILL
IS THAT WE'RE INCENTIVIZING
BUSINESSES. TO HADES YOU FOR
ACTUALLY DOING WORK AND OTHER
PROGRAMS BUT INSTEAD OF PUTTING
THE MONEY IN THE HANDS OF THE
KIDS. WERE GIVEN IT TO LOCAL
BUSINESSES THAT. THAT THESE KIDS
LEARN TO WORK FOR IT. WHAT
SENATOR GROW SAID THE- TO
POVERTY IS. A J. O. E. AND- THE
OTHER REALLY GREAT. ABOUT THIS
BILL IS IT GOING TO GET BUSINESS
ON. A THE LAND IN TO OUR LOCAL
CARE. AND SO MANY DON'T KNOW. I
TELL YOU RIGHT AFTER TO GO. I
DID NOT KNOWN ANY OF THESE DID
AND I HEARD OF. AND A CHECK THAT
YOU'RE OF MY LIFE MOST BUSINESS
OWNERS DON'T KNOW EITHER AND SO
THIS BILL WILL ALLOW US TO PULL
BACK THE CURTAIN A LITTLE BIT
AND CHANGE THE LENS THROUGH
WHICH- BUSINESS OWNERS SEE ARE
AFTER YOUR COMMUNITY. YOU KNOW
WE HAVE BIG OPINIONS EVERYBODY
PROBABLY IN THIS ROOM ABOUT OUR
PRISON POPULATION OR HOMELESS
POPULATION. FOUR AND- H.
PREGNANCY AND ABORTION BILL THAT
ARE NOT ALWAYS IN MY OPINION
THAT WE CAN AGREE ON LIKE TO ASK
YOU TO PLEASE ARE UP UP QUICKLY.
YEAH WHAT ARE YOU. ABOUT SHOT
THAT THEY CAN. ADD A FEW. AND I
THIS BILL THAT I WRAPPED UP THE
STORE. AND ACTUALLY I KNOW FOR I
NEED TO SAY ONE MORE SENTENCE
AND THEN WE NEED TO MOVE ON I
APOLOGIZE. OKAY AT THE WORD OF
THE STATE IF YOU'RE ALONG TO US
AND WE CAN DO BETTER AND I
BELIEVE THIS BILL WILL ALLOW.
YOU THAT THE- GOOD THANK YOU.
SIGN BACK I'M NOT SURE OF BOTH
THE LEAD WITNESSES HAVE
TESTIFIED YES MA'AM. VERY GOOD
WILL MOVE ON TO WITNESSES IN THE
ROOM. MADAM CHAIR AND OTHER
MEMBERS PLAYER ON BEHALF OF THE
TULARE COUNTY BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS AND SUPPORT THANK
YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH IS
THERE ANYBODY ELSE IN THE ROOM.
SINGMAN WILL GO TO THE
CONFERENCE LINE. MISTER
MODERATOR CAN YOU QUEUE UP THOSE
THAT WOULD LIKE TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU IF YOU ARE IN
SUPPORT OF SB. FOURTEEN
HI MADAM CHAIR WE ARE GETTING
NOBODY TO QUEUE UP AT THE START.
VERY GOOD WILL MOVE ON TO-
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION WE HAVE
NO LEAD OPPOSITION WITNESSES SO
WE'LL SEE IF THERE'S ANYONE IN
THE ROOM THEY WOULD LIKE TO
TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION. THING
NINE WILL GO TO THE
TELECONFERENCE LINE. MISTER
MODERATOR IF YOU COULD QUEUE UP
THOSE IN OPPOSITION. IF YOU ARE
IN OPPOSITION TO THE SP ONE OF
FOUR REPORT PLEASE PRESS ONE
FOLLOWED BY ZERO AT THIS TIME
WHEN FILED BY ZERO. A MOMENT
MADAM CHAIR. WE ARE GETTING A
COUPLE TO QUEUE UP HERE ONE FALL
BY ZERO IF YOUR NOT POSITION TO
SB. FOURTEEN EIGHTY FOUR. AND WE
WERE LINE ONE TWENTY ONE YOU ARE
OPEN. ONE TWENTY ONE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. WHAT TWENTY ONE YOUR LINE
IS OPEN WOULD YOU LIKE TO
TESTIFY. ARE WILL MOVE ONE POINT
FIFTY FOUR YEAR OLD. HI KATIE
HARTMAN WITH THE CALIFORNIA
TEACHERS ASSOCIATION ON
UNFORTUNATELY OPPOSED THE BILL
WE UNDERSTAND THE INTENT- BUT
DON'T BELIEVE AND IT'S THEIR WAY
REVENUES MARKLE'S THE
FANTASTIQUE IS THE RIGHT
SOLUTION THANK YOU. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH X. PLEASE. THANK YOU
WILL GIVE ALL ONE FINAL TO
TESTIFY IT HAPPENS TO AS BEFORE
EIGHTY FOUR PLEASE PRESS ONE
ZERO. FIVE ONE THIRTY EIGHT YOU
ARE OPEN. WHAT WANT TO EIGHT WE
CAN HEAR YOU. WELCOME. TO I
THINK YOU TO OFF ONE OF YOUR
DEVICE BECAUSE WE'RE HERE AT. WE
WILL. ALWAYS THERE'S NO ELSE
ACUMEN CHAIR VERY GOOD WE'RE TO
BRING THE MATTER BACK TO THE-
COMMENTS MOTIONS YES CENTER
DRIVE YEAH- I SUPPORT THIS BILL
HAD A ASSUME BILL LET YEAR OF ON
THE HOMELESS HIRING TAX CREDIT
FOR BUSINESSES AND THAT WE
ACTUALLY DEVELOPED IT WITH
BUSINESSES WHO WANTED TO DO
THEIR PART IN ADDRESSING
HOMELESSNESS- AND SO IT WAS
REALLY IMPORTANT OBVIOUSLY I
TRULY BELIEVE IN A JOB AND THE
EXPERIENCE THAT COMES WITH THAT
DIGNITY THAT COMES WITH WITH IT
AND- SO ALL BE SUPPORTING- I
THINK THE- AND I THINK- SCOTT
CASH AND MISS MACLAINE. OFF FOR
THE SERVICES EVEN WITH A JOB OF
THOSE FOSTER YOUTH ARE GOING TO
NEED SUPPORT A LOT OF SUPPORT
AND WITHOUT THE SUPPORT AROUND
THEM THE AND THE THEIR EMPLOYER
MAY NOT SUCCEED SO- THAT'S ONE
THING I THINK WE NEED TO REMIND
OURSELVES THANK YOU. SENATOR
LUNAR. I'M THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIRMAN I- AND TERRY I SAID
THIS BILL AFTER TODAY AND I
THANK YOU FOR- FOR- FOR THE BILL
TO REALLY HELP- HOMELESS USE AND
FORMER FOSTER YOUTH TO BE ABLE
TO GET JOBS AND GET THEIR LIVES
BACK TOGETHER- I DO WANNA TO
NOTE- BUT I WASN'T ABLE TO
RESPOND TO THE AUTHORS ON THE
CLOTHES BEFORE BUT THERE THERE
IS ACTUALLY TI<c.cyan>- WE LOOK AT AND</c>
I'VE YOU KNOW I'VE- DONE A LOT
OF WORK AROUNDS- HOMES YOUTH IN
FOSTER YOUTH- 40% CASH IT'S NOT
40% ALMOST HALF. OF HOMELESS
YOUTH IDENTIFY AS LGBT- IN
ADDITION I ALSO BE T. TO YOU ARE
HAVEL OVER A IN THE FALL CARE-
SEEM ASK YOURSELF WHY IS A FIVE
THAT HOME THAT YOUNG PEOPLE ARE
SO INTENSELY OVER REPRESENTED
AMONG HOMELESS USE AND YOUTH IN
THE FOSTER CARE SYSTEM GREEN
LOOK AT USE OVERALL IN THE WORLD
IT'S NOT THE CASE THAT FORTY
PLUS PERCENT OF ALL YOUTH ARE.
WITH MUCH SMALLER PERCENTAGE BUT
ALMOST HALF OF HOMELESS YOUTH
ARE LGBTQ AND I DON'T KNOW WHAT
THE EXACT PERCENTAGES IN THE
FOSTER CARE SYSTEM BUT I'S VERY
HIGH WHY IS THAT THIS IS RANDOM
NO IT'S NOT RANDOM IT'S BECAUSE
OF THE WAY SOCIETY TREATS THESE
CODES THREE TO MY GARBAGE LIKE
GARBAGE PEOPLE THAT SOCIETY IS
TRYING TO RAISE THEIR OFFER
KICKED OUT OF THEIR HOMES THEIR
THEIR TREATED HORRIBLE SCHOOL-
THEY ARE TOLD FROM EARLY AGE BUT
THEY DON'T MATTER THAT THEY HAVE
NO WORTH- THAT THEY'RE FAKING IT
WE SEE THAT WITH TRANS KIDS ARE
PARTICULARLY TRYING TO SCAM YOUR
WAY ON TO SPORTS TEAM OR- INTO A
RESTROOM- THAT YOU'RE MAKING IT
UP AND- MANIPULATING. AND SO IS
IT ISN'T WONDER THE DISCO. STRAW
WITH RATES OF SO HARM. BUT ALSO
WITH HIGHER RATES OF HOMELESS.
AND AN ENTRANCE THE FOSTER CARE.
AND WITH TRAFFICKED. THIS IS A
ROUGH TO A BILL- A- A VERY
PROBLEMATIC TO. THAT THE SENATE
PUBLIC SAFETY COMMITTEE A FEW
WEEKS AGO THE DOT PASSED. OUT OF
COMMITTEE- AND SOME OF THE
BACKERS OF THAT BILL. SOME OF
WHOM. DO NOT HAVE STRONG RECORDS
IN SUPPORTING LGBTQ. CIVIL
RIGHTS- WORDS. REFERENCING LGBTQ
KIDS BEING TRAFFICKED. BETTER
SOMEONE LGBTQ ART BELL- AND I
THOUGHT IT WAS IMPORTANT TO
POINT OUT. THE WHY LGBTQ KIDS.
OR SOMETIMES TRAFFICKED WHEN
THEY'RE OUT ONE OUR STREETS AND
HAVE NO WAY TO TRY TO EVEN
SURVIVE AND ENGAGE IN SURVIVAL
SEX WORK THAT THAT'S REAL
BATTLES REAL IN OUR SOCIETY AND
THAT IS BECAUSE OF THE WAY THERE
TREATED BY OUR SOCIETY. AND YEAH
ONE PEOPLE LIKE RHONDA SANDERSON
GREAT JOB IT AND ALL THESE
PEOPLE ARE TRYING TO LITERALLY
SAY THAT YOU'RE NOT ALLOWED TO
TALK ABOUT WHO YOU ARE IN SCHOOL
BUT IT'S A LEGAL. T. EVEN TALK
ABOUT WHO YOU ARE AS A HUMAN
BEING IN SCHOOL OR THAT YOU'RE
GONNA BE TAKEN AWAY FROM YOUR
PARENTS AND YOUR PARENTS PUT IN
JAIL. BECAUSE THEY SUPPORT
HEALTH CARE FOR THE TRANS KID
THAT'S NOT POLITICIZING
ANYTHING. THAT'S EXPLAINING WHY
SO MANY OF THESE KIDS ARE ON THE
STREET WHY SO MANY OF THESE KIDS
ARE IN FOSTER CARE. WHY SO MANY
OF THESE KIDS QUESTION THEIR OWN
WORTH AND ENGAGE IN SELF HARM
THAT'S NOT POLITICS. THAT IS
POLITICS AND POLITICS BY CERTAIN
POLITICIANS WHO WERE TRYING TO.
THAT WHEREVER THEY'RE TRYING TO
GO ON THE BACKS OF CHILDREN. AND
THAT EXPLAINS WHY THESE CHILDREN
SUFFER SO MUCH- AND SO I JUST
WANT TO EXPRESS AND I'M GLAD
THAT YOU'RE PUSHING FOR THIS
BILL THIS IS A GOOD BILL AND I
SUPPORT A HUNDRED PERCENT- AND
IF WE CAN HELP THESE KIDS. ON
GET OFFICE. EXISTS ACCESS FULLY
OUT OF FOSTER CARE GET THEM JOBS
THAT'S FANTASTIC AND I COMMEND
YOU FOR BRINGING THIS BILL BUT I
DID THINK IT WAS IMPORTANT. TO
SERVE EXPLAINED- THESE OTHER
DYNAMICS THAT ARE VERY VERY VERY
REAL THANK YOU. THE COMMENTS
QUESTIONSJUST WANT TO SAY THANK
YOU FOR INTRODUCING THIS BELT-
THERE'S NO QUESTION THAT- YOU
KNOW WE TAKE WE TAKE THE ISSUES.
IN PIECES AND TRY TO SOLVE THEM
OUT LITTLE BY LITTLE AND- MANY
TIMES THERE THERE'S A MUCH
BROADER ISSUE THAT- BECOMES
DIFFICULT TO GET OUR ARMS AROUND
AND THE WHOLE ISSUE OF FOSTER
CARE HAS- HAS LONG BEEN A
CHALLENGE BECAUSE WE WANT TO
PROTECT KIDS BUT SOMETIMES WHEN
THEY GET INTO THE FOSTER CARE
SYSTEM THEY JUST DON'T GET THE
HELP THEY NEED- AND I KNOW
BECAUSE I'VE- I'VE DONE A LOT OF
WORK- IN. IN THAT SYSTEM AND
IT'S FRUSTRATING- HOW LITTLE
SUPPORT FOSTER KIDS GET IN THE
END OF DAY MAY BE SAFE FOR IT
FOR SOME OF THEM DURING THE
EIGHTEEN YEARS THAT THEY'RE THAT
THERE ARE CONSIDERED MINERS BUT%
THEN AFTER THAT IT'S VERY
DIFFICULT FOR THEM- BECAUSE THEY
DON'T HAVE ANY FAMILY SUPPORT IN
AS WE KNOW FAMILY SUPPORT IS. IS
EVERYTHING IN OUR IN OUR
COMMUNITY SO WE GOT TO CREATE
OUR OWN FAMILY SO THANK YOU FOR
BRINGING THIS FORWARD- WE DO
HAVE A MOTION- THE MOTION IS TO
PASS AS AMENDED THE FIRST
AMENDED RE REFER TO THE
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS SO
WE'RE GONNA LET YOU CAN CLICK.
THANK YOU THANK YOU MA'AM SURE
THANK YOU FOR YOUR COMMENTS I
APPRECIATE THAT MY COLLEAGUE
FROM SAN FRANCISCO THANK YOU FOR
SUPPORTING THE BILL AND ALSO MY
CALLING FROM LOS ANGELES- BUT
WHAT MISC. SAID I TOUCH MY HEART
BECAUSE IT IT IS TRUE YOU KNOW
MOST OF YOU KNOW THAT I OWN OF
EMPLOYMENT STAFFING COMPANY AND
WE PUT AT RISK KIDS SECOND
CANCERS SUCH AS OUR OIL INDUSTRY
PROS PROVIDES A 55% OF THE
PEOPLE THAT WORK IN THE OIL
INDUSTRY OUR SECOND CANCERS AND
MOST OF THEM WOULD HAVE GONE
BACK TO PRISON HAD THEY NOT AND
THE HAVE THESE JOBS THAT PAY
WELL OVER A HUNDRED THOUSAND
DOLLARS A YEAR. BUT I THINK A
LOT OF IN THE OIL HER CULTURE
YEAH ARE THE BOILING YEAH REALLY
OIL ENACT. EMPLOY MAY NOT HAVE
TAKEN THE- CHANCE ON SOMEONE- IT
THE I. RE DO BELIEVE THAT WOULD
HAVE TAKEN THAT CHANCE ON
SOMEONE IF THERE WASN'T SOME
BENEFIT SO THAT IF THEY DID HAVE
ALL THESE PROBLEMS THEY WOULD AT
LEAST HAVE SOME WAY TO RECOUP
SOME OF THEIR LOSSES THROUGH TAX
CREDIT. AND BUT THESE PROGRAMS
FOR SECOND CHANCE THERE'S A
MILITARY VETERANS HAS AND- HAVE
BEEN VERY BENEFICIAL AND IF YOU
LOOK AT THE DATA- THERE'S A HUGE
PERCENT OF SUCCESS. WHEN YOU GET
SOMEONE A JOB. AND YOU'RE RIGHT
WE DON'T DO ENOUGH FOR FOSTER
CARE AND YOU. THEY GET SOME OF
THESE PLACES GET SIX SEVEN
THOUSAND DOLLARS A MONTH FOR
THESE GROUP HOMES IN THESE KIDS
WALK OUT OF THERE WITH NOTHING.
BUT A PILLOWCASE OR SUITCASE- IF
THEY'RE LUCKY AND SO WE DON'T
OFFER. A YOU KNOW WRAP AROUND
SERVICES I APPLIED- BAKER STILL
THE JEWELS. AND DEBT THAT- ERR
IF YOU'RE A COMMUNITIES
PARTNERSHIP WITH THE ALLIANCE
WITH WHAT THEY DO. TO WRAPAROUND
SERVICES FOR FOSTER CARE YOUTH
WE'RE BUILDING A FACILITY IN
BAKERSFIELD FOR. HOMELESS
TRANSITION WE'VE DEDICATED
TWENTY OF THOSE UNITS TO
SPECIFICALLY FOSTER CARE.
BECAUSE THEY IN AND IT HAS
ACCOUNTABILITY IN RAP BROWN
SERVICES AND- BECAUSE WE NEED
THAT. AND WE'RE ALSO DOING A
THING CALLED FOREVER FAMILIES IN
OUR COMMUNITY WHICH I WHICH WAS
ADOPTED THROUGHOUT THE STATE
BECAUSE EVEN THOUGH YOU'RE
EIGHTEEN. YOU STILL NEED A
FAMILY TO GO HOME TO AND HAVE
THANKSGIVING WITH CHRISTMAS.
MAYBE TALK TO THE YOU KNOW YOUR
SUMMIT ADULT ABOUT. BUYING A CAR
OR OPENING A CHECKING ACCOUNT OR
YOU NEED THE SKILL SETS THAT A
LOT OF OUR FORMER. FOSTER YOUTH
HER FOSTER HOMELESS YOU DON'T
HAVE. AND SO I REALLY APPRECIATE
THE AYE VOTE I APPRECIATE THE
SUPPORT ON THIS BILL AND I LOOK
FORWARD. HOPEFULLY TO GETTING IT
PASSED. THE YOU VERY MUCH THE
MORE. IS TO PASS AS AMEND BUT
FIRST AMEND AND RE REFER TO THE
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. SENATORS
CAPITO HI CABALLERO HI NIELSEN.
NIELSEN HI TO ROSEAU. ROSEAU HI
HERTZBERG. HERTZBERG FIVE
WINNER. WINNER HI. THANK YOU
SIR. FIVE ZERO FIVE ZERO THE
BILL IS OUT. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH- LOOKING AROUND TO SEE IF
SENATOR STERN IS HERE HE IS NOT
SO WE'RE GONNA MOVE ON TO
SENATOR BURGESS WELCOME. WE'LL
START WITH S. B. TWELVE SIXTY
SIX. AND I IF I COULD JUST TO
THE COMMITTEE THAT- WE HAVE ONE
HEARING THAT WILL BE FAIRLY
CONTENTIOUS IT'LL PROBABLY TAKE
A SIGNIFICANT AMOUNT OF TIME SO
WE PROBABLY NEED TO MOVE THROUGH
THE BILLS- QUICKER YES. WELCOME
I THAT WAS MY CUE TO GO QUICKLY
. A GOOD MORNING- MADAM CHAIR
AND MEMBERS I THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO PRESENT S. B.
TWELVE SIXTY SIX FIRST I WANT TO
SAY THANK YOU FOR SHARING
COMMITTEE STAFFER CONTINUE TO
WORK WITH ME ON THIS IMPORTANT
ISSUE. SENATE BILL TWELVE SIX
SIX SIX TO CREATE A 50% STATE
TAX CREDIT ON THE PURCHASE OF A
BACK GENERATOR FOR A BACKUP
BATTERY FOR RESIDENTS AND SMALL
BUSINESSES LOOK WITHIN TWO
THREE. OF THE C. SEES FIRES MAP
WHICH ARE STATES MOST BY PRONE
AREAS I THINK- MOST EVERYBODY
HERE INCLUDING CENTERS HERTZBERG
AND CENTERS DRAWS- NIELSEN
CABALLERO I THINK WE ALL HAVE- A
SENTIR THREE TERRITORIES. IN
TWENTY TWENTY ONE CALIFORNIA'S
WEALTH SEES WAS THIS WORST
WILDFIRE SEASON ON RECORD BERNIE
MORE THAN TWO AND A HALF
MILLION. ACRES ACROSS THE STATE
CALIFORNIA'S LIVING AND WORKING
DESIGNATE A WILDFIRE ZONES FACE
SEVERAL UNCERTAINTIES
SURROUNDING NOT ONLY THE THREAT
OF WILDFIRES. BUT THE EFFECTS OF
THEM AS WELL. LAST YEAR
INDIVIDUALS AND BUSINESSES IN
TOWARD EIGHTEEN MAJOR PUBLIC
SAFETY POWER SHUT OFFS OTHERWISE
KNOWN AS PSP PS EVENTS. WHICH
LEFT THEM WITHOUT POWER FOR
SEVERAL HOURS IN A MORE EXTREME
INSTANCES MULTIPLE DAYS. THROUGH
NO FAULT OF THEIR OWN
INDIVIDUALS AND BUSINESSES ARE
LEFT WITHOUT POWER UNTIL IT CAN
BE SAFELY RESTORED. AMONG THE
MANY PROBLEMS REPORTED RESIDENTS
LOST FOOD. MEDICALLY FRAGILE
CUSTOMER STRUGGLE TO ACCESS
POWER FOR LIFE SUSTAINING
MEDICAL EQUIPMENT BUSINESSES
SUFFERED ECONOMIC LOSSES
CUSTOMERS LACKED ACCESS TO POWER
TO CHARGE ELECTRONIC DEVICES
NECESSARY TO OBTAIN SAFETY
INFORMATION. AND CELL TOWERS
LACKED ADEQUATE POWER RAISING
PUBLIC SAFETY CONCERNS. HAVING
BACKUP GENERATION READILY
AVAILABLE HELPS MITIGATE THE
NEGATIVE IMPACTS INDIVIDUALS AND
BUSINESSES WITHIN THESE AREAS
FACE WHEN POWER IS LOST. THIS
BILL SEEKS TO RELIEVE INDIVIDUAL
AND BUSINESS AND SIX FIRE AREA
OF A PORTION FINANCIAL BURDEN
ASSOCIATE WITH THE COST OF THE
EXPENSIVE EQUIPMENT TO ENSURE
THEY CAN MEET THEIR SPECIFIC
POWER NEEDS. AND PREVENT FURTHER
HARDSHIPS FACED DURING
CALIFORNIA'S WILDFIRE SEASON
HERE WITH ME TODAY I HAVE LAURIE
pBUSINESS CALIFORNIA TESTIFYING
IN SUPPORT OF S. B. TWELVE SIX
SIX. LORI KAMMER THANK COMMITTEE
AND SHAKE YOU MADAM CHAIR VICE
CHAIR CAN MEMBERS LAURIE CAN
WITH SMALL BUSINESS CALIFORNIA
AND I ALSO DID NOT GET A LETTER
IN QUICKLY ENOUGH BUT- ALSO HERE
ON BEHALF OF THE NATIONAL
ASSOCIATION OF WOMEN. BUSINESS
OWNERS CALIFORNIA CHAPTER- IS
AS- MANY OF YOU KNOW I ALSO DO A
LOT OF PUBLIC AFFAIRS FOR THE
SMALL BUSINESS DEVELOPMENT
CENTERS. AND I HAVE HEARD- YOU
KNOW ALL OF THE PROBLEMS THAT
THEY'VE HAD TO GO THROUGH WITH
NOT JUST WILDFIRES. COVE IT AND
THEN MORE WILDFIRES AND THEN
ANOTHER ROUND OF COVED AND THEN
MORE WILDFIRES HIGH WINDS
FORCING THEM TO SHUT THEIR
BUSINESSES AS YOU ALL KNOW I
NOTED THAT YOU HAVE HEARD FROM
YOUR CONSTITUENTS. HOW DIFFICULT
THE LAST THREE YEARS HAVE BEEN-
THIS BILL IS JUST A VERY
IMPORTANT FOR SMALL BUSINESSES
WHO HAVE HAD TO PIVOT AND THE
WORD THAT WE HAVE SO OVER USED
AND HOPEFULLY WE DON'T HAVE TO
USE AGAIN BUT- ANOTHER POINT. TO
IS THAT- BY BRINGING IN THE
BATTERIES IN THE GENERATORS THAT
THE- THE BUSINESSES CAN STAY IF
THOSE THAT WERE SHUT DOWN. MOVE
TO ONLINE AND SO SELLING THEIR
PRODUCTS ONLINE THESE ARE THE
COMMUNITY- OUR BUSINESS IS A
COMMITTEE STORES THE PEOPLE THAT
LIVE IN THE COMMUNITY- THIS ALSO
IS IMPORTANT BECAUSE IT KEEPS
OUR CLASSROOMS OPENED. IT WE
NEED TO HAVE POWER IN THE
CLASSROOM PARENTS NEED TO GO TO
WORK THERE'S A SMALL BUSINESSES
IN YOUR YOUR DISTRICTS SO I
RESPECTFULLY. ASK FOR YOUR I.
PHONE. THANK YOU MUCH. IS THERE
ANYBODY ELSE IN ROOM THAT WOULD
LIKE TO TEST FINDS. THING THEN
WE'LL GO ON TO THE
TELECONFERENCE LINE MISTER
MODERATOR FEW COULD PROMPT
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT S. B.
TWELVE SIXTY SIX. THANK YOU
MEDICARE IF YOU ARE IN SUPPORT
OF S. B- TWELVE SIXTY SIX PLEASE
TAKE THIS OPPORTUNITY PRESS ONE
FOLLOWED BY ZERO. ONE BLOW BY
ZERO AT THIS TIME. AND WE HAVE
ONE QUEUING UP ONE MOMENT PLEASE
FOR ANYBODY ELSE PLEASE PRESS
ONE FOLLOWED BY. MADAM CHAIR
THAT PERSON SHOULD BE WITH THIS
MOMENTARILY VERY GOOD APPLE
THANK YOU. IN LINE ONE SIXTY ONE
YOU ARE OPEN. HELLO I WOULD LIKE
TO- LET YOU GUYS KNOW THAT
CALIFORNIANS WILL NOT SURVIVE IF
YOU COULD INCREASE THE TAX ON
THE GAS. BEFORE YOU HAVING A
HARD TIME WHEN THE INFORMATION
ON GROCERIES ON OUR DAILY
EXPENSES AND I AND IT'S
DEFINITELY GOING TO AFFECT US IN
A NEGATIVE WAY. THANK YOU NEXT
PLEASE. THERE ARE NO OTHER
PARTICIPANTS CUED UP MEDICARE
VERY GOOD WE'RE GOING TO MOVE ON
TO OPPOSITION WE HAVE NO LEAD
OPPOSITION WITNESSES NOTED IS
THERE ANYONE IN ROOM TWENTY TWO
HUNDRED AND BEEN SAYING THE
WRONG NUMBER SO- TWENTY TWO
HUNDRED THAT. WOULD LIKE TO
TESTIFY. SINGMAN WILL MOVE ON TO
THE TELECONFERENCE LINE. THE
MODERATOR IF YOU COULD CHECK IF
THERE'S ANYONE IN OPPOSITION.
YOUR IN OPPOSITION TO SB TWELVE
SIXTY SIX. PLEASE PRESS ONE
ZERO. AND OUR FIRST PARTICIPANT
IS WHITE FIFTY FOUR PLEASE GO
AHEAD. RIGHT THE HARD ABOUT THE
HEALTH TEACHERS ARE. AND THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. WE'LL GIVE A ONE.
FINAL ARE RE ONE ZERO IF YOU
WERE IN OPPOSITION TO SB. TWELVE
SIXTY SIX. I KNOW ELSE'S QUEUING
UP MADAM CHAIR VERY GOOD WILL
BRING THAT MATTER BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE AND SEE IF THERE'S
ANYBODY THAT HAS ANY QUESTIONS
COMMENTS CONCERNS. SINGMAN I'LL
ENTERTAIN A MOTION. SO MOVE
THERE IS A MOTION BY SENATOR
NIELSEN. WILL ALLOW YOU TO.
CONCLUDE THANK GOODNESS THEY
TERMINATE BUT THAT JUST SEEMS
LIKE THE WRONG. MICHAEL G. I
THINK WE ALL KNOW THAT WE ARE
EVOLVING AS A STATE MOVING INTO
ALTERNATIVE ENERGIES IN THE MOST
COMMONPLACE- THIS IS AN
OPPORTUNITY TO HELP ADVANCE THAT
CAUSE AS WELL- THROUGH THE TAX
CREDIT FOR BATTERIES SO IT'S SO
NOT ONLY DOES THAT HELP
INDIVIDUALS IN THESE VERY UNIQUE
HERE'S THE SO THIS IS A VERY
DISCREET. FIVE HIGHEST HIGHEST
RISK TERRITORY WITHIN THE STATE-
OF THAT BUT IT ALSO SERVES AS A
SUPPORT MECHANISM FOR THE
STATE'S OVERALL AGENDA MAKING- A
REDUCTION IN OUR CARBON
FOOTPRINT- IN LASTLY- I THINK-
BY THE UP THE SOLE OPPOSITION
THAT WE HEARD- I'M NOT CERTAIN
WHY THAT OCCURS BECAUSE THIS IS
A GENERAL FUND ASK- FOR- FOR
THIS TYPE OF TAX CREDIT AND SO
BASED ON WHAT I WAS ABLE TO-
DISCERN. IS THAT I THINK ANY
OPPOSITION AB WE'RE GONNA
STATION JUST RELYING ON GENERAL
FUND DOLLARS SO I DON'T IT'S NOT
ON THE MERITS THE BILL IS MY
UNDERSTANDING OF BOTH THAT BEING
SAID WE ALL SUFFER FROM
WILDFIRES IN SOME OF ITS ALLIES
SUFFER EVEN MORE ACUTELY AS I
MENTIONED BEFORE MOST EVERYBODY
HERE I'M WITH THE EXCEPTION
POSSIBLY SENATOR WIENER-
EVERYBODY HERE HAS SOME TIER
THREE WITHIN THEIR COMMUNITIES
AND SO THIS IS AN OPPORTUNITY
FOR US TO HELP THOSE MOST
IMPACTED MAKE THE MOST
CONSEQUENTIAL- INVESTMENTS IN
OUR COMMUNITY. NOT ONLY TO
SURVIVE DURING WILDFIRES BUT
ALSO TO KEEP BUSINESSES AND IN
IN. FOR WITH A RESPECTFULLY ASK
YOU AYE THE- BREAK FOR THE MATH
MOTION IS TO AND WE REFER TO
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATE. PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL SENATORS. HI
PROBABLY AT I NIELSEN. NEIL
DURAZO THE ROAD- HERTZBERG- I
HEARD. FIVE WIENER. WIENER I.
FIVE ZERO THE MOTION PASSES FIVE
TWO ZERO. NEXT UP ON OUR AGENDA
IS. DID IT IS THE US SENATOR
BRADFORD HE'S NOT HERE MAYBE
THIS WOULD BE A GOOD TIME FOR
SENATOR HERTZBERG TO JUMP IN AND
TAKE HIS FELLOW. WILL FILL IN
BECAUSE WE NEED TO MOVE ON THE
MOVE OR GENDER ABSOLUTELY- ITEM
NUMBER SIXTEEN THE AGENDA SB
THIRTEEN FORTY BY CENTER
HERTZBERG. THIS IS ONE OF THOSE
BORING BILLS THAT ARE
FUNDAMENTAL TO. THE
INFRASTRUCTURE WHAT WE NEED TO
DO TO INCENTIVIZE THE CONVERSION
OF OUR ELECTRIC GRID. YOU KNOW
WE SET THESE GOALS FOR TWENTY
FORTY FIVE TWENTY THIRTY WE TALK
ABOUT ALL THIS STUFF BUT AS I
ALWAYS LIKE TO SAY GOD IS IN THE
DETAILS. AND THIS IS ONE OF
THOSE THINGS THAT- WE HAVE A-
TAX CREDIT FOR THESE LARGE SOLAR
FACILITIES GONNA IT'S GONNA
EXPIRE IN TWENTY TWENTY FOUR.
AND SO WHAT WE'VE DONE HERE IS
WE'RE EXTENDING IT AND TRYING TO
REACH A COMPROMISE WITH THOSE
JURISDICTIONS. THAT HAVE THE
GREATER BURDEN OF HOW THE- OF-
HOUSING THOSE THOSE OF LARGER
FACILITIES. I WANT TO THANK THE
COMMITTEE. STAFF FOR THEIR WORK
WITH RESPECT TO THIS MEASURE AND
PURSUANT TO COMMENT SIX MADAM
CHAIR I WOULD OF BE AMENDING
THIS MEASURE TO DO TWO THINGS
FIRST. VERIFY THAT IF IT'S ALL
OCCURS DURING THE PHASE DOWN THE
NOTED UNDER THE NEW SECTION
SEVENTY THREE POINT TWO. THEN
THE PROJECT COULD BECOME A 100%
TAXABLE IN LINE WITH THE CURRENT
LAW AND SECONDLY AS SET FORTH IN
COMMENTS SIX. FIXING A DRAFTING
ERROR IN THE BILL TO CLARIFY THE
PERCENTAGES OF THE STEP DOWNS TO
MATCH MY STATED INTENT WE'RE
CNCERNED ABOUT IS THAT WE NEED
TO HAVE A COMPETITIVE ADVANTAGE
WE NEED TO LOCATE THESE
FACILITIES IN THE STATE. RATHER
HAVING. THE RENEWABLE ENERGY-
OCCURRING OUTSIDE THE STATE FOR
A HOST OF OTHER REASONS
INCLUDING GETTING WORK FOR OUR
PEOPLE HERE IN CALIFORNIA. AND
THE LIKE WITH ME I HAVE SHANNON
EDDIE FOR THE LARGE SCALE SOLAR
ASSOCIATION RICK YOU MONTH WITH
THE SOLAR ENERGY INDUSTRIES
ASSOCIATION RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR VOTE. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
WE'RE GONNA START WITH YOUR LEAD
WITNESS IN SUPPORT. KENNEDY
LARGE SCALE SOLAR ASSOCIATION
THANK YOU. FOR A GOOD MORNING
MENTION ANY VIRTUAL SOURCES
ASIAN THANKS FOR THE TIME AND
THE OPPORTUNITY TO PRESENT ON
THE BILL WELL THAT'S ACTUALLY
GONNA BE FOLLOWING MY COLLEAGUES
SO HE'S GOING TO DO SOME STAGE
SETTING BUT I WILL SAY THAT
CALIFORNIA IS GOING TO BE
BRINGING ON ABOUT SEVENTY
THOUSAND MAY WANT OF UTILITY
SCALE SOLAR. IN THE NEXT TWENTY
YEARS AND SO WHAT THIS BILL DOES
IS IT STRIKES A CAREFUL BALANCE
BETWEEN MAKING SURE THAT THE-
COUNTIES ARE COMPENSATED. FOR
CITING THE PROJECTS BUT AT THE
SAME TIME. THE RATE PAYERS ARE
NOT DUE UNTIL THE BURDENS WITH A
NEW TAXATION. THE OTHER ELEMENT
OF THIS BILL HELPS TO- RETAIN
COMPETITIVENESS BETWEEN
CALIFORNIA AND THE NEIGHBORING
STATES TAX STRUCTURES. TO HELP
PREVENT ACCIDENTS OF PROJECTS
FROM CALIFORNIA TO THE OTHER
STATES- WE APPRECIATE THE WORK
OF THE COMMITTEE STAFF ON THIS
IS A PRETTY TECHNICAL BILL. WE
ENGAGED EARLY WITH THE COUNTIES
AND ALSO WITH THE ASSESSOR'S.
HAVING GOOD PRODUCTIVE
DISCUSSIONS WITH THEM AS WELL
AND ALSO. APPRECIATE THE SUPPORT
OF BOTH THE IRON WORKERS FOUND
THAT LABOUR'S. THANKS FOR TIME.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. THE WE HAVE
RICK ON- MAAF IS FROM THE SOLAR
ENERGY INDUSTRIES ASSOCIATION
WELCOME. THANK YOU OF MADAM
CHAIR AND COMMITTEE MEMBERS-
YEAH MY NAME IS RAJKUMAR FROM
WITH THE SOLAR ENERGY INDUSTRIES
ASSOCIATION- WE ARE THAT
NATIONAL ASSOCIATION FOR THE
SOLAR INDUSTRY- AND I WANT TO
EXPRESS OUR SUPPORT FOR SB
THIRTEEN FORTY. THE BILL IS
CRITICAL TO HELPING THE STATE
MEETS LONG TERM CLIMATE ENERGY
RELIABILITY NEEDS IN A MANNER
THAT KEEPS CALIFORNIA
COMPETITIVE WITH NEIGHBORING
STATES INSURERS OF TENS OF
THOUSANDS OF SOLAR JOBS STAY IN
CALIFORNIA. BY RECOGNIZING THE
IMPORTANT ROLE THE SOLAR ENERGY
WITH PLAYING CALIFORNIA'S ENERGY
MIX THE CALIFORNIA VOTERS PASSED
PROP SEVEN IN NINETEEN EIGHTY
THIS AUTHORIZED THE CAT THE
LEGISLATURE TO EXCLUDE THE
CONSTRUCTION SOLAR ENERGY SINCE
. FROM THE PHOENICIAN UP NEW
COULD. FOR THE PURPOSE OF
PROPERTY TAXATION. SO APPROACH
IS REAL HELP TO BRING DOWN THE
COST OF SOLAR AND IT IS SUCH
THAT NOW IT IS ONE OF THE MOST
COMPETITIVE PRICE RESOURCES. IN
THE STATE'S ENERGY MIX. AND THIS
IS VERY CRITICAL TO HELPING THE
STATE MANAGES COSTS BECAUSE WE
CONTINUE GO FORWARD HOP AND WE
TRIPLE THE GRID SIZE OVER THE
NEXT TWENTY YEARS. FURTHER AND
IMPORTANTLY SB THIRTEEN FORTY.
ONE FOR THE HOMEOWNERS AND SMALL
BUSINESSES THAT USE TO INVEST IN
CLEAN ENERGY ARE NOT
UNNECESSARILY BURDENED BY HIGHER
COSTS. FOR THESE REASONS WE URGE
YOUR AYE VOTE TODAY I ALSO WANT
TO THANK THE- LEADERSHIP OF
CENTER HERTZBERG ON THIS MATTER
AS WELL THANK YOU. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH IS THERE ANYONE ELSE
IN THE ROOM THAT WOULD LIKE TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT. A GOOD
MORNING MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS
COMMITTEE HELPER TO RECALL. MATH
OF SOMEONE IN SUPPORT THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. GOOD MORNING MADAM
CHAIR AND MEMBERS DELANEY HUNTER
ON BEHALF OF FOR FRONT OF POWER
A REFUND EDF RENEWABLES AN EDP
RENEWABLES ALL STRUCK SUPPORT
THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
SEEING NO FURTHER TESTIMONY IN
THE ROOM WE'RE GOING TO MOVE ON
TO THE TELECONFERENCE LINE
MISTER MODERATOR FEW COULD
PROMPT THOSE INDIVIDUALS THAT
WOULD LIKE TO TEST FOR IN
SUPPORT OF S. B. THIRTEEN FORTY.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR IF YOU ARE
IN SUPPORT OF SB THIRTEEN FORTY
WE TAKE THIS OPPORTUNITY PRESS
ONE FOLLOWED BY ZERO AND WE WILL
BEGIN WITH BY ONE THIRTY TWO.
YOU ARE OPEN.
ONE MORE SHOT ONE ONE THIRTY TWO
WOULD YOU LIKE US TO FIVE. NOW
WILL MOVE UNDERLYING ONE SIXTY
SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
MORNING COULD MAINTAIN ON BEHALF
OF INTERFACE OUR SUPPORT SB
THIRTY FORTY FEET YOU. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. ONE ONE SIXTY SEVEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. THE MORNING
LIVE GRILLING FROM KP PUBLIC
AFFAIRS ON BEHALF OF CYPRESS
CREEK RENEWABLES IN SUPPORT
ABOUT THE THIRTEEN FORTY THANK
YOU. THANK YOU NEXT PLEASE FIND
THIRTY EIGHT THANK YOU I'M
THIRTY EIGHT THE COLLAPSE. THANK
YOU CANTONE OF THE OWN ADVOCACY
ON BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
SOLAR AND STORAGE ASSOCIATION IN
INTO THE ETHICS REPORT. THANK
YOU. THE FINAL REMINDER TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT FOR SB THIRTY
FORTY PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO AT
THIS TIME ONE SIXTY EIGHT EUROPE
. ON BEHALF OF THE INDEPENDENT
ENERGY PRODUCERS AND SUPPORT.
ONE ONE SIXTY FIVE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. BERNADETTE HELLO THAN
WHAT THE WHITE AMEND GRIP ON
BEHALF OF AB ASKED IN SHOCK
RIGHT. MADAM CHAIR NO OTHER
PARTICIPANTS QUEUED UP VERY GOOD
WE'RE GOING TO MOVE ON TO
OPPOSITE THAT WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION WE HAVE ONE LEAD
OPPOSITION WITNESS PAUL YEAR
YODER FROM KERN COUNTY. THANK
YOU MADAM CHAIR AND OTHER
MEMBERS OF YOUR SHUTTER INTO
SCHMELZER LAND WE HAVE THE KERN
COUNTY BOARD OF SUPERVISORS NOT
SURE OF THEIR YES OKAY GREAT SO
THE STATEWIDE ASSOCIATIONS. HAVE
EXPRESSED CONCERNS BILL TO. THE
THRESHOLD QUESTION WITH THIS
BILL IN THIS POLICY IS. THIS IS
A STATE OF CALIFORNIA WANT TO
CONTINUE TO SUBSIDIZE A LARGE
SCALE SOLAR INDUSTRY IN
CALIFORNIA. ALMOST EXCLUSIVELY
ON THE BACKS OF KERN COUNTY AND
THE RESIDENTS OF KERN COUNTY
BECAUSE THAT IS WHAT HAS
HAPPENED FOR OVER A DECADE NOW.
KERN COUNTY HAS APPROVED SOLAR
PROJECTS IN GOOD FAITH BASED ON
THE LEGISLATIVE INTENT TO SUNSET
THE SOLAR TAX EXCLUSION. WE'VE
DONE THIS EXCLUSION NOW MULTIPLE
TIMES. SO IN GOOD FAITH KERN
COUNTY WENT ALONG WITH THIS
EXTENSIONS OF THIS TAX BREAK TO
COMMERCIAL LARGE SCALE SOLAR HAS
COST KERN COUNTY A HUNDRED AND
TEN MILLION OR LESS TEN YEARS TO
MEMBERS IMAGINE SAN BENITO
LOSING A HUNDRED MILLION OVER
TEN YEARS. SHASTA SAN FRANCISCO
LOS ANGELES. LOSING THAT SAME
AMOUNT OF MONEY AND CAN AGAIN
THIS I THINK AS YOU ALL KNOW
THIS IS ONE OF THE MOST
DISADVANTAGED PARTS OF
CALIFORNIA. SO FIFTEEN YEARS AGO
THIS WAS A NEW AN EMERGING
EMERGING INDUSTRY IT ISN'T
ANYMORE IT'S A STABLE. LONG TERM
INDUSTRY IN CALIFORNIA. THE
COUNTIES FISCAL LOSSES HAVE
SUBSIDIZE GREEN ELECTRONS
THROUGHOUT CALIFORNIA. NOW
MATURE ESTABLISHED INDUSTRIES
AND ADJUSTMENTS NEED TO BE MADE
. THE COUNTY CONTINUES TO
BELIEVE SOLAR CAN BE A GOOD
CORPORATE CITIZEN A LONG TERM
INVESTMENT PART PARTNERS IN
CALIFORNIA. THERE'S A GOLDEN
OPPORTUNITY HERE MEMBERS AND
WE'VE BEEN DISCUSSING WITH THE
NEW SOME ADMINISTRATION.
LANGUAGE CAN BE MORE CAREFULLY
AND MORE THOUGHTFULLY CRAFTED
WITH ALL DUE RESPECT TO RESHAPE
ANY TAX CREDIT IN A WAY THAT
MAKES THESE INVESTMENTS MORE
ATTRACTIVE FOR COUNTIES IN
CALIFORNIA. THERE'S A WAY TO DO
THIS THAT WILL ACTUALLY GROW
LARGE SCALE SOLAR RATHER THAN
HAVE THIS TENSION AND WHAT IS
INCREASINGLY FEELING LIKE A
FIGHT. I'M GONNA STOP THERE AND-
LET'S SEE SACRAMENTO'S
REPRESENTED C. SIX WEEKS I WOULD
ASK FOR A NO VOTE UNTIL THE
LANGUAGE CAN BE CHANGED SO THAT
IT BETTER INCENTIVISES LARGE
SCALE SOLAR IN CALIFORNIA THANK
YOU. JEFF NEAL WITH THE
CALIFORNIA STATE ASSOCIATION OF
COUNTIES. WE CAME IN WITH THE
CONCERNS POSITION TO THIS
COMMITTEE. WE DO APPRECIATE THAT
THE- SOLAR. INDUSTRY AND THE
AUTHOR I RECOGNIZE THAT THERE
ARE SOME- SOME REVENUE FROM
THESE PROJECTS- SHOULD GO TO THE
COMMUNITIES WHERE THERE CITED-
WOULD LIKE TO CONTINUE WORKING
WITH THEM TO. TO SEE WHAT THE
APPROPRIATE BALANCES AS- AS MY
COLLEAGUE WAS. I WAS TALKING
ABOUT BECAUSE OF THE CONCERN
THAT THIS- THIS THIS A SUBSIDY
WE WILL THEY AND AN INCENTIVE OR
SUBSIDY IS BORN A PREDOMINANTLY
BY. RURAL AREAS THAT HAPPEN TO
BE SUNNY- FOR THE BENEFIT OF
EVERYONE IN THE STATE. AS A
WOULD LIKE TO. CONTINUE TO
EXAMINE THAT THANK YOU. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. NO FOR THE
TESTIMONY IN THE ROOM I'D LIKE
TO MOVE ON TO THE TELECONFERENCE
LINE MISTER MODERATOR IF YOU
COULD QUEUE UP WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION TO SB THIRTEEN FORTY
. THANK YOU WE WOULD LIKE TO
EXPRESS OUR BELIEF THAT YOU CAN
IMPORTANT PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO
AT THIS TIME ONE FOLLOWED BY
ZERO. MADAM CHAIR NOBODY IS
GIVING UP. OKAY VERY GOOD WILL
BRING THE ISSUE BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE THAT'S FOR QUESTIONS
COMMENTS CONCERNS CENTER NIELSEN
. THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR. I HAVE
TO CONFESS SOME FRUSTRATION WITH
THE SOLAR INDUSTRY. AS HAS BEEN
TESTIFIED HERE IT'S BEEN AROUND
QUITE A WHILE. IT IS MATURING.
IT HAS ITS PLACE IN OUR ENERGY
MIX. THE TOO MUCH HAS BEEN MADE
OF HOW WE CAN BE TO BENDED ON A
ONLY AND ENERGY. AND SOLAR
ENERGY IT HAS ITS PLACE. BUT IF
THAT'S WHERE WE PUT ALL THE EGGS
IN OUR ENERGY BASKET. OUR
CHILDREN THE GENERATIONS WILL
SUFFER GREATLY. THEY AGAIN HAVE
THEIR PLACE BUT MY FRUSTRATION
IS A SOLAR INDUSTRY SEEMS TO BE
QUITE GREEDY. EVERY YEAR SEEKING
NEW ADVANTAGES FOR THEM. TO
SUSTAIN ITSELF. DOWN ON THE FARM
WE CALL IT WINNING THE CALF.
MAYBE IT'S TIME FOR A LITTLE
WINNING OF THE SOLAR INDUSTRY.
AND AS TESTIFIED HERE AND I'M
DELIGHTED TO SEE THE COUNTIES
COMING FORTH EXPRESSING CONCERNS
. NOT VIGOROUS OPPOSITION BUT
CONCERNS. AND THAT'S WHAT I'M
VOICE. I DON'T SEE THE SOLAR
INDUSTRY HELPING AND SUPPORTING
OR EVEN TALKING ABOUT IT BEING
AWARE OF COGENERATION. WHICH
WOULD HELP US CLEAN UP THE FORCE
IN THE WILDLANDS AND CUT DOWN
THESE ENORMOUS CATACLYSMIC FIRES
. SO MY POINT IS A CHALLENGE TO
THE SOLAR INDUSTRY. THE QUIT
BEING SO SELFISH. AND THINK
ABOUT THE WHOLE ENERGY BASKET
FOR THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA. AND
SUPPORTING OTHER ENERGY
PRODUCING ENTITIES AND HELPING
THE COUNTIES AS THEY HAVE
EXPRESSED HERE THEIR OWN
CONCERNS THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR.
THANK YOU ANY OTHER COMMENTS OR
CONCERNS MOTION. CENTER HURT FOR
YOU CAN MAKE THE MOTION YEAH.
THE SENATOR RAZA MAKES MOTION I
DO HAVE A I DO HAVE A COMMENT
AND I DO APPRECIATE THE COMMENTS
FROM THE- FROM THE COUNTY- TWO
THINGS ONE IS THAT YOU KNOW IS
CALIFORNIA REALLY HAS INVESTED
A- LOT OF. TIME ENERGY AND MONEY
ON THE SOLAR INDUSTRY. AND IT'S
FRUSTRATING TO ME THAT WE STILL-
THAT WE ARE STILL BUYING OUR
SOLAR PANELS FROM OTHER
COUNTRIES WE DON'T EVEN PRODUCE
THEM HERE IN IN OUR COUNTRY AND
SO FOR CALIFORNIA TO BE AT THE
FOREFRONT AND SAY WE REALLY WANT
TO GO GREEN AND YET WE DON'T DO
IT OURSELVES IT'S FRUSTRATING
BECAUSE THAT THOSE ARE JOBS SO
THAT'S NUMBER ONE. THERE THERE
ARE A COUPLE OF NEW SMALLER
COMPANIES THAT ARE STARTING UP-
BUT WE NEED TO. WE NEED TO MAKE
SURE THAT THE THEIR SUCCESSFUL
BECAUSE THAT'S OUR WORKFORCE. SO
THAT'S NUMBER ONE NUMBER TWO IS
THAT- WE HAVE INCENTIVIZE. GREEN
TECHNOLOGY. IN THEM WHICH IS
REALLY IMPORTANT IT'S BEEN GREAT
BUT- BY THE- COMMUNITIES THAT
HAVE HAD THEWHERE WITH ALL TO.
SET UP THE CCA'S. I ALWAYS
FORGET WHAT THE ACRONYM STANDS
FOR BUT THE CHOICE EXIT HE
COMMUNITY CHOICEAGGREGATE
THAT'S WHY I CAN NEVER REMEMBER
BECAUSE WHAT DOES THAT MEAN TWO
THOUSAND YEAH AND- AND THAT.
THOSE ARE FOR THE MOST PART THE
COMMUNITIES THAT HAVE INVESTED
IN THOSE ALTERNATIVE. ENERGY CAN
CONGLOMERATES ARE ON THE COAST
AND THEIR WEALTHIER COMMUNITIES
AND THEY HAVE LESS NEED. WE HAVE
THE SAID THEY SAID THEY HAVE A
NEED FOR ENERGY BUT THEY HAVE
LESS OF A NEED BECAUSE THEY'RE
NOT AS HOT AS THE INTERIOR OF
THE STATE AND THEY'RE NOT AS
COLD AS THE INTERIOR OF THE
STATE AND MY POINT I'M MAKING
WITH ALL OF THIS IS THAT- WHAT
THEY WANT TO DO. IS BUILD SOLAR
IN THE CENTRAL VALLEY AND
TRANSPORT THAT ENERGY TO THE
COAST AND WHILE THAT'S A GOOD
THING- I THINK THE CENTRAL
VALLEY I DON'T BENEFIT FROM THAT
DEVELOPMENT. AND SO I'VE BEEN
ENCOURAGING THE CCA'S. TWO IF
THEY'RE GONNA BILL SOLAR PANELS-
THAT THEY DO IT. AROUND
COMMUNITIES IT REALLY NEED THE
ENERGY- WHAT- AND I DO HAVE TO
COMMEND THAT. SAN MATTEO CCA FOR
BUILDING SOLAR AROUND UNLESS
FINANCING THEY'RE GOING TO
INCLUDE THE CITY OF LOS FINE YES
AND THEY'VE ALSO AGREED. THAT
THEY WOULD EXTEND THE SAME
OPPORTUNITY FOR COMMUNITIES
MENDOTA FIREBAUGH. SAN JOAQUIN
THE REASON THAT'S IMPORTANT. AND
IN THIS GETS BACK TO OUR OUR
THAT OUR- ENERGY POLICY GOALS AS
WELL AS OUR- CLIMATE CHANGE
GOALS IS THAT THAT AREA. WILL
LOSE BETWEEN FIVE HUNDRED
THOUSAND TO A MILLION ACRES OF
AG LAND PRODUCTION ONCE SIGMA
CLIQUE KICKS IN SO WE HAVE THESE
SEPARATE SYSTEMS RIGHT WE HAVE
THE WATER SYSTEM IS SEPARATE
THEN ENERGY THAT SEPARATE THEN
THEN- LAND USE BUT BUT WHEN YOU
PUT IT ALL TOGETHER THE
COMMUNITIES ARE REALLY GONNA
SUFFER IN THE COMMUNITIES THAT
THEY DON'T HAVE ANY RESOURCES
THAT HAVE A LOT OF. OF PEOPLE
THAT ARE- HARD WORKING
CALIFORNIANS AND THAT- RELY ON
AGRICULTURE THAT ARE NOT GOING
TO HAVE A LIVELIHOOD AND THAT
THEY'RE NOT GONNA HAVE ENERGY IN
THERE AND SO WEAK MY POINT ABOUT
ALL OF THIS IS THAT- WE NEED TO
SHARE. WE NEED TO MAKE SURE THAT
HAVE SOLAR PANELS ARE GOING INTO
COUNTY THAT THEY SHARE IN THE
BENEFIT OF THE SOLAR PANELS AS
WELL AS WE CAN FIGURE OUT HOW TO
DO THAT. I'M GONNA SUPPORT THE
BILL TODAY I HEAR THAT THAT-
THERE'S SOME MORE WORK TO BE
DONE AND I WILL I WILL I AM.
ASSUMING THAT YOU WILL APPLY TO
THE COURT WILL GET THERE AND SO
UP WITH THAT YOU MAKE INCLUDE.
THEM THE MAGIC THAT'S TWO
HUNDRED SIXTY THOUSAND SQUARE
MILES SIXTY FIVE THOUSAND SQUARE
MILES OF CALIFORNIA. INFORMED BY
FIFTY EIGHT COUNTIES. EACH OF US
HAVE RESPECTED BURDENS. EACH OF
US CONTRIBUTE IN DIFFERENT WAYS
TO WHAT IS CALIFORNIA. THE
PEOPLE THAT LIVE IN THE HARBOR.
THOSE TRACTORS WOULD COME TO.
PLOW THOSE FIELDS COME FROM A
LOT OF THOSE SHIPS. THAT THOSE
KIDS ARE. SUCKING UP THAT THE
ASTHMA AND THE PROBLEMS THEY
FACE BECAUSE THE TRACTORS. HOW
MANY PEOPLE FROM EACH OF THE
COUNTIES GO TO. SANDALS
INTERNATIONAL AIRPORT. AND
UTILIZE THAT FACILITY. WHAT
COUNTIES ARE ENGAGED IN SELF
HELP AND WHICH COUNTIES ARC. THE
QUESTION IS WE IS A STATE. IN
THE BIG PICTURE POLICY THIS
INFORMED BY THE QUESTIONS HERE
IN THE- OPPOSITION HERE. HAVE AN
OBLIGATION. WE SIT BACK IN A RIP
IN A AND R. AGENCIES TELL US
THAT WE'VE GOT TO PRODUCE
SEVENTY GIGAWATTS SEVENTY
GIGAWATTS SEVEN THOUSAND
MEGAWATTS OF SOLAR POWER. TO
MEET THE TWENTY FORTY FIVE SO
WE'RE CREATING THIS
EXTRAORDINARY TRANSITION. THAT'S
HAPPENING AT A TIME WHERE
TECHNOLOGY IS FUNDAMENTALLY
CHANGE I'VE BEEN DOING THIS FOR
THIRTY FIVE YEARS I'VE WATCHED
TECHNOLOGY CHANGED DRAMATICALLY.
AND YOU KNOW I TRY TO BUILD THE
SOLAR FACTORY IN LOS ANGELES IT
DIDN'T WORK. THE BILL FOR
OFFICERS THAT WE SHOULD PUT
EVERY ONE OF THOSE JOBS SHOULD
BE HERE. AND PART OF WHAT WE'RE
TRYING TO DO HERE IN LOOKING AT
THE ECONOMICS IS TO MAKE SURE
THAT THE JOBS WITH RESPECT TO
UTILITY GRADE SOLAR DON'T GO TO
THE STATE. BECAUSE IT'S ABOUT
MONEY WE WANT THOSE JOBS HERE WE
WANT THAT THOSE FACILITIES TO BE
BUILT HERE WE DON'T WANT THEM IN
A NEIGHBORING STATE THAT ALSO
HAVE SON. THAT MUCH MORE TO BE
JUST POLICY. EXES SO YES IT'S
MATURED DRAMATICALLY YES THE
TECHNOLOGY HAS CHANGED JUST THE
PRICING HAS GONE DOWN BUT IF YOU
LOOK AT WHAT WE'RE TRYING TO DO
AS A AS AS A STATE. TO MOVE AWAY
FROM FOSSIL FUELS WE HAVE TO
FIGURE OUT HOW TO GET THERE AND
THIS IS A NECESSARY COMPONENT.
AND I'VE HAD SOME VERY IMPORTANT
INTERESTING CONVERSATIONS WITH
ELECTED OFFICIALS FROM KERN
COUNTY AND I UNDERSTAND THEIR-
THEIR POINT OF VIEW I GET IT.
BUT IF YOU LOOK AT WHEN YOU TALK
IT LANDED ABUSE OTHERWISE WHAT'S
THOSE OTHER REVENUE STREAMS- IS
REVENUE FROM THIS. WHAT WE'RE
TRYING TO DO IS TO FIGURE OUT.
WE CAN BALANCE. AS THINGS CHANGE
I THINK A LOT OF THIS WHAT'S
GOING TO HAPPEN MY OWN PERSONAL
VIEW IS WE'RE GOING TO BE GREEN
HYDROGEN WHICH IS BASICALLY
SOLAR CELLS AND WATER. MAKING
HYDROGEN WHICH IS GONNA BE
EXPORTABLE YOU CAN PUT IN PIPES
YOU CAN DO ALL SORTS OF THINGS.
I THINK WE'RE IN THIS DEVELOPING
STAGES OF WHAT'S GOING ON WE
MADE THE SUN SETS BECAUSE WE
MADE ANTICIPATIONS WE DIDN'T
KNOW WHERE WE WOULD BE. BUT THE
BOTTOM LINE- JUST FINISHED
CAMANCHE HERE IS THAT WE'RE NOT
THERE YET THAT WE HAVE TO SEND
MARKET SIGNALS THE COMPANIES TO
INVEST. AND MAKE THAT HAPPEN.
AND SO. I WOULD JUST SUGGEST TO
YOU. THAT THIS IS A THOUGHT AND
INTO. APPROACH THAT IS NOT BEING
PACKAGE. IN TERMS OF WHAT'S
GOING ON WITH RESPECT TO MARKET
SIGNALS. AND WHERE WE ARE I
DON'T THINK THIS WILL BE
FOREVER. BUT I DO THINK THAT
THIS IS NECESSARY FOR US. TO
ACTUALLY HARMONIZE AND MEET THE
GOALS AND EVERYBODY TO CARE THE
WRIST CARRY THE RESPECTIVE
BURDENS. OF WHAT'S NECESSARY YOU
KNOW ALL THE GOODS MOVING THE
COMES OUT OF LA AND ALL OF THOSE
THINGS INFORM ALL OF US. SO WITH
THAT. I THINK IS AN IMPORTANT
MEASURE I THINK THE COMMITTEE
STAFFERS MADE SOME IMPORTANT
CHANGES TO IT. LAST YEAR I
BOUGHT. THANK YOU VERY MUCH THE
MOTION IS. DO PASS AS AMENDED
BUT FIRST AMENDED RE REFER TO
THE COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL SENATORS
CAPITO HI CABALLERO HI NIELSEN.
NIELSEN NO DURAZO TERRAZZO HI
HERTZBERG HERTZBERG HI WIENER
RIGHT WIENER HI. FORTY ONE. THE
BILL IS OUT. FOUR TO ONE. I AM
LOOKING FOR AUTHOR CENTER
BRADFORD. YOU'RE GOING.
SENATOR BRADFORD WE'RE GOING TO
START WITH S. B. TWELVE EIGHTY
ONE. THE TO THE FLOOR'S YOURS
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT MA'AM
AND CHEER AND I AM HERE TO
PRESENT TWELVE EIGHTY ONE WHAT
TOOL ONE LUMINATE THE CANNABIS
CULTIVATION TAX AND REDUCE
EXCISE TAX ON CANNABIS PRODUCTS
IS WILL ALSO MOVE THE POINT. OF
TAX COLLECTIONS FROM THE
DISTRIBUTOR TO THE RETAILER OR
POINT OF SALE I'M ACCEPTING THE
COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS- AND
ANALYSIS AS WE ALL KNOW AND
CALIFORNIA IN TWO THOUSAND
SIXTEEN VOTERS APPROVED THE
PASSAGE OF PROP SIXTY FOUR THE
CONTROL REGULATE AND TAX ADULT
USE OF MARIJUANA ACT. WHILE THE
IMPLEMENTATION OF ARE STILL
MINUTES EARLY STAGES CANNABIS
INDUSTRY STRUGGLING TO SURVIVE
AS LEGALLY OPERATED BUSINESSES
WITH MANY ON THE BRINK OF
COLLAPSE NOW DECEMBER LAST YEAR
DIVERSE GROUP OF CANNABIS
BUSINESS LEADERS AND CONSUMERS
ALERTED TO POLITICAL LEADERSHIP
OF THE STATE. THAT THEIR
INDUSTRY WAS IN CRISIS
STRUGGLING TO OPERATE IN FACE AN
IMMINENT LOSS OF THEIR
BUSINESSES NOT ONLY HERE IN THE
STATE. BUT I ATTENDED A
CONFERENCE LAST DECEMBER IN A
LAND OF THE NATIONAL CONFERENCE
WOULD BLOCK STATE LEGISLATORS.
AND THIS IS A CRISIS ALL OVER
UNITED STATES SPECIALLY WHEN IT
COMES TO EQUITY OPERATORS. AND
THEY'RE HOPING THAT THEY CAN
SURVIVE. THE INDUSTRY REPORTED
THAT THE OPPORTUNITY TO CREATE A
ROBUST LEGAL CANNABIS MARKET IS
BEING SQUANDERED BECAUSE OF.
EXCESSIVE TAXATION AND
OVERREGULATION FOR OUR
REGULATIONS LEGAL CANNABIS
PRODUCTS ARE AT LEAST 50% MORE
EXPENSIVE. THAN ON THE ILLICIT-
UNDERGROUND MARKET CALIFORNIA
TAX POLICIES RESULTING IN AN
ENVIRONMENT FOR THE ILLICIT
MARKET TO EXPAND. AND MAKING IT
ALMOST IMPOSSIBLE FOR LEGITIMATE
BUSINESSES TO COMPETE WITHOUT
SOME KIND OF REAL MEANINGFUL
SUBSTANTIVE CHANGE I AM AFRAID
THAT THIS INDUSTRY IS DESTINED
TO FAIL SB TWELVE EIGHTY ONE
WOULD ELIMINATE CANNABIS
CULTIVATION TAX REDUCED EXCISE
TAX. FROM 15% 25% AND MOVE THE
POINT OF COLLECTION OF THE
EXCISE SAYS FROM THE DISTRIBUTOR%
THE RETAILER. WILL TO
CULTIVATION EXCISE TAX ARE
CURRENTLY COLLECTED AT THE POINT
OF ISTRIBUTION OFTEN REQUIRING
CANNABIS RETAILERS TO PAY ACCESS
TAX BEFORE EVER- MAKING A SELL
ON CANNABIS SO IN ESSENCE YOU'RE
PAYING FOR INVENTORY I MEAN
OPINION ATTACKS ON INVENTORY
THAT YOU MIGHT NOT NEVER STILL
AND AS WE ALL KNOW ALL OF. THESE
PRODUCTS HAVE EXPIRATION DATE
AND I'VE VISITED- RETAILERS AS
WELL AS DISTRIBUTION CENTERS
WHERE. THEY HAVE TO GO OUT IN-
DISPOSE OF- WHY A BIT OF THIS
PRODUCT ON A REGULAR BASIS AND
THEY ALSO JUST CAN'T PUT IT IN
THE TRASH CAN YOU HAVE TO HAVE A
SPECIAL- RECYCLER ARE COLLECTOR
TO COME IN AND- HANDLES
SITUATION. WHICH IS ADDITIONAL
COST AND BURDEN TO THE BUSINESS.
AND WHILE THE ELIMINATION OF THE
CULTIVATION TAX AND A REDUCTION
OF EXCISE TAX MAY DECREASE TAX
REVENUE FOR PROGRAMS THAT ARE
DEPENDENT UPON THE REVENUE. IT
IS ANTICIPATED THAT YOU WILL
HAVE GREATER DEMAND FROM THE
LEGAL OPPORT OPERATORS WILL TOOL
MORE THAN MAKE UP FOR THE
DIFFERENCE AND- FROM GOING FROM
15220% BECAUSE I THINK WE'RE
GOING TO DRIVE MORE- BUSINESSES
TO THE LEGITIMATE BUSINESS
VERSUS THE LEGAL. OUR UNTIL THE
MARKET CAN SYMBOLIZE INCREASE
CELLS. ARE REALIZE WERE PRESENT
PURSUING A GENERAL FUND REVENUE.
TO OFFSET ANY REDUCTION IN THE
CANNABIS TAX FUND TO ENSURE THE
PROGRAMS THAT ARE DEPENDENT ON
THAT WILL. CONTINUE TO BE FUNDED
SO I ASK FOR YOUR SUPPORT AND
THIS MEASURE AND I HAVE A
WITNESS HERE TO TESTIFY. ON
BEHALF I THINK IT'S A MEETING
CONSTRUED. VERY GOOD WE HAVE AMY
CHEN HAD FROM THE CALIFORNIA
CANNABIS INDUSTRY ASSOCIATION
WELCOME YES THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR AND MEMBERS. AMY JENKINS
ON BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
CANNABIS INDUSTRY ASSOCIATION
HERE TO EXPRESS OUR ENTHUSIASTIC
SUPPORT FOR SB TWELVE EIGHTY
ONE. AND TO CONVEY OUR SINCERE
APPRECIATION TO SENATOR BRADFORD
ON BEHALF OF OUR OVER FOUR
HUNDRED MEMBERS FOR INTRODUCING
THIS CRITICALLY IMPORTANT
LEGISLATION. WE BELIEVE IT IS
IMPORTANT TO NOTE THAT
CALIFORNIA VOTERS WERE CLEAR
ABOUT THEIR EXPECTATIONS WHEN
THEY PASSED PROPOSITION SIXTY
FOUR WHICH STATED AND I QUOTE.
IT IS THE INTENT OF THE PEOPLE
AND ACTING THIS ACT TO TAKE. NON
MEDICAL MARIJUANA PRODUCTION AND
SALES OUT OF THE HANDS OF THE
ILLEGAL MARKET AND TO TAX THE
GROWTH AND SALE OF MARIJUANA. IN
A WAY THAT DRIVES OUT THE
ILLICIT MARKET AND QUOTE. SB
TWELVE ANYONE OFFERS MEANINGFUL
TAX REFORM FOR CALIFORNIA'S
REGULATED CANNABIS INDUSTRY BY
ADDRESSING MANY OF SYSTEMIC
CHALLENGES THAT ARE DRIVING
LEGAL OPERATORS AND CONSUMERS TO
THE ILLICIT MARKET. A RECENT
STUDY CONDUCTED BY THE REASON
FOUNDATION WHICH WILL BE
RELEASED LATER TODAY. EXAMINES
CONSUMER PURCHASING HABITS AND
FOUND A CLEAR CORRELATION
BETWEEN CALIFORNIA'S CANNABIS
TAX RATES AND CONSUMER
PARTICIPATION IN THE LEGAL
MARKET. AND ANALYZING THE
TAXATION OF LEGAL CANNABIS THE
STUDY FOUND THAT THE COMBINATION
OF CALIFORNIA'S CULTIVATION AN
EXCISE TAX COUPLED WITH LOCAL
TAXES CAN BE AS HIGH AS NINETY
DOLLARS PER OUNCE. WHICH IS
EQUIVALENT TO ONE THOUSAND FOUR
HUNDRED AND FORTY ONE DOLLARS
PER POUND. FOR COMPARISON LEGAL
CANNABIS TAXES AVERAGED THREE
HUNDRED AND FORTY A POUND IN
OREGON AND FIVE HUNDRED AND
TWENTY SIX POUND IN COLORADO.
FINDINGS FURTHER VALIDATED
PREVIOUS REPORTS THAT
CALIFORNIA'S LEGAL CANNABIS
INDUSTRY REPRESENTS
APPROXIMATELY APPROXIMATELY
THIRD. SHOULD BE. BASED ON THE
STATE'S POPULATION AN ESTIMATED
ADULT USAGE RATES AND SHOWS THAT
NEARLY TWO THIRDS OF ALL
CANNABIS SALES CONDUCTED IN
CALIFORNIA STILL TAKE PLACE IN
THE ILLICIT MARKET. FURTHER
EXACERBATING THESE ISSUES AS A
STATE WIDE LACK OF ACCESS TO
LEGAL CANNABIS RETAILERS. SINCE
THE VAST MAJORITY OF CALIFORNIA
LOCALITIES HAVE BANNED THE SALE
OF CANNABIS MORE THAN HALF OF
THE STATE'S READ LEGAL RETAILERS
ARE LOCATED AND JUST EIGHTEEN
CITIES. DUE TO THE COMBINATION
OF LOWER TAXES AND GREATER
ACCESS TO LEGAL RETAILERS
RESIDENTS IN OREGON SPEND THREE
HUNDRED AND SEVENTY EIGHT MORE
PER CAPITA ON LEGAL CANNABIS I
RESIDENTS IN COLORADO SPEND
THREE HUNDRED AND 35% MORE PER
CAPITA ON LEGAL CANNABIS. THAN
RESIDENTS HERE IN CALIFORNIA. TO
MAKE LEGAL CANNABIS PRICES MORE
NEWMAN HAD TO ASK YOU TO OKAY IT
TO THE END NO PROBLEM SO SB TWO
TWELVE EIGHTY ONE IS CURRENTLY
THE ONLY TAX REFORM BILL THAT
OFFERS GENUINE REFORM WHICH IS
ESSENTIAL TO STABILIZING
CALIFORNIA'S LEGAL CANNABIS
MARKET. AND CURBING THE STATE'S
ILLICIT MARKET SO FOR THESE
REASONS WE STRONGLY SUPPORT
THANK YOU THANK YOU VERY MUCH
NEXT WE HAVE PAMELA LOPEZ FROM
CAN NORMAL. CALIFORNIA NORMAL
GOOD MORNING PAM LOPEZ WITH K.
STREET CONSULTING ON BEHALF OF
CALIFORNIA NORMAL. I WHICH IS
THE STATE'S CANNABIS CONSUMER
RIGHTS AND CONSUMER ADVOCACY
GROUP. WE ARE HAPPY TO SUPPORT
SB TWELVE EIGHTY ONE AND THANK
SENATOR BRADFORD FOR INTRODUCING
HAS THIS BILL AND HIS WORK ON
THIS ISSUE. REDUCING CANNABIS
TAXES IS CRITICAL IF THE STATE
WHICH IS TO BRING THE TWO THIRDS
OF CANNABIS CONSUMERS. WHO ARE
STILL BUYING BLACK MARKET
CANNABIS INTO THE LEGAL ECONOMY.
IT IS BETTER FOR THEIR HEALTH
AND IT WILL ALSO HELP THE STATE
MEET THEIR CANNABIS TAX REVENUE
GOALS. AS MS JENKINS MENTIONED-
THE REASON FOUNDATION WILL BE
RELEASING A REPORT LATER TODAY.
THAT SHOWS THAT REDUCING
CANNABIS TAXES WILL ACTUALLY
INCREASE STATE CANNABIS TAX
REVENUES. ARE BECAUSE MORE
PEOPLE WILL BUY LICENSED
PRODUCTS I AND BE PAYING THOSE
TAXES. THE FACT THAT TWO THIRDS
OF CANNABIS CONSUMERS ARE STILL
BUYING ILLEGAL CANNABIS IS A
CRITICAL PART OF THIS ANALYSIS.
IT'S BECAUSE THERE ARE SO MANY
CONSUMERS WHO AREN'T ABLE TO PAY
THESE HIGH TAXES. THAT WE STILL
HAVE SO MUCH ROOM TO GROW IN
TERMS OF BRINGING NEW TAXPAYERS.
INTO THE ECONOMY WITH LOWER
TAXES. THE REPORT SHOWS THAT THE
DIVISION TAX ZERO OUT. AND THAT
THE EXCISE TAX CAN BE LOWERED
SIGNIFICANTLY- AND THAT THE
CANNABIS TAX BASE WILL STILL
GROW SUBSTANTIALLY. IN
CALIFORNIA WE ENCOURAGE THE
STATE TO TAKE ACTION NOW I AM
BRING MORE CONSUMERS INTO THE
TAX PAYING CANNABIS ECONOMY.
BOTH FOR THEIR HEALTH AND SAFETY
AND TO MEET THE STATE'S CANNABIS
TAX REVENUE GOALS. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. THERE ANYTHING ELSE
IN THE ROOM THAT WOULD LIKE
TESTIFYING IN SUPPORT. CHARM
ALICIA PRIEGO ON BEHALF OF KIVA
AND ALSO THE CALIFORNIA CANNABIS
MANUFACTURERS ASSOCIATION IN
STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU. YOUR
MEMBERS RAN MARTIN ON THE HALF
OF THE PARENT COMPANY IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF THIS VERY RATIONAL
PROPOSAL THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
THE MORNING CENTERS MY NAME IS
CHLOE FERGUSON ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA EQUITY POLICY.
COUNCIL IS ON SUPPORT IF AMENDED
TO INCLUDE ADDITIONAL PROVISIONS
FOR SUCH EQUITY ENTREPRENEURS
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. MADAM
CHAIR MEMBERS BREAK LEVEL TO
HEAR WITH APEX GROUP ON BEHALF
OF CARE RELIEF AND PERFECT TEEN
INTO VERTICALLY INTEGRATED
CAMPUS COMPANIES IN STRONG
SUPPORT. THANK YOU THANK YOU.
KEVIN HOOKS ON BEHALF OF ELLIS
GREENS- SOCIAL EQUITY BUSINESS
HERE SACRAMENTO STRONG SUPPORT
THANK YOU. GOOD MORNING TARA
CRAWFORD ON I'M IN EQUITY
OPERATOR IN THE CITY AND I'M IN
STRONG SUPPORT. THANK YOU THANK. GOOD AFTERNOON I'M BRANDON
BOLDEN I'M IN STRONG SUPPORT IF
AMENDED TO INCLUDE MORE A SOCIAL
EQUITY INITIATIVE. THANK YOU. HM
THE MEDICAID AS BUSINESS
ASSOCIATION AND THE QUESTION I
CAN AS WELL AS BADLY NETWORK IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. SEEING NO FURTHER
WITNESSES IN THE ROOM WE'RE
GOING TO MOVE ON TO THE
TELECONFERENCE LINE MISTER
MODERATOR IF YOU COULD PROMPT.
ANY WITNESS THAT WOULD LIKE TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF SB TWELVE
EIGHTY ONE. THANK YOU IF YOU ARE
IN SUPPORT OF SB TWELVE EIGHTY
ONE PLEASE PRESS ONE FOLLOWED BY
ZERO AT THIS TIME WHEN FALL BY.
ZERO FOUR TWELVE EIGHTY ONE IN
SUPPORT. AND WE'LL BEGIN WITH
FIBER- THIRTY FIVE YOU ARE ALL
THANK. NO I'M CALLING ON BEHALF
OF THE NATION'S LARGEST OLDEST
CANNABIS. ABBASI GROUP FOR
PATIENTS IN STRONG SUPPORT OF
THE FOR THE BILL THANK YOU SO
MUCH NEXT PLEASE. WE WILL ALIGN
NINETY EIGHT YOU ARE OPEN. WELL
IT IS NOT GROWTH WITH OTHER
ORGANIC- STRONGLY SUPPORT ITSELF
. THANK YOU. LINE ONE EIGHTY
FIVE PLEASE GO AHEAD. EIGHTY
FIVE YOU ARE ALL THANK. HI THERE
THIS IS DIANE AGAIN NINETY NINE
THE EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF THE
NEVADA COUNTY CAMPUS ALLIANCE
HALF OF OUR TWO HUNDRED FIFTY
MILE AN INDEPENDENT. MERGED OUT
WE STRONGLY SUPPORT ITSELF THANK
YOU THANK YOU. TWENTY ONE
SEVENTY FIVE YOU ARE OPEN. GOOD
MORNING NINE O'CLOCK WITH MY
LOOK WITH THE CALIFORNIA CALLING
ON BEHALF OF CERTIFICATION FOR
IT THE HOBBIT CARRION DR
BRONNER'S INK AND OPENS THAT
HAVE BEEN FOR EQUITY AND
PROSPERITY IN STRONG SUPPORT
GRATITUDE AND- I. HOPE THAT THE
IS MY SECOND YEAR THANK YOU. WHY
TWENTY FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HELLO MY NAME IS KAREN PILO I'M
OWNER OF THE HIGHER PATH
DISPENSARY LOS ANGELES HONORABLE
BY NAPA AND DISTRIBUTION HIGH
PACKED AND SELF APPOINTED LEADER
OF THE SENATOR BRADFORD FAN CLUB
AND STRONG SUPPORT OF THIS BILL
. THANK YOU I MARKET ONE TWENTY
NINE YOU ARE OPEN. HELLO BRIAN
COLLINS CANDIDATES- NOR INVESTOR
AND ADVOCATE- THE ABELARD
FOUNDATION STRONG SUPPORTER OF
THE BILL THANK YOU. ONE EIGHTY
SIX EUROPE. GOOD MORNING JEANINE
COLEMAN EXECUTIVE DRECTOR OF
ORIGINS COUNSEL REPRESENTING
NINE HUNDRED ALL INDEPENDENTLY
OWNED AND OPERATED WE'RE ALL
LICENSED CANNABIS BUSINESSES IN
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA VERY
STRONG SUPPORT FOR THIS BILL
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. ONE
SEVENTY THREE YOU ARE OPEN. GOOD
MORNING EVERYONE MY NAME IS
ALFRED GIORDANO OF THE SOCIAL
EQUITY OPTION INC ADVOCATE VICE
PRESIDENT OF THE SOCIAL EQUITY
HOLDERS OF WORKERS SOCIAIS
HAITIAN. ARE IN THE OF TWO THANK
YOU THANK YOU VERY MUCH. ONE
TWENTY ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD. WHAT
TWENTY ONE WHAT ARE YOU GETTING
. HELLO MY NAME IS KELLY TO OPEN
. YES DON'T THANK YOU. SIXTY
THREE PLEASE GO AHEAD. SIXTY
THREE PLEASE ON MUTE. ONE MORE
SHOT AT LINE SIXTY THREE WOULD
YOU LIKE TO TESTIFY BEFORE.
AMBER MARC BUT NOR CAL CANNABIS
AND STRONG WORK. THANK YOU.
FIFTY ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD. THIS
IS MAGGIE CRABB PUBLIC BERKELEY
WE STRONGLY SUPPORT THIS BILL.
THANK YOU. EIGHTY EIGHT YOU ARE
OPEN. HI MY NAME IS MADISON
SHOCKLEY ON THE PRESIDENT OF
CANADA'S EQUITY POLICY COUNCIL-
WE REPRESENT SOCIAL ACTIVITY-
ENTREPRENEURS ACROSS THE STATE-
ARE WILLING WITH SUPPORT THE
BILL YOUR COMMANDED TO INCLUDE A
EXCISE TAX THAT USE 3% APPLY 2%
OF SOCIAL EQUITY BUSINESSES SO
SUPPORT IF. THANK YOU. ONE FIFTY
EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO MY
NAME IS THAT WE START WORKING
EVEN ENTERPRISES VERTICALLY
INTEGRATED CANNABIS COMPANY
OPERATING OUR FLAGSHIP RETAIL
LOCATION FIFTY THOUSAND THREE
WORDS SONG PART OF ACT II TWELVE
EIGHTY ONE I THINK THE NUMBER
BRADFORD SAYS THE LEGISLATURE TO
ENSURE THE SURVIVAL OF. THANK
YOU NEXT PLEASE. ONE EIGHTY
THREE YOUR OWN THING. AFTERNOON
I GUESS GOOD MORNING MY NAME IS
JOHNNY DEL PLAN I'M THE
PRESIDENT OF THE SAN FRANCISCO
CANNABIS RETAILERS ALLIANCE AB
REPRESENTING OVER TWO DOZEN
SOCIAL EQUITY AND LEGACY MEDICAL
CANNABIS RETAILERS AND CITY
TAXES GO AND WE OF COURSE AREN'T
VERY STRONG SUPPORT THIS BILL.
THANK YOU THANK YOU. ONE EIGHTY
TO PLEASE GO AHEAD. ONE EIGHTY
TWO LAUREL VERA ON THE SOCIAL
EQUITY OPERATOR AND OWNER AND
ALSO EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF
SOCIAL XBLA AND WE SUPPORT THIS
BILL. THANK YOU. BY NINETY SIX
PLEASE GO AHEAD. SB SIX WOULD
YOU LIKE TO TESTIFY. YOUR LINE
IS OPEN NINETY SIX. I WILL MOVE
ALONG THE LINE SEVENTY EIGHT
PLEASE GO AHEAD OF. HI THIS IS
CHRISTY WENT ON BEHALF OF
PARTICIPATORY INCORPORATED AT
SAN FRANCISCO MICHAEL BUSINESS
WITH LESS THAN TEN THOUSAND
SQUARE FEET AND I STRONGLY
SUPPORT THIS BILL. THANK YOU.
ONE EIGHTY EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD
. MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS MICHAEL
COLE BRUNO- BOARD MEMBER OF THE
LAKE COUNTY CANNABIS ASSOCIATION
AND OWNER OF A SMALL FARM GOES
DOWN TRANSIT AND WE ARE IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF THIS BILL.
THANK YOU. ONE ONE EIGHTY ONE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR NUMBER GRIEGO'S POLICY
DIRECTOR FOR GOOD FARMERS GREAT
NEIGHBORS AND ALLIANCES SOME
GROWN AND GREENHOUSE FARMERS
THROUGHOUT THE CENTRAL COAST AND
A CO PUBLISHER OF THE REASON
STUDY AND CANNABIS TAX
IMPLICATIONS IN STRONG SUPPORT
OF SB TWELVE EIGHTY ONE. THANK
YOU. I WON NINETY THANK YOU
PLEASE GO AHEAD. ONE NINETY. ONE
ONE NINETY WOULD YOU LIKE TO
TESTIFY. ARE YOU MUTED ONE
NINETY. WILL MOVE ON- TO LINE
ONE EIGHTY PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HELLO THIS IS BLOOD MONEY
REPRESENTING FLOW KIND CULTURE
AND WE STRONGLY SUPPORT THIS
BILL. THANK YOU. I WON FIFTY SIX
WEEKS GO AHEAD. GOOD MORNING I
AM ANALLY SPIRIT REPRESENTING
ENDO INDUSTRY WE ARE IN SUPPORT
OF S. U. TWELVE EIGHTY ONE.
THANK YOU. ONE ONE NINETY TWO
YOU ARE OPEN. ONE NINETY TWO
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. ONE MORE SHOT
ONE ONE NINETY TWO WOULD YOU
LIKE TO TESTIFY. I WILL MOVE
ALONG THE LINE ONE NINETY THREE. ONE NINETY THREE YOU ARE OPEN. WE CAN HEAR YOU ONE ONE NINETY
THREE PLEASE GO AHEAD. ALL RIGHT
WE'LL TRY ONE NINETY SEVEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. BUFFALO
REPRESENTING BIG TRADING HELLO
THE- EQUITY NONVOLATILE
MANUFACTURING COMPANY OPERATING
OUT OF THE BAYVIEW NEIGHBORHOOD
IN SAN FRANCISCO WE ARE IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF THIS BILL
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. MADAM
CHAIR THERE NO OTHER
PARTICIPANTS QUEUED UP FOR GOOD
WE'RE GONNA MOVE ON TO THE
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION WE HAVE
ONE LEAD. OPPOSITION WITNESS
LENDS OVER SHE'S ON THE PHONE
FROM THE PUBLIC HEALTH INSTITUTE
. IN THE FLOOR'S YOURS. THANK
YOU MADAM CHAIR- AGAIN AFTER
LUNCH OVER PEDIATRICIAN PUBLIC
HEALTH INSTITUTE AND MEMBER OF
THE PROP SIXTY FOUR STAKEHOLDERS
I THINK FOR THE DEPARTMENT
HEALTHCARE SERVICES. OPENING 81%
EVEN GREATER CHALLENGES FOR USE
IN PUBLIC HEALTH AND SENATOR
MCGUIRE STILL. IT TO ROB PETER
TO PAY PAUL. BECAUSE OF THE FAR
GREATER TAX CUTS BUT MUCH LARGER
AMOUNTS IN PERMANENTLY SB KOBE
ONE WILL REQUIRE HUNDREDS OF
MILLIONS OF DOLLARS IN GENERAL
FUND. TO BE SEIZED THE
SUBSIDIZED PROFITS THE CANNABIS
INDUSTRY IN ORDER TO MAINTAIN A
CENTRAL PACKED FUNDED PROGRAMS
FROM CHILD CARE TO USE
PREVENTION DIVERSION FROM
INCARCERATIONS. ARE UNINSURED OR
STRUGGLING FOR COVERAGE OUR
PUBLIC HEALTH DEPARTMENTS AFTER
TWO YEARS OF THE PANDEMIC THAT
KILLED A MILLION PEOPLE HAD HI
TO SALES FOR TWO HUNDRED MILLION
IN FUNDING. YES THIS BILL WOULD
DIVERSE FORMS OF CONTROLLERS TO
HELP EDUCATION RACIAL JUSTICE
HOUSING OR OTHER NEEDS TO GIVE
IT TO THE CANNABIS INDUSTRY. WHY
TARGETED BREAKS THE EQUITY
LICENSEES MAKES SENSE AND IT'S
NOT WHAT IS PROPOSED THE VAST
MAJORITY BENEFITS WILL GO TO THE
LICENSEES WHO ARE NOT ACTUALLY
LICENSEES. SADLY ONLY ABOUT
TWENTY OF OUR FIVE HUNDRED
THIRTY NINE CALIFORNIA
JURISDICTIONS AND CREATED EQUITY
LICENSING PROGRAM THAT IS THE
PROBLEM. WE NEED TO FIX. THE
BILL LOOKS PROFITS REDUCED. CAN
BE. WE BECOME. BY SALES. THAT
WILL BEGIN EVERY STOPS ABUSE FOR
GOAL OF THE STATE. IT IS NOT
CLEAR TO WHAT EXTENT DOES
INCREASE SALES WOULD COME FROM
THE ILLICIT MARKET OTHER THAN
CONGRESSIONAL WIDESPREAD. USE
TARGETED MARKETING OF THE
INDUSTRY. WHAT CANNABIS BOTH
HAVE VALID MEDICAL USES OF
CANNABIS IS NOT STRAWBERRIES.
CANNABIS IS NOW THE LEADING
CAUSE OF SUBSTANCE ABUSE
TREATMENT FOR TEENS DAILY OR
NEAR DAILY CANNABIS USE AMONG
CALIFORNIA DON'T CRIPPLE THE
PAST DECADE. AND COUNTLESS SOLD
TODAY IS NO LONGER THE
TRADITIONAL MECHANICAL PRODUCTS
BUT ONE WHO SPOKE WITH C. IS
FIVE TO TEN TIMES HIGHER IN
PLANTS. AND MANY MANUFACTURED
PRODUCTS ARE NEARLY PURE THC
LEADING TO MAJOR INCREASES
INDEPENDENTLY YOUR VISIT DRUG
DRIVING. IMPAIRED EDUCATIONAL
IMPACT AND OTHER CANNABIS
RELATED PROBLEMS FOR EXAMPLE
LGBT Q. USE AT HIGH RISK FOR
SUICIDE AND MENTAL HEALTH
ISSUES. EGGMAN AND
DISCRIMINATION ARE EXPERIENCING
HIGH RATES CANNABIS. USE
DISORDER. TEMPTATION IS CENTRAL
ONE CENTRAL. OF THE FACT PUBLIC
STRATEGY. THAT ALLOW ME SALE MY
MOTHER CAR USE OF PRODUCT. IT IS
NOT WISE TO FALL THE PROBLEM THE
LOOK MARKET
ACCEPTED ACTUALLY UNDERSTATES
FEW. CREATING CONSUMPTION WILL
DIMINISH. SERVE HEALTH AND
SOCIAL EQUITY. MENTIONED EARLIER
COMMISSION BY DOT LEGAL ANALYSIS
BY MR COHEN CONCLUDED THAT THESE
ARE INADMISSIBLE AMENDMENTS TO
PROPOSITION SIXTY FOUR IN
CONSISTENT WITH THE INTENT AND
PURPOSE OF THE PROPOSITION. I
WOULD ALSO LIKE TO REITERATE OUR
DAY THAT THAT IT IS NOT CORRECT
TWO THIRDS OF CALIFORNIA
JURISDICTIONS DO NOT ALLOW LEGAL
CANNABIS SALES. 52% OF
JURISDICTIONS ALLOW EITHER
STOREFRONT OR DELIVERY FAILED
HOME 260% OF RESIDENTS RETAIL
SALES HAS NOT COLLAPSED RATHER
THEY HAVE GROWN RAPIDLY BY TWO
HUNDRED AND 49% SINCE TWENTY
EIGHTEEN. FOR ONE STATE REMAINS
DIVIDED REGARDING LEGALIZATION
IT IS FAR FROM THIS EXTREME
SITUATION AS THE INDUSTRY HEY.
WE THEREFORE CALL UPON THE
COMMITTEE TO RESPECT THE INTENT
OF THE VOTERS OR AT A MINIMUM
PUT OFF REVENUE NEUTRAL CHANGES
WITHOUT READING THE GENERAL
FUND. AND MAINTAIN THE TAX
REVENUE FUNDED EDUCATION. WHILE
SPEAKING SOLUTION FOR EQUITY
LIKE HATE. OUR CHILDREN ANOTHER
PRESSING SOCIAL NEEDS MUST TAKE
PRECEDENCE OVER SUBSIDIZING
CANNABIS INDUSTRY PROFITS WE ASK
FOR YOUR NAY VOTE THANK YOU
SURE. MEMBERS THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. MY DOCTOR SUPER WOULD MOVE
ON TO ANYONE IN THE ROOM. WHO
WOULD LIKE TO TESTIFY IN
OPPOSITION. GOOD MORNING
SENATORS MY NAME IS TACK ALLEN
AND THE LEGISLATIVE CHAIR FOR
THE C. P. BLACK CAUCUS WE ARE
ONLY OPPOSED UNLESS AND MANDATE
TO. ADD MORE EQUITABLE
PROVISIONS FOR THE DEMOGRAPHIC
MOST AFFECTED. BY THE WAR ON
DRUGS AND TO INCENTIVIZE THEM TO
PARTAKE IN THE LEGAL ABOVE
GROUND MARKET FOR THIS
PARTICULAR CANNABIS INDUSTRY.
THANK YOU THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
SEEING NO FURTHER TESTIMONY IN
THE ROOM IN THE COMMITTEE ROOM
I'D LIKE TO MOVE ON TO THE
TELECONFERENCE LINE. MISTER
MODERATOR IF YOU COULD QUEUE UP
OPPOSITION. THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR IF YOU'RE OPPOSED TO SB
TWELVE EIGHTY ONE PLEASE PRESS
ONE ZERO AT THISTIME WHEN FILED
BY ZERO BY NINETY SIX PLEASE GO
AHEAD. YES THEY ARE RESTORING
COASTAL SON REGENERATIVE ORGANIC
CANNABIS GROWERS I'M ACTUALLY IN
STRONG SUPPORT FOR SOME REASON I
GOT BUMPED OUT OF THE QUEUE
PREVIOUSLY BUT I'M IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF THIS. WONDERFUL BILL
THANK YOU SENATOR BRADFORD FOR
ALL YOUR HARD WORK. THANK YOU SO
MUCH NEXT PLEASE. FORTY SEVEN
YOU ARE OPEN. WITHOUT ON THE
HAPPEN I'LL TROUT. IT IS THE
NATURE CONSERVANCY CALIFORNIA
PLANT SOCIETY VENDORS OF
WILDLIFE AND THE CROP PROJECT IN
OPPOSITION. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
. NEXT PLEASE MADAM CHAIR NOBODY
ELSE YOU'D UP WITH THIS PLAN
VERY GOOD WORK WILL BRING THAT-
MATTER BACK TO THE COMMITTEE IS
ARE THERE ANY COMMENTS CONCERNS
. SEEING NONE I'LL ENTERTAIN A
MOTION. THE MOTION IS TO PASS AS
AMENDED BUT FIRST AMEND AND RE
REFER TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS I THANK YOU FOR
BRINGING THIS FORWARD MY
ASSUMPTION IS THAT SOME OF THIS
IS GOING TO BE A HASHED OUT- IN
THE BUDGET BUT IF IT ISN'T THEN
THIS NEEDS TO MOVE ON SO THAT
THERE COULD BE FURTHER
DISCUSSIONS WITH THE ASSEMBLY ON
HOW WE GET THERE. GET TO EQUITY
SO APPRECIATE IT- YOU MAKE
INCLUDE- LOG WE'RE BOTH THE
SUPPORTERS AND THE OPPOSITION OF
THIS BILL AND- THIS BILL BY NO
MEANS THREATENS TO TAKE AWAY
THOSE PROGRAMS WHICH WAS.
ALREADY BEING FUNDED WERE CLEAR
ABOUT THAT- WE TRULY BELIEVE IF
YOU. INCREASE THE LEGAL MARKET
IT WILL BE. NO LOSS OF THOSE
PROGRAMS. WILL BE A INCREASE THE
FUNDING FOR THOSE PROGRAMS.
BECAUSE AGAIN THE MAJORITY OF
FOLKS NOW ARE USING THE LEGAL
MARKET I AND I WILL NEVER REFER
TO IT AS A BLACK MARKET BECAUSE-
JUST LIKE THERE'S NO BLACK AND
BROWN PEOPLE ON THE LEGITIMATE
MARKET WE'RE NOT DOING THE LEGAL
MARKET YOU THEM. HE EITHER SO
IT'S UP. LISTEN MARKET THAT IS
DOING THE MAJORITY OF THE WORK
HERE. AND SO WE CAN MOVE THOSE
FOLKS TO THE RETAIL DOORS THERE
WERE ONLY EIGHT. AND ACHIEVING
THE GOAL BECAUSE FOLKS ARE NOT
MAKING A PROFIT EITHER- TO
BELIEVE THAT FOLKS MOST FOLKS
ARE STRUGGLING TO KEEP THEIR
DOORS. OPEN SO THIS IS A COMMON
SENSE MEASURE AND I WAS.
STRONGLY AYE OUTRIGGER AYE VOTE
THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
THE MOTION IS TO PASS AS AMENDED
BUT FIRST AMENDED RE REFER TO
THE COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS.
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL SENATORS
CAPITO HI CABALLERO HI NIELSEN.
NO NIELSEN NO DURAZO. TERRAZZO.
HI HERTZBERG. WIENER TWO ONE THE
BILL HAS TO VOTER GONNA PUT IT
ON CALL PRECIADO. YOUR TESTIMONY
HERE- PRESENTATION HERE TODAY
WERE YOU HAVE- TWO MORE BILLS
WILL TAKE UP ITEM NUMBER TEN S.
B. TWELVE NINETY THREE OKAY. AND
WE'RE BACK AGAIN ON ON TAX
CREDITS IN A- EQUITIES- AGAIN
TWELVE NINETY THREE WOULD
PROVIDE LICENSE CANNABIS EQUITY
OPERATORS- WITH TAX CREDIT WITH
A TAX CREDIT THAT WOULD APPLY TO
THEIR PERSONAL INCOME AND
CORPORATE TAX INCOME- INTO TWO
THOUSAND SIXTEEN AND WE PASSED
PROP SIXTY FOUR WITH THE
ESTABLISHED TO LEGALIZE CANNABIS
MARKET. AND WHILE CALIFORNIA'S
CLEARED THE PATH FOR CANNABIS
INDUSTRIES TO OPERATE LEGALLY
MANY OF THE COUNTLESS VISITORS
ARE STRUGGLING TO SURVIVE THRUSH
THOSE OF OUR OWN BY WOMEN PEOPLE
OF COLOR AND OUR EQUITY OPERATOR
SO- IT'S A CRISIS AND AS I
STATED I ATTENDED A CONFERENCE
ON IN DECEMBER AND ATLANTA WHERE
WE HAD OVER FOUR HUNDRED STATE
LEGISLATORS FROM ALL ACROSS THE
COUNTRY AND THEY'RE ALL SAYING
THE SAME THING THAT. EQUITY
OPERATORS ARE STRUGGLING TO KEEP
THEIR DOORS OPEN EVEN THOUGH THE
MODEL ARE LEGISLATION SB TWELVE
NINETY FOUR WHICH ARE OUT THERE
THREE YEARS AGO FOUR YEARS AGO
TO CREATE THE FIRST SOCIAL
SOCIAL EQUITY PROGRAM IN THE
COUNTRY IT'S FAILING MISERABLY.
AND ENTREAT ACHIEVING ITS GOALS.
REPORTING TWENTY TWO ONE BY THE
CALIFORNIA CANNABIS INDUSTRY
ASSOCIATION NOTES THAT WHILE THE
BARRIERS TO MARKET ENTRY ARE
HIGH FOR. ANY CANNABIS OPERATOR
THE ODDS ARE AGAINST AVERAGE
EQUITY OPERATOR WHO MIGHT NOT
HAVE THE SAME RESOURCES AND
ADVANTAGES. OF OTHER OPERATORS
IN THE MARKETPLACE REPORT
RECOMMENDS PROVIDING TAX RELIEF
AN ADDITIONAL FUNDING TO SUPPORT
CANNABIS SOCIAL EQUITY.
OPERATORS FEDERAL LAW IN TAX
EQUITY AND FISCAL RESPONSIBILITY
ACT PROHIBITS TAXPAYERS FROM
DEDUCTING OR CLAIMING. FOR ANY
AMOUNTS PAID OR IN CURE.
INCURRED IN CARRYING ON ANY
TRADE OR BUSINESS AND SUCH TRADE
OR BUSINESS CONSIST OF TROPIC
KING IN A CONTROLLED SUBSTANCE.
SINCE CANNABIS CONTINUES TO BE
CLASSIFIED AS A SCHEDULE ONE
CONTROLLED STOP SUBSTANCE A
BUSINESS THE SALES CANNABIS EVEN
IN THE STATE WERE IN THIS LEAGUE
IT IS LEGAL CANNOT DEDUCT
ORDINARY. AND NECESSARY BUSINESS
EXPENSES. FROM OTHER FEDERAL
TAXES ONE WAY TO A FACT GOAL OF
FINANCIALLY HOPING EQUITY
OPERATORS TO THE STATE TAX
CREDIT FOR CANADA'S BUSINESS
RELATED TO EXPENSES. DUCKS
CREDIT WOULD REDUCE THE TAX
LIABILITY OF EQUITY THE CANNABIS
OPERATORS ARE BROUGHT PROVIDE
SOME RELIEF THAT MAY HELP THEIR
BUSINESSES SURVIVE THIS WILL
STOP TO TAX CREDIT THAT WILL
ALLOW. A LICENSE EQUITY
OPERATORS IN CANNABIS INDUSTRY
TO ACCOUNT FOR THE FACT THAT
THEY COULD NOT WRITE OFF
BUSINESS RELATED EXPENSES AT THE
FEDERAL LEVEL THE TAX CREDIT
WOULD HELP EQUITY CANNABIS
OPERATORS THAT WERE
DISPROPORTIONATELY. HARM DURING
THE WAR ON DRUGS OVER THE LAST
FOUR YEARS OR AT LEAST LIVE IN
THE AREA THAT WAS SPEND ECONOMIC
DISADVANTAGED. AND STAY AND GROW
IN THEIR OWN COMMUNITIES AND
GROW THESE BUSINESSES SB TWELVE
NINETY THREE TAKES EFFECT IN
JANUARY TWENTY TWENTY THREE OF
ITS PAST IN A BLOG TO TAX YEAR
TWENTY TWENTY TWO. INCLUSIVE
TWELVE NINETY THREE INCLUDES A
SUNSET DATE OF DECEMBER THIRTY
ONE ON TWENTY TWENTY SEVEN HERE
TESTIFY WILL MISTER SHOCKLEY IS
NOT YOUR TESTIFIED WE HAVE A
REPLACEMENT HERE. AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK RIVAL. YES WE
HAVE KALO FERGUSON THE DEPUTY
DEPUTY DIRECTOR CALIFORNIA
EQUITY COUNCIL YES THANK YOU.
THERE'S MY NAME IS COME OVER.
I'M IF YOU'RE FOR CANNABIS
EQUITY POLICY COUNCIL. C. P.
REPRESENTS HUNDRED OF CANNABIS
EQUITY ENTREPRENEURS OF ALL
LICENSE TYPES ACROSS THE STATE
INCLUDING EQUITY OPERATOR FROM
SACRAMENTO THE BAY AREA LOS
ANGELES AND EMERGING SAN DIEGO
MARKET. OUR GOAL IS TO PROMOTE
MEDICAL CANNABIS POLICY AT THE
STATE AND LOCAL LEVEL. ANY OF
YOU HAVE PROBABLY HEARD ABOUT
THE CHALLENGES ASSOCIATED WITH
OPENING A COMMERCIAL CANNABIS
BUSINESS. HOWEVER WHAT MANY OF
YOU THE PUBLIC DO NOT KNOW DO
NOT REALIZE THAT THE BARRIERS TO
ENTRY AND THE CAMERAS INDUSTRY
ARE SIGNIFICANTLY GREATER. TO
LEGITIMATE EQUITY OPERATORS. A
TWENTY SEVENTEEN MARIJUANA
BUSINESS DAILY REPORT FOUND THAT
FIVE POINT SEVEN CANNABIS
BUSINESSES FOUNDERS IDENTIFIED
AS LATINO. FOUR POINT 3%
IDENTIFY AS AFRICAN AMERICAN AND
TWO POINT FOR PERSONS AS ASIAN.
SEVERAL OF THE SAME OBSTACLES
THAT LEAD TO INEQUITIES FOR
COMMITTEES OF COLOR. AND
UNDERSERVED POPULATIONS IN
INDUSTRIES LIKE HOUSING AND
HEALTH CARE ARE CREATING THE
SAME CHALLENGES IN THE CANNABIS
MARKET. AMONG OTHER THINGS IT IS
HOW IT IS MORE CHALLENGING FOR
EQUITY OPERATORS TO ACQUIRE
INITIAL CAPITAL FINANCING. IS
MORE CHALLENGING FRANKLY
OPERATORS TO FIND ELIGIBLE REAL
ESTATE AND IT'S HOUSING TO GO TO
THE LICENSING PROCESS. CANADA'S
EQUITY OUT OF THE NORTH FACE
PROBLEMS RELATED TO ECONOMIES OF
SCALE THAT'S A PRESS THEIR
ABILITY TO REACH OPTIMAL GROWTH
RATES. THE HIGH TAX RATE
INDUSTRY PAIRED WITH THE
INABILITY TO ACCESS CAPITAL
THEREBY HINDERS THE ABILITY OF
EQUITY OPERATIVE TO COMPETE WITH
LARGER OPERATIONS. IN THIS IS
THE PAPERWORK NECESSARY TO APPLY
FOR CANNABIS LICENSE. FOR NORTH
MUST ALSO PROVE THAT THEY ARE
BONA FIDE EQUITY APPLICANTS.
THIS REQUIRES BUSINESS BUSINESS
OWNERS SELECT ONES HERE TODAY.
THE DOCTOR THIS NO HOOPS IN
ORDER TO QUALIFY FOR A LICENSE.
IN THE CITY OF LOS ANGELES THESE
WHO CAN GO TO GOING TO A FIRST
COME FIRST SERVE WINDOW TO FILE
FOR ONE COVERED INITIAL SPOTS.
ONE OF THE COVETED MISSILES BUT
FRANKLY LICENSES AND PROCESS
THAT LED TO A LAWSUIT AGAINST
THE CITY. EACH OF THESE
CHALLENGES COMES WITH INCREASED
COST EQUITY ENTREPRENEURS
ADDITIONAL LEGAL FEES THE TIME
SPENT FOR RESEARCH AN EXTRA
PAPERWORK. AND OTHER RESOURCES
WE HAVE NEEDED THEY HAD NEED TO
SPEND AWAY FROM THEIR BUSINESS
PLANS. THIS LED TO A HUGE
DISADVANTAGE FOR EQUITY
OPERATORS BEFORE WE BEFORE THEY
EVEN OPENED THE DOORS. TO THE
BUSINESS FOR PUBLIC. SB TWELVE
NINE THREE. IS CRITICAL BECAUSE
PROVIDES EQUITY OPERATORS SOME
SORT OF FINANCIAL RELIEF NEEDED
TO ALLOW THE BUSINESS TO THRIVE.
THIS BUSINESS HELP LEVEL THE
PLAYING FIELD BETWEEN EQUITY AND
NON EQUITY BUSINESSES. THE
FUNDING FROM TAX CREDITS HEALTH
EQUITY BUSINESS RECOUP SOME OF
THE COSTS THAT WE NEED. THEY
NEED TO USE OUR A TF CARD TO USE
IN OTHER AREAS TO MAINTAIN THE
STATUS I SOCIAL EQUITY
OPERATORS. A SAYS THAT THEY HOLD
BECAUSE OF THEIR AND DOESN'T
EXPERIENCE BY THEM THEIR
FAMILIES AND OTHER COMMUNITIES
IMPACTED BY THE WAR ON DRUGS. I
STRONGLY URGE SUPPORT ON THIS
BEFORE NINETY THREE TODAY THAT
CALIFORNIA KEEP ITS PROMISE AND
TO PROMOTE EQUITY AND SUPPORT
THOSE COMMUNITIES NEGATIVELY
IMPACTED BY PAST CRIMINAL. CAN
PROMISES POLICIES THANK YOU VERY
MUCH SENATOR BRADFORD AND TO THE
COMMITTEE FOR THE OPPORTUNITY
PRESENT TODAY I'M HAPPY HAPPY TO
ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS AT THE
APPROPRIATE TIME. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH FOR YOUR TESTIMONY. WILL
MOVE ON AND SEE IF THERE'S
ANYBODY IN THE ROOM THAT WOULD
LIKE TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT
PLEASE COME FORWARD. LINDSEY
ROBINSON ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA CANNABIS INDUSTRY
ASSOCIATION IN STRONG SUPPORT
THANK YOU. MARIN PM BEHALF OF
THE AMERICAN HAS BEEN
ASSOCIATION SUPPORT. THANK YOU
SENATOR MEMBERS RENT MORE NOT BE
HALF OF THE PARENT COMPANY WHICH
HAS ITS OWN VERY ACTIVE ON
SOCIAL EQUITY PROGRAM IN VERY
STRONG SUPPORT OF THIS BILL.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU KEVIN HOOKS
US SOCIAL EQUITY OPERATOR'S
LICENSE HOLDER HERE IN
SACRAMENTO STRONGLY SUPPORT.
THANK YOU. BRANDON BOLDEN LOCAL
SOCIAL EQUITY ENTREPRENEUR IN
FULL SUPPORT. THANK YOU. CARL
CRAWFORD EQUITY OPERATE WITHIN
THE CITY IFS IN SUPPORT IF
AMENDED TO INCLUDE LANGUAGE THAT
REMOVES BARRIERS TO ENTRY FOR
EQUITY APPLICANTS THANK YOU. ASH
A SHORT PAN LOPEZ ON BEHALF OF
CALIFORNIA NORMAL IN SUPPORT
THANK YOU. IMACS ARE HOT SO EVEN
IF YOU'RE SURE YOU GET PICKED UP
SO IT'S ALL GOOD. IS IT UP BY
SAYING NO OTHER. TEST BY
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT IN THE ROOM
WILL MOVE ON TO THE
TELECONFERENCE LINE MISTER
MODERATOR IF YOU COULD QUEUE UP.
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU
FOR YOUR SUPPORT OF SB A TWELVE
NINETY THREE PLEASE PRESS ONE
FOLLOWED BY ZERO. ONE FILED BY
ZERO AND WE WILL LINE ONE
SEVENTY FIVE PLEASE GO AHEAD. I
WANT SEVENTY FIVE YOU ARE OPEN.
WE HEAR YOU ONE SEVENTY FIVE.
WOULD YOU LIKE TO TESTIFY. ALL
RIGHT WE'LL MOVE ON TO- WANT TO
LINE TWENTY FOUR YOU ARE OPEN.
TWENTY FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HELLO HELLO. YES WE CAN HEAR YOU
HOW ARE. BRIGITTE HELLO- OWNER
OPERATOR IN THE CITY OF LOS
ANGELES IN STRONG SUPPORT THANK
YOU. ONE EIGHTY THREE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. BY ONE EIGHTY THREE RURAL
. HELLO THIS IS CHANTELLE PLANE
I ONCE AGAIN REPRESENTED TEXAS
FOR CANNABIS RETAILERS ALIVE AND
OVER TWO DOZEN SOCIAL EQUITY AND
LEGACY MEDICAL CANNABIS
OPERATORS IN STRONG SUPPORT OF
ITSELF THANK YOU. THANK YOU. ONE
SEVENTY THREE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD MORNING THIS IS ALFIE
SORIANO'S SOCIAL EQUITY ON YOUR
AND ADVOCATE VICE PRESIDENT OF
THE SOCIAL EQUITY OWNERS AND
WORKERS ASSOCIATION ON BEHALF OF
ALLY SPECIFICALLY RETAILERS WE
STRONGLY SUPPORT THIS BILL.
THANK YOU THANK YOU. ONE EIGHTY
TO YOUR OPEN. HELLO MY NAME IS
RUTH RIVERA. IF YOU'RE ON. YES
FROM THE EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF
SOCIAL EQUITY L. A. AS WELL AS A
SOCIAL EQUITY OPERATOR- STRONG
SUPPORT OF DINNER FIVE FERNANDES
BILL. THANK YOU. ONE TWENTY NINE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. TWENTY NINE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. A BRIAN COLLINS
IN STRONG SUPPORT OF THE BILL
THANK YOU. FIFTY SIX YOU ARE
OPEN. GOOD MORNING I AM IN ONLY
JERIT ON BEHALF OF INDO
INDUSTRIES WE ARE IN SUPPORT OF
S. B. TWELVE NINETY THREE. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU TO ALL PLEASE GO
AHEAD. IT WOULD BE HARD TO. FIND
BOB. I THANK YOU VERY MUCH. I'M
SURE THERE ARE NO OTHER
PARTICIPANTS QUEUED UP. NUMBER
ONE IS THAT POSSIBLE TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT. YES YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. A LINK OVER
SPEAKING AS AN INDIVIDUAL- IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
YEAH ONE MORE QUEUE UP ON THE
PHONE LINES YOU'D LIKE TO TAKE
THAT YES. ACTUALLY THERE'S- A
COUPLE HERE AND WON- RE QUEUED I
LIKE ONE SEVENTY FIVE PEOPLE AT
. ALL GOOD AFTERNOON NIGHT OF
OCT WITH MY LOVE GROUP- CALLING
ON BEHALF OF VERIFICATION FIFTY
FIVE CARRYING DR BRONNER'S SOAP
AND- COMPUTER CONTRACTING
PROSPERITY FARMS SUPPORT HAVE-
TWELVE NINETY THREE AND SENATOR
FOR BEGINNING TO ADDRESS THAT
PROBLEM. ACUITY THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. ONE NINETY TWO PLEASE GO
AHEAD. RELATED TO YOUR OPEN
AGAIN. IN YOUR ME YEAH. YES MY
NAME IS SANTA CLAUS. IN THIS
INDUSTRY ADVOCATE FOR SELECT THE
AB IN SMALL BUSINESS SMALL
FARMER ADVOCATE AND I STRONGLY
SUPPORT THIS BILL. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. ADAM SURE NOBODY ELSE
CUED UP. GOOD WE'RE GONNA MOVE
ON TO OPPOSITION WE HAVE NO LEAD
OPPOSITION WITNESSES SO WHEN TO
SEE IF THERE'S ANYBODY IN THE
ROOM THAT WOULD LIKE TO TESTIFY
IN OPPOSITION THE S. B. TWELVE
NINETY THREE. SINGMAN WILL MOVE
ON TO THE TELECONFERENCE LINE-
MISTER MODERATE IF YOU COULD
QUEUE UP THE THOSE WHO WISH TO
TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION. YES WE DO
HAVE SOMEONE ROUTE JUST BY IN
OPPOSITION TO- SB TWELVE NINETY
THREE THE FIRST UNDER OUR SYSTEM
ONE FALL BY ZERO. OPPOSITION TO
OUR SB ONE TWO NINE THREE.
THERE'S ONE WITH AN OPERATOR ONE
MOMENT MA'AM SURE ANYBODY ELSE
PLEASE TAKE THIS OPPORTUNITY A
PRESS ONE FOLLOWED BY ZERO. AND
WILL THE LINE ONE OF FOUR PLEASE
GO AHEAD. ONE OF FOR YOUR OPEN.
WHAT WOULD YOU LIKE TO TESTIFY.
GREAT THERE'S ONE MORE QUEUING
UP WHAT- FOR MORE SHOT WOULD YOU
LIKE TO TESTIFY YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. AMMOLITE TO ELEVEN YOU ARE
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. ONE TWO
ELEVEN ARE YOU MUTED. THIS IS
YOUR YOU'RE WORTH FOLLOWING AS
AN INDIVIDUAL AND I OPPOSE UNITS
FAIL. VERY GOOD THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. NOBODY ELSE CUED UP MADAM
CHAIR VERY GOOD WILL COME BACK
TO THAT- COMMITTEE RUMEN PLEASE
A LOT OF ALLOW YOU TO TESTIFY.
GOOD MORNING AGAIN SENATORS MY
NAME'S TECH ALLEN AYE AND THE
LEGISLATIVE MEETING HERE FOR THE
CD BLACK CAUCUS WE ONCE AGAIN
ONLY OPPOSE THE BILL BECAUSE WE
ARE TRYING TO CLOSE UP SOME OF
THE LOOPHOLES ESPECIALLY WHEN IT
COMES TO MORE EQUITABLE ACCESS
INITIATIVES FOR THE MOST IMPACT
THE COMMUNITY WE THANK YOU
SENATOR BRADFORD FOR ENGAGING IN
CONVERSATION WITH US AND WE LOOK
FOR TO CONTINUE TO WORK WITH YOU
IN THE CPC. TO GET TO THAT
DEFINITION ARE LOOKING FOR. VERY
GOOD THANK YOU SO MUCH. IS THERE
ANYONE ELSE IN THE ROOM. SEEING
NO OTHER OPPOSITION WILL BRING
THE MATTER BACK TO THE COMMITTEE
FOR- COMMENTS QUESTIONS MOTIONS
. THERE IS MOTION CENTER
BRADFORD YOU MAKE INCLUDE. THANK
YOU MANAGER AND AGAIN I WANT TO
THANK THE WITNESSES BOTH IN
SUPPORT. INFANCY AND YOU SIXTY
THE STRUGGLES THAT WE HAVE- WHEN
YOU TALK ABOUT SOCIAL EQUITY AND
IT'S A SHAME THAT WE HAVE TO
COME KANSI DO LEGISLATION TO
ADDRESS THE INEQUITY ACT
INEQUITIES AND- THE AND
DEFICIENCIES THAT. EXIST BUT
THEY ARE REAL I INDUSTRY THAT'S
JUST FOUR YEARS. AND IT'S YOU
KNOW INTRODUCTION IT'S DOMINATED
BY 85% WHITE MEN AND WE SHOULD
ALL BE CONCERNED ABOUT THAT
BECAUSE WE'RE TALKING ABOUT THE
CRIMINALIZATION OF MARIJUANA
WOULD BE NOTHING BUT BLACK AND
BROWN PEOPLE IN THE ROOM MOST OF
THE TIME. SO WHEN WE TALK ABOUT
THE OPPORTUNITY TO MAKE MONEY TO
GROW BUSINESS TO SUSTAIN THE
COMMUNITY AND- AND CREATE WEALTH
WERE STILL BEING- CHALLENGE SO
THIS IS JUST FACE OMMONSENSE
MEASURE THAT PROVIDES ONLY A TEN
THOUSAND DOLLAR TAX CREDIT. ON
THEIR PERSONAL INCOME AND I WAS
REQUEST FOR AYE VOTE. THE MOTION
IS TO PASS BUT FIRST BE RE RE
REFERRED TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL SENATORS COME A YEAR AGO HI
CABALLERO- HI NIELSEN. NIELSEN
NO DURAZO. TERRAZZO HI HERTZBERG
. WIENER AYE WIENER HI. THREE
ONE THREE EYES ONE NO I'M GONNA
PUT THAT ON CALL BUT IT IS OUT
THANK YOU IT WILL GET OUT I'M
GONNA MOVE ON TO THE FINAL ITEM
THAT YOU HAVE HERE SENATOR WHICH
IS SB FOURTEEN SEVENTY SIX.
THANK YOU. BOB THIS SIMPLY
MONITOR. HOUSES TO PURCHASING A
THORNY FOR THE WEST I MEAN A
WATER REPLENISHMENT DISTRICT IN
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA BETTER KNOWN
AS W. R. D. AND I START BY
SAYING AND I ACCEPTED CAN
COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS. TO ADD
FIVE YEAR SUNSET ON THE
ELIMINATION OF THE REQUIREMENT
FOR COMPETITIVE BIDDING- THIS
BILL WOULD JUST MODIFY. MODIFY
THE PROVISIONS OF EXISTING LAW
THAT REQUIRED COMPETITIVE
BIDDING AND PUBLIC NOTICE
PROCEDURES- FOR CONTRACTING WITH
A W. R. D. IT WOULD ELIMINATE
THE REQUIREMENT SAID W. R. D.
ADVERTISE FOR BIDS FOR
PROFESSIONAL SERVICES MATERIALS
SUPPLIES. AND EQUIPMENT THAT ARE
VALUED AT TWENTY FIVE THOUSAND
STATE RECORD OF YOUR DUE TO
ADOPT POLICIES AND PROCEDURES
GOVERNING CONTRACTS FOR
PROFESSIONAL SERVICES MATERIAL.
BUT IS THE PREDATOR BIT BIT
REQUIREMENT FOR WORKS CONTRACTS
FIVE THOUSAND MORE IT WOULD
INCREASE FROM 1-000-024-0000 THE
THRESHOLD AMOUNT FOR CONTRACTS
AND OTHER DOCUMENTS THAT REQUIRE
AUTHORIZATION BY THE BOARD OF
DIRECTORS- THIS WILL THROUGHOUT
THE BOARD TO FOCUS ON MATTERS OF
GREATER IMPORTANCE RATHER THAN
ACTING ON EVERY SMALL PURCHASE
CONTRACT- FOR WHICH- FUNDING HAS
BEEN. PREVIOUSLY APPROVED BY THE
DISTRICT'S ANNUAL BUDGET- OFFER
TWENTY YEARS W. RDS FROM THIS
AND FROM A LOCAL AGENCY THAT
PURCHASED WATER. BOB FOR
GROUNDWATER REPLENISHMENT
PURPOSES TO AN AGENCY THAT OWNS
TO ADVANCE WATER TREATMENT
FACILITIES AND AROUND WATER. D.
SALTER ON THE EVOLUTION OF
INJURING ONE CONTRACT. OUR WATER
PURCHASE TO ENTERING A MERIT OF
CONTRACTS NECESSARY FOR THE
OPERATION OF EVENTS WATER
TREATMENT FACILITIES NOW CALLS
FOR UPDATING THE WATER
REPLENISHMENT DISTRICT ACT AS
OPPOSED BY THIS MEASURE
STREAMLINING THE PURCHASE
PROCESS WILL BE MORE EFFICIENT
IN TERMS OF TIME AND COST- THIS
WILL HELP W. R. D. IN ITS
EFFORTS TO KEEP REPLACE.
ASSESSMENT INCREASES ACTUAL
SALES INCREASE TO THE MINIMUM
NEED TO ENSURE THE GROUNDWATER
BASINS ARE OPERATE. KANAB DOUBLE
- OPTIMAL MANNER THE MORE
OPERATIONAL EFFICIENCIES WILL
ALLOW MORE AFFORDABLE WATER
SERVICES- OF FOR ALL OF OUR
CONSTITUENTS AND MODERNIZATION
THE OF MODERNIZING I SHOULD SAY
THE PURCHASING OF THE- STORY OF
W. R. D. I WILL BRING IT IN LINE
WITH ALL THE LOCAL AGENCIES
INCLUDING CITIES AND COUNTIES.
HERE TO TESTIFY AS WELL. BUT TO
USE- ASSISTANT GENERAL MANAGER
OF THE WATER REPLENISHMENT
DISTRICT. VERY GOOD WHAT WILL I
MOVE ON TO YOUR- PRIMARY
WITNESS- ROB BEST FASTER. FROM
THE WATER REPLENISHMENT DISTRICT
OF SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA. YES
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE- ROTH
AS THE ASSISTANT GENERAL MANAGER
OF THE WATER REPLENISHMENT
DISTRICT OF SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA
AND THE SPONSOR OF SB FOURTEEN
SEVENTY SIX. THIS LEGISLATION IS
NEEDED STREAMLINED THE CURRENT
PURCHASING PROCESS FOR DISTRICTS
TO BE MORE EFFICIENT IN TERMS OF
TIME AND COST. SB FORTY SEVENTY
SIX WILL BETTER ENABLE THE
DISTRICT. BONTA MATERIALS
EQUIPMENT REPAIR AND REPLACEMENT
NEEDS THAT ARE ADVANCE FOR
TREATMENT PLANTS. AND FACILITIES
THAT HAVE BEEN BUILT TO REPLACE
OUR NEED TO IMPORT PURCHASE
IMPORTED WATER. TO OUR TO
GROUNDWATER BASINS THAT BENEFIT
FOR MILLION CALIFORNIANS IN OUR
SERVICE AREA. FINALLY SB
FOURTEEN SEVENTY SIX PRESERVES
THE OPEN AND TRANSPARENT
PURCHASING PROCEDURES THAT ARE
SET IN OUR ADMINISTRATIVE CODE
WHICH IS A PUBLIC DOCUMENT. I'M
HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS I
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST ABOUT BOTH
AND I THINK CELEBRATE FOR
PROCURING THIS BILL. VERY GOOD-
IS THERE ANYONE IN THE COMMITTEE
ROOM THAT WOULD LIKE TO TESTIFY
IN SUPPORT. SEEING NO ONE WILL
MOVE ON TO THE TELECONFERENCE
LINE IN AND SEE IF THERE'S
ANYONE THAT WOULD LIKE TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF SB
FOURTEEN SEVENTY SIX. THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR IF YOU ARE IN
SUPPORT OF SB FOURTEEN SEVENTY
SIX PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO ONE
FILED BY ZERO AT THIS TIME.
NOBODY IS GIVING UP ADAM SHARE.
VERY GOOD. WE DO NOT HAVE A LEAD
OPPOSITION WITNESS SO WE'LL SEE
IF THERE'S ANYONE IN THERE IN
THE COMMITTEE ROOM THAT WOULD
LIKE TO TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION.
SEEING NONE WILL GO TO THE
TELECONFERENCE LINE AND SEE IF
THERE'S ANYONE. THANK YOU IF YOU
WOULD LIKE TO EXPRESS SUPPORT
ARE EXCUSE ME OPPOSITION TO SB
FOURTEEN SEVENTY SIX PLEASE
PRESS ONE ZERO FOR OPPOSITION TO
SB FOURTEEN SEVENTY SIX. AND
NOBODY IS GOING OUT. VERY GOOD
BOB WILL BRING THIS MATTER BACK
TO THE COMMITTEE FOUR COMMENTS
QUESTIONS CONCERNS A MOTION.
MOTION MADE BY SENATOR DERIVE SO
MOTION IS TO PASS AMENDED TO THE
SENATE FLOOR. SENATOR WOULD YOU
LIKE TO CONCLUDE OUR SUCCESS
YOU'RE A VOTE THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
SENATORS CAMBIADO HI CABALLERO
HI NIELSEN RIGHT NIELSEN HI
COROZZO TERRAZZO HI HERTZBERG.
WIENER WIENER HI. FOUR ZERO
FORTY ZERO WILL PUT THE MATTER
ON CALL FOR THE MISSING MEMBER
THANK YOU MENTOR COMMITTEE
MEMBERS THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
SENATOR ARLEN WELCOME S. B.
TWELVE NINETY SO COMMITTEE
MEMBERS- WE'RE RUNNING OUT OF
TIME WE STARTED AT NINE O'CLOCK
THIS MORNING AND- AND BELIEVE
THAT THERE ARE OTHER COMMITTEE
HEARING TO START AT ONE THIRTY
AND THIS ROOM IS NEEDED- BY ONE
THIRTY SO WHAT I'D LIKE TO DO-
FOR THE REMAINING CASE THAT
BILLS IS TO SET UP A FIFTEEN
MINUTES FOR EITHER SIDE SO THAT
WE CAN. TRY TO SEE IF WE CAN GET
THROUGH ALL OF THAT WITNESSES
THAT WANT TO TESTIFY AND
ANNOUNCED THAT THE WITNESSES TO
BE AS SUCCINCT AS POSSIBLE- IN
ORDER FOR US TO YOU KNOW
APPROPRIATELY HERE BUT ALSO TO
MAKE SURE THAT WE CAN GET AS
MANY PEOPLE THAT ARE ON THE LINE
AS POSSIBLE SO- CENTER WELCOME
THANK YOU WELL- SO LET ME THINK
THE COMMITTEE IN THE CHAIR. TIME
IT ANY GIVEN TO THIS. ALSO WE
DISCUSS THE SUPPORT ISSUE THAT
WOULD ARE YOU TODAY- HAVE YOU
TAKE THE AMENDMENTS IN THE-
COMMITTEE ALL THE AMENDMENTS.
ARE THIS YEAR OUR LEGISLATURE IS
ENGAGED IN IMPORT DEBATE OVER AN
EFFORT TO PROVIDE MORE
REASONABLE AFFORDABLE LEGAL
PATHWAYS FOR STREET AND MOBILE
VENDING THROUGHOUT OUR STATE-
THE EFFORT FOR A BUILT UPON THE
GROUND BREAKING WORK OF OUR
FORMER COLLEAGUE SENATOR- AND
COMMISSIONER RICARDO LARA TO
DECRIMINALIZE STREET VENDING.
IT'S A BILL THAT I BUT IF- AND-
WHEN IT PASSED AND WAS SIGNED
INTO LAW TWENTY EIGHTEEN. AND I
STRONGLY SUPPORT THE WORK OF OUR
COLLEAGUE LENA GONZALEZ IS WORK
TO TRY TO MAKE ESSENTIAL REFORMS
OF THE RETAIL FOOD CODE. IN HER
BILL THAT SHE HAS MOVING I WHICH
PASS AND HEALTH COMMITTEE
RECENTLY TO COME BEFORE THIS
BODY FOR LATER THIS MONTH- NOW.
BY BRINGING THIS BILL TO YOU
TODAY BECAUSE IT'S MY SINCERE
BELIEF THAT IN CERTAIN
COMMUNITIES THROUGHOUT OUR STATE
INCLUDING MY DISTRICT SICKLY
HIGH TOURIST AREAS CHARLIE I
TOURIST AREAS ARE THERE ARE
THOSE WHO ARE THERE'S A SMALL
GROUP OF PEOPLE BUT BUT IT BUT
IT BUT A NOT INSIGNIFICANT-
FOLKS WHO ARE EXPLOITING THE
GOODWILL. OF ARE MORE PERMISSIVE
VENDING LAWS TO OPERATE WITH
THAT DEGREE OF IMPUNITY AND
DISREGARD FOR PROPERTY PUBLIC
SAFETY. AND PUBLIC HEALTH. AS
THIS BILL IS PROPOSED TO BE
AMENDED TO MAKE A VERY MODEST
CHANGE. TO THE CIVIL PENALTY
FRAMEWORK THAT LOCAL GOVERNMENTS
COULD UTILIZE IN THE YOU
REGULATE REGULATION STREET
VENDING. SPECIFICALLY THE BILL
WOULD PROVIDE LOCAL GOVERNMENTS
WITH THE OPTION TO IMPOSE A
HIGHER FINE ON VENDORS WHO WERE
CITED FOR THE EXACT SAME
VIOLATION FOUR OR MORE TIMES
WITHIN A ONE YEAR PERIOD.
HOWEVER TO EXERCISE THAT OPTION
A LOCAL GOVERNMENT MUST ALSO.
ONE ESTABLISH IN DISTRICTS
DIRECTLY ADJACENT TO ANY AREAS
WHERE THEY BANNED EITHER
STATIONARY OR ROAMING SIDEWALK
VENDORS TO. IDENTIFY VENDING
DISTRICTS IN BANNED AREAS ON
THEIR WEBSITE THROUGH PROMINENT
SIGNAGE AND TO ADDRESS LANGUAGE
ISSUES PROST ONLINE ALL VENDING
REGULATIONS IN THE MOST TO MOST
COMMONLY SPOKEN LANGUAGES IN THE
JURISDICTION. CERTAINLY HAPPY TO
TALK MORE ABOUT WAYS TO- TO
LIMIT THE IMPACT OF THE BILL IF
THAT'S OF INTEREST TO THE TO THE
FOLKS HERE- THIS COMMITTEES
AMENDMENTS TO THE BILL ALSO
REQUIRE THE GO BIZ ISSUE REPORT
ON THE EXTENT OF NON COMPLIANCE
WITH LOCAL SIDEWALK VENDING
ORDINANCES IN CALIFORNIA INCLUDE
RECOMMENDATIONS FOR LEGISLATIVE
CHANGES. IMPOSE A THREE YEAR
SUNSET- SO THAT THOSE WHO
SUPPORT THIS BILL MUST RETURN TO
SACRAMENTO TO SHOW THAT THE LAW
IS WORKING AS INTENDED. THE
LEGISLATION SUPPORTED AND
SPONSORED BY THE CITY SANTA
MONICA- BECAUSE IN HIGHLY
TRAFFICKED TOURIST DESTINATIONS
SUCH AS THE SANTA MONICA PIER
SAFE REGULAR. NURSES BY LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS INCREASINGLY
CHALLENGING. A CODE ENFORCEMENT
OFFICERS UTILIZING THE CIVIL
PENALTY STRUCTURE UNDER CURRENT
STATUTE HAVE NOT BEEN ABLE TO
STOCK. ROGUE VENDORS FROM
OPERATING IN AN UNSAFE MANNER IN
THE CITY. HAS CHOSEN. I TO
CREATE A TASK FORCE TO BRING
POLICE OFFICERS TO THE PIER TO
ENFORCE CRIMINAL PENALTIES. NOW
YOU MAY I HAVE BEEN TALKING A
LOT TO THE- TO THE- OPPONENTS OF
THE BILL- YOU KNOW THERE THERE
ARE- I GUESS THE COMMENT THAT
YOU HEAR A LOT AS WELL A LOT OF
THESE ACTIVITIES YOU'RE TALKING
ABOUT. ARE ALREADY ILLEGAL SO
THE BILL'S UNNECESSARY. BUT IN
THE END OF THE DAY THE PROBLEM
THAT WE RUN INTO WITH THAT
ARGUMENT IS THAT IT BASICALLY.
WE'RE BASICALLY TELLING LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS THAT YOU SHOULDN'T
SOLICIT EVEN SLIGHT MODIFICATION
CIVIL. I'M AND AS A RESULT YOUR
PRACTICE WHAT THAT MEANS IS THAT
CITIES LIKE SANTA MONICA ARE
JUST GONNA INSTEAD ALL THEY ALL
THEY CAN DO IS JUST PUT IN MANY
MORE POLICE AT GREAT COST- AND
ALSO A YOU KNOW TO ENFORCE THE
CRIMINAL PENALTIES THAT ARE
STILL AVAILABLE TO THEM. AND I
JUST CAN'T HELP BUT BELIEVE IT
THAT'S NOT ULTIMATELY IN THE
INTEREST OF THE FOLKS. WHO ARE
BEING ADVOCATED FOR BY SOME OF
THE FOLKS WHO RAISED CONCERNS
ABOUT THE BILL. SO MY STAFF AND
I'VE BEEN TALKING THE OPPONENTS
THIS BILL SINCE LAST YEAR- WE-
WE SHARE THEIR SINCERE VISION.
TO BRING MORE VENDORS OUT OF THE
SHADOWS TO LEGITIMATE THEIR
ENTREPRENEURIAL ACTIVITY. AROUND
THE STATE- I'VE OFFERED I WOULD
BE HAPPY TO TAKE IN A MOMENT
MAKING AN ACRONYM MY BILL
CONTINGENT ON THE NOT GONNA
CENTER GONZALEZ IS LEGISLATION
BECAUSE I ALSO BELIEVE THAT
CHANGES TO THE RETAIL FOOD CODE.
ARE ESSENTIAL IN ORDER TO MAKE
IT EASIER FOR MOBILE VENDORS TO
GET LICENSED. BUT WHERE I
RESPECTFULLY DISAGREE WITH THE
OPPOSITION IS IN THEIR ASSERTION
THAT NOTE CHANGES THERE'S LITTLE
NO. ROOM FOR CHANGE WE MADE A
CIVIL PENALTY FRAMEWORK IN THE
GOVERNMENT CODE TO BOLSTER
SINCERE EFFORTS BY CODE
ENFORCEMENT. TO ENSURE THE
VENDING IS OCCURRING IN A SAFE
MANNER. I BELIEVE THAT WE CAN
MAKE VERY MODEST CHANGES SUCH AS
BEEN PROPOSED BY THE- COMMITTEE-
TO THE FRAMEWORK IN CONCERT WITH
CONTINUE TO BUILD A MORE
EQUITABLE FINANCIALLY ACCESSIBLE
PATH TO LEGAL MUMBO. AND STREET
VENDING. SO JOINING ME IF I IN
SUPPORT OF THE BILL TODAY ARE
CINEMA CITY COUNCIL MEMBER
FLANIGAN THING AND- RANDALL
SCOTT WHO'S EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR
OF PHYSICIANS WORK IN SAN
FRANCISCO. VERY GOOD WELL- ASK
FOR. LAN NEGATIVE NEGATIVE THE
COUNCILMEMBER CITY OF SANTA
MONICA DO TO. PLEASE SPEAK FIRST
. AND WE ARE GONNA HAVE FIFTY
FIFTEEN MINUTES TO HEAR FROM
EVERYONE SO I WANNA MAKE SURE
PEOPLE ARE AS BRIEF AS POSSIBLE
. I WILL READ BY POSSIBLY CAN.
THE MORNING HERE. MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE THANK YOU FOR HAVING
ME TODAY MY NAME IS LANA ANOTHER
THING THAT THEY HAVE FOUND MY
LIFE THANK YOU TO COME UP
SCHOOLS AND GIVE MY NUMBER HAVE
. THANK YOU ABOUT ME TO DISCLOSE
CAN. OTHERWISE AND MY SMALL.
OWNER I'M THE DAUGHTER OF
IMMIGRANTS INTO MY- LET'S START
THANK PEOPLE VERY THE PEOPLE OF
OUR- SB NINE SIX THE SECOND.
NINETEEN IN OUR CITIES HAS
WORKED OUT WITHOUT. AND LOCAL
OFTEN. INCLUDE THEIR INCOME
SHAKE THE BY. PRO FOR THE WHO
WISH SEND A LOT. ISSUE MORE THAN
A SIDEWALK VENDOR COMMITTEE HERE
THE STATEMENT ISSUE THE CITY OF
LA A CITY THAN FORTY TIMES ARE.
COULD YOU TO STRUGGLE OUR
HISTORIC PIER. VENDORS COOK WITH
THE FLAMES COMBUSTIBLE PRETTY A
FIERY HELLO. SHE FIRED BECAUSE
THE FROM. I'M PERMITTED BY HAVE
BEEN. TO MOVE AWAY FROM THE PIER
TO PARTS OF THERE ARE. ARE LOCAL
PERMITTED THEM ARE SMALL
BUSINESS ON A IF FOR THE RULES
HOWEVER THERE TO TALK OF DRUG I
JUST. GROUP OF. THE CALTRAIN AND
INTO TO. IGNORE LOCAL FIFTY RAKE
. FOR THE.
UNFORTUNATELY SHOULD AFFECT
PATIENTS REGARDLESS OF HOW MANY
OCCASIONS THEY'RE GIVEN THEY
CONTINUE TO OPERATE WITHOUT
CONCERN. IT IS CLEAR THAT THERE
WILL TO MAINTAIN ORDER THANK YOU
BUT THERE'S NOT ENOUGH OVERSIGHT
AUTHORITY THAT REGULATES LIMIT
AND MODIFICATIONS THAT WOULD.
MERIT CALCULATION OF AN
INSTRUMENT ALL OF THIS WAS OFTEN
REPETITIVE UNAUTHORIZED THE
DANGEROUS BEHAVIORS MUST
PERMITTED VENDORS. THANK YOU TO
BREAK THE RULES BUT WE ARE
LIMITED UNDERTOOK. THE RULES THE
- GIVING LOCAL. ABILITY TO
PROTECT OUR COMMITTED VENDORS IN
THE HEALTH CARE. OUR COMMUNITY
IS A CRITICAL FUNCTION OF
GOVERNMENT. THE UNFORESEEN
CONSEQUENCES OF AT NINE FORTY
SIX MADE THE MOMENT JUST. LIKE
OUR CONSTITUTION. SB TWELVE B.
IN GIVE LOCAL CHURCH. THE
ABILITY PROTECT OUR CITY OUR MY
FOR. NO THANK YOU. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. NOW WE'RE GOING TO
MOVE ON TO RUN SCOTT WHO'S THAT-
FROM TO. WHAT THANK YOU CHAIR W.
I DON'T- COMMITTEE MEMBERS AND
ALLEN- AS MY NAME IS RAY SCOTT
THE TICKET DIRECTOR FOR THE BUSH
WHARF CAN EVENTS DISTRICT- WE'RE
RESPONSIBLE FOR MANAGING
CURATING ACTIVATING THE PUBLIC
SPACE CENTER AROUND FISHERMAN'S
WHARF IN SAN FRANCISCO I NEED AN
ATTORNEY NOR MEMBER LAW
ENFORCEMENT I'M SIMPLY A STEWARD
OF OUR NEIGHBORHOOD. ON THE
NORTHERN WATERFRONT. HE
PREVIOUSLY. WE THE STATE OF
ANARCHY OUR DISTRICT ANOTHER
LOCATIONS THROUGHOUT OUR CITY.
BUT THEN LINE FISHERMAN'S WHARF
EVERYDAY SELLING FOOD AND DRINKS
SOMETIMES ALCOHOL. AND PREVENT
TOURIST ACCESS TO THE
RECREATIONAL OPPRTUNITIES ARE
HISTORIC DESIGNATION OFFERS.
CONCENTRATION OF UNCOMMITTED
COMMERCIAL ACTIVITY HAFEN
INTERFERES WITH THE ABILITY OF
THOSE GREEN RESIDENTS FROM
MOVING ABOUT. AND EXPERIENCING
MORE. YEP WOULD HAVE BEEN IN THE
EVEN SAFETY ISSUE A PROPANE
EXPLODED LAST WHICH WAS CAPTURED
ON VIDEO. THANK LETTER TO PAY
WERE SCALE IS ONLY A MATTER OF.
BEFORE SOMETHING LIKE THIS AGAIN
. BUT OUR LOCAL GOVERNMENTS BEST
A FOR TO CRACK THE PROBLEM TO A
LOCAL VENDING ORDINANCE IMAGES
OF OVERCROWDING FOOD WASTE AND
I'M SAFE FOOD PRACTICES THAT YOU
SEE IN YOUR PACKET THANK OUR
DUTIES THAT WE SEE DALY. PORTION
OF THE CHALLENGE YOU LIMIT ITS
REACHED. AND FRANKLY ON FORCE%
SENSE THAT. ADMINISTRATIVE FEES
NOT GOING TO DETER THEM
OFFENDERS SELLING THEIR WALKING
RENTAL ONE PROBABLY DOES AWAY.
LOOK NEED MORE TOOLS HELP CURB
THAT THE- GENERAL TO ALLOW LOCAL
AUTHORITIES TO IMPOSE MINUTES TO
FIND SOMEBODY SURE P. BY. THE
SAME OF THE BUILDING OR- BUT
PEOPLE TELL ME DRESSINGS PART OF
A MUCH WERE PROBLEM. WE KNOW
THERE IS A CRUCIAL. ADDRESSING
THE **** OF AND BARRIERS TO
OBTAIN. PERMITS TO VENTURE. WE
WANT TO FULLY SO. IN WHEN. THAT
IS FAIR AND RESPECTFUL. ACROSS
EVERY GOING TO IN SOCIO SO
ECONOMIC. WHILE HOLDING A
ACCOUNTABLE WHO REPEATEDLY
EXPLORE. THE AND LOCAL RENT.
THANK YOU VERY FOR YOUR TIME.
THANK YOU WE'RE GONNA MOVE ON
JUST FOR THE RECORD YES I'M
CREEK MEDINA FORMER COUNCIL FROM
SAN MONICA AND SMALL OWNER ON
THE HERE IS ALSO AVAILABLE TEST
FOR FRESH FOR WE K. LATER VERY
GOOD I APPRECIATE. WE MOVE ON TO
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT HERE IN THE
ROOM PLEASE COME FORWARD IF YOU
COULD. LINE UP WE CAN. MAKE SURE
WE GET TO EVERYONE YES THANK YOU
ON BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
TRACTION SOME PARTS. I AM
THRILLED CARTE. YOU ARE COASTAL
PARKS HAVEN'T WITH THE AND WE-
SENATOR ALAN HIS LEADERSHIP AND
WE'RE STRONG SUPPORT OF THE
BILL. THANK YOU VERY MUCH. AND
WE'RE GONNA MOVE ON TO THE
TELECONFERENCE LINE. BECAUSE
THERE'S NO ONE ELSE IN THE ROOM.
IF YOU COULD QUEUE UP. THE WITH
MRS IN SUPPORT OF S. B. TWELVE
NINETY. AND IF ANYBODY WANTS TO
SAY SOMETHING NICE ABOUT SENATOR
ISLAND THAT'S VERY. IT'S JUST.
IT'S ON THE BILL TODAY WE ALL
LOVE HIM VERY MUCH AND-
APPRECIATE HIS. HIS- HIS GOOD
WORK. BUT I WANT TO BE ABLE TO
GET THROUGH AS MANY PEOPLE AS
POSSIBLE TODAY. MADAM CHAIR IF
YOU WOULD LIKE BEST BUY IN ORDER
FOR SB TWELVE NINETY PLEASE TAKE
THIS OPPORTUNITY IN PRESS ONE
FOLLOWED BY ZERO ONE FALL BY
ZERO FOR SB TWELVE NINETY. AND
WE WILL BEGIN WITH THE LINE
EIGHTEEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. THANK
YOU TURN MEMBERS EMILY AT THE
MONEY CALLING ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA TRAVEL ASSOCIATION
FOR THE FALL OF NINETY AND
CONTINUING THIS IMPORTANT
CONVERSATION. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. NEXT PLEASE IT'S WITH A
LINE YES THANK YOU MEDICARE ONE
FIFTY NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD. YOU
ARE OPEN ONE FIFTY NINE. ONE
FIFTY NINE WE CAN HEAR YOU
PLEASE GO AHEAD. I WILL TRY LINE
ONE FIFTEEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. ONE
YOU ARE OPEN. BY ONE FIFTY
PLEASE GO AHEAD. ALL RIGHT
LOOKED HOLLY TWENTY PLEASE GO
AHEAD TO TWENTY TO. TWO TWENTY
TWO YOU ARE ALL. OUR APPLICATION
. OKAY BY TWO FORTY PLEASE GO
AHEAD. RIGHT TO FORTY. WE HEAR
YOU LIKE YOU FORTY THREE THOUGHT
AT. RIGHT LIKE TWO OH SEVEN YOU
ARE OPEN. MY. TWO OH SEVEN.
WOULD YOU LIKE TO TESTIFY TO A
SEVEN. THANK YOU NINETEEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR
AND COMMITTEE MEMBERS MAPPED
OFF- I'M CALLING ON BEHALF OF
THE SANTA MONICA CHAMBER OF
COMMERCE REPRESENTED UNDER LOCAL
BUSINESSES AND APPROPRIATIONS
WITH THE CITY OF SANTA MONICA IN
SUPPORT OF THIS BILL THANK YOU.
THANKS VERY MUCH. THANK
SEVENTEEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. TWO
SEVENTEEN. TWO SEVENTY WOULD YOU
LIKE TO TESTIFY YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. HELLO YOU HEAR ME WE CAN
HEAR YOU. HI MY NAME IS THAT
CURRENT SANTA MONICA RESIDENTS
AND ANY OF THE MONEY TO TRAVEL
AND SPEND THEIR BECAUSE OF COLD
NEED IT THE TERM IN THE HELP
REQUIREMENTS NEEDED FOR THREE
UNDER HOW ARE. ARE YOU FEELING
ARE YOU IN SUPPORT OR IN
OPPOSITION TO THE BILL AT THE
BOARD OF PUBLIC SAFETY FOR
VENDORS AND THE PUBLIC THANK.
YOU THANK YOU SO MUCH. AND
MOVING ALONG WITH A LINE TO
TWENTY. GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM
CHAIR COMMITTEE MEMBERS JUST
TAILORED BACKWARD PRESIDENT CEO
HERE THIRTY NINE STEPS DISCO MY
SUPPORT IS B. TWELVE NINETY THAT
WILL ADDRESS THE BUSINESS
COMMUNITY'S PUBLIC SAFETY
CONCERNS. WE UNDERTAKE LICENSE
SENDING THEY CAN'T LEGISLATE
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. OF NEXT.
FIND ONE ONE RURAL. HELLO AND I
BELIEVE I CALLED IN YOU REALLY
THIS IS THE. VERY GOOD WELL
EXCEPT YOUR YEAR TEST MONEY. AND
WE WILL FOLLOW TO ONE TO THIRTY
PLEASE GO AHEAD. YES THIS IS
JAMES HARRISON MY PIER. AND I'M
CALL IN SICK OF THIS. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. ONE NINETY SIX PLEASE
GO AHEAD. ONE NINETY SIX YOU ARE
OPEN. THANK YOU CHAIR CAMBIADO
MANY MEMBERS MY NAME IS GREG
MARADA MY FAMILY OWNED A SMALL
BUSINESS ON THE SANTA MONICA
PIER FOR THE LAST FORTY FIVE
YEARS I'M A FORMER SANTA MONICA
CITY COUNCIL MEMBER. WE NEED
YOUR HELP TO PROTECT THE
SPEAKING HELP OF OUR STAFF
VISITORS IN THE ENVIRONMENT
PLEASE. SENATOR ALAN BILL SB
TWELVE NINETY THANK YOU FOR YOUR
TIME. THEY YOU VERY MUCH. R. ONE
ONE FIFTY SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD.
YOU NEVER ON RIGHT THE SIGN
BOARD PRESIDENT FISHERMEN FOR
THEIR FRANCISCO COMMUNITY
BENEFIT DISTRICT IN SUPPORT OF
OUT OF SB TWELVE NINETY ACTION
MUST BE TAKEN TO CORRECT SB NINE
FORTY SIX THANK YOU. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. ONE ONE THIRTY TWO
PLEASE GO AHEAD. ONE THIRTY TWO
YOU ARE OPEN. BY ONE THIRTY TWO
ONE MORE CHANCE LIKE TO TESTIFY
. I WILL GO TO LINE TWO FORTY
EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD. TWO FORTY
EIGHT YOUR OPEN. YES HI- CAN YOU
HEAR ME. IN HERE YOU YEP. OKAY
GREAT THANK YOU HI- GOOD
AFTERNOON MY NAME IS JANET AND
NOTHING I AM THE ORGANIZING
DIRECTOR FOR THE CENTER FOR
TWENTY ACT AND MY MOST
PRODUCTIVE AND I'M CALLING IN
TODAY TO CLOSE AT EIGHT TWELVE
NINETEEN- THE FACT THAT VERY
GOOD THANK YOU FOR YOUR
TESTIMONY I APPRECIATE IT. NEXT
PLEASE. THANK YOU FOR TO PLAY GO
AHEAD. HI MY NAME IS KATHY
BENNETT I'M CALLING FROM UCLA
SCHOOL OF LAW AND I OPPOSE THAT
IT TWELFTH. VERY GOOD NEXT
PLEASE. WHY ONE THIRTY TWO
PLEASE GO AHEAD. ONE THIRTY TWO.
AND WE DO HAVE SOME MORE QUEUING
UP- MEDICARE ONE MOMENT THERE
WITH I WANT TO REMIND PEOPLE
THAT WE ARE ON- SUPPORT. AND I
WE ARE COUNTING DOWN WHERE AND
SO I DON'T WANT TO BLEED INTO
THE OPPOSITION BECAUSE THEN IT
MAKES IT A LITTLE BIT MORE
COMPLICATED. ALL RIGHT LIKE TWO
FIFTY THREE PLEASE GO AHEAD. ARE
YOU IN OPPOSITION ALL NOW WE ARE
TAKING SUPPORT CALLS. THANK YOU
OKAY WELL ABOVE THAT. WE WILL GO
TO LINE ONE FORTY SIX PLEASE GO
AHEAD. ONE FORTY. SO LIKE YOU
WANT TO FORTY ONE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. BY WHAT TO TWENTY ONE YOU
ARE OPEN TWENTY ONE. YOUR FOR ME
TO TWENTY ONE. WHY TO THIRTY ONE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. I HAS A BUNCH
OF VENDORS IT HAD A CO WORKER
WHO WERE GONNA PUT SUPPORT I'M
JUST CONCERNED THAT WE'VE THIS-
IS THE- ANNA. IT'S BEEN A LONG
DAY I AM AND I UNDERSTAND. BUT
I'M SURE THERE'S NOT HAVE
PURCHASED IS GEARED UP EIGHT
OKAY VERY GOOD WELL THAT- WE
WERE ALMOST ON THE MONEY FOR-
FIFTEEN MINUTES- WE'RE GONNA
MOVE ON TO OPPOSITION WE HAVE TO
INDIVIDUALS LISTED IN OPPOSITION
IS LEAD WITNESSES- THE THEY CAN
GO AND IN WHATEVER ORDER THEY
THEY PREFER. ALREADY I KNOW
SANTIAGO WHO IS FROM COMMUNITY
POWER COLLECTIVE AND CHRISTOPHER
SONGES FROM THE WESTERN SYDNEY
CENTER ON LAW AND POVERTY. THE
NOTICED A LETTER SUNDAY I WILL
ONE OF THE S. EVEN THOUGH I'M
NOT MOMENT TO DOUBLE FROM WHAT
ARE YOU GONNA IN TURN. I'M GOING
TO TRY THAT WOULD BE TERRIFIC
AFTER WORK- AFTERWARDS OKAY-
BIMINI THE SENIORS. I WE WENT
OVER MULLIN TO BASED ON FOR.
MEDIA HAVE BEEN. NEWSROOM IN THE
THAT IRAQ OKEY. THIS BY THIS
WEEK. VENULES WHETHER FACT THAT
. HIS FELLOW IS IN MAY LOST IN
THE WINTER. COMO THE LOTUS
ARAMBULA THIS KNOW THAT MOTION
PC IN THAT BUT I OF MOST OF THE
GOSPEL. MUCHO MENOS BUT I GOT
MORE TIME. A SAFETY BUT I WHOLE
BONTA ALMOST AS SOON. THEY LET
THEM ON THAT. HELLO NIKA BOOKS
FILM THAT THE WAS BUT I SAY YOU
ON THE LINE THE SAID I WILL BE A
THERE. WILL LOSS YOU'LL BE THIS
FAMILY. FOR MORE THE ON THE. I
WANT TO KNOW EXISTENCE LOOKS
DELIVERY I'LL- DILLINGHAM YOU
SEVEN IT WAS. BEND CALL ME THAT
. FATAL MORE DOES. THE LOS IN
BOTH AFTER MEDIAN DOLLARS IN TO
PASS A FROM HANDLE. THIS POST IS
NOT IS CORRECT. CAN BE THE MOST
LEVELS. DATE ROSE COSTUMES
BECAUSE THIS WAY.
I THINK THIS CAN VOTE SOME WAY
THAN DATA MOVED US. FOR KNOCKED
IN THEIR OWN BETTER RESULTS. FOR
EXAMPLE IN A APPROVAL. ZERO NO
MORE THEM CLOSER I DON'T KNOW
SOMEBODY A BOTTLE OF LAUNCHING.
ME CAPITAL NOT ME SO CAL POLY
SELES YOU THAT. DESERVE THOSE
LEGALLY IF YOU LIVE IN SORREL
ALMOST SIMILAR. POSTED PELLETS
DC WAS TOTAL SOME AND MEANS FOR
A TEAM MOOD DRIVEN ANALYTICS NOR
BAGAN. IT SAYS ONE OF THE YOUR-
THE YOU. THE NEW BY WILLIS FROM
THAN I BELIEVE THAT I AM YOU
COULD IS THE ONE. ARE YOU TO
MONDAY THE YOU HAVE A NATIONAL
JUNE WILL TAKE OVER AN HOUR.
DIDN'T POSE THAT THEY THOUGHT
ABOUT HOW TO BONUS YOU. BUT I
CARE YEAH WE I'M AT HOME. LATE
LAST AND THEM AND ALSO IS SEEN.
IF YOU SEE ON THIS. FINANCING
WITHOUT BUT IT DOES SAY WILL BE
THAT. YOU KNOW I THIS YOU THAT
IN MY MOVED. OUR COURSES THE
BILL WHAT IS. MEDIUM OF THIS
COMMITTEE BEAGLE DEPRIVED TOTAL
OF MUSIC EVAN LOW. HELLO THIS
THE LEVEL.
SACRAMENTO VALLEY MY FAMILY
DEPENDS ON MY HOMEBOY HONEST
WORK AND I'M HERE TO EXPAND THE
GREAT DAMAGE THE SB TWELVE
NINETY WILL COST US A STREET
VENDORS WE DON'T EARN ENOUGH TO
COVER OUR EXPENSES MUCH LESS PAY
A FINE. WE DO THIS WORK BECAUSE
WE ARE THE ONLY PEOPLE AND IS
THE ONLY OPTION WE HAVE TO MOVE
FORWARD OF PERHAPS ONE THEY HAVE
A VERY STABLE BUSINESS AS THE
LAW DICTATES. NOW THERE'S NO
REAL OPTION TO THE ALIVE MY BET
SINCE ALL FOOD BUT THE FIND
CONTINUE FIND OF TWO THOUSAND TO
ONE HUNDRED START TWO HUNDRED TO
ONE THOUSAND WILL MAKE IT
IMPOSSIBLE TO CONTINUE WORKING.
FOR YOU DOES NOT MAKE THE WE AT
A REDUCTION OF THE COST OF THE
TICKETS UP TO FOUR TICKETS BUT
IT VERY EASILY TO RECEIVE
TICKETS IN A WEEK. I MYSELF HAVE
RECEIVED SEVERAL TICKETS IN ONE
DAY COMPORTMENT OFFICES CAN IS
WHAT THE PETITION FOR NOT HAVING
A PERMIT FOR EXAMPLE IN THE
AFTERNOON I CAN RECEIVE A TICKET
FOR USING AN UMBRELLA AT NIGHT
BECAUSE THE FOOD COURT IS NOT
AUTHORIZED BY THE- DEPARTMENT.
IS TWENTY NINETEEN WE'VE ONLY
KNOWN TICKETS YOU MAY SAY WELL%
IT'S ONLY A MINISTER OF TICKETS
MANY VENDORS DON'T EVEN PAY THEM
THIS IS A STATEMENT YOU DON'T
DESPISE MY CREDIT WILL BE
RUINED. IN THE SAME SITUATION.
THE WAY TO ART TO ARRIVE AT A
SOLUTION U. S. CENTER THE PAST
TO WORK. THE IS A BETTER
RELATIONSHIP WITH. VENDORS AND-
ENOUGH. TO INTEREST. AND SAFE.
THERE'S ONLY FROM. FIND
HARASSED. AND WHAT POVERTY.
MEMBERS OF THIS. I YOU WILL BE.
OF MY FELLOW VENDORS IN WORKERS
IN THE STATE. TO VOTE NO. SB
NINETY. JUST ALSO CLARA. THERE'S
A LOT OF. CON RIGHT NOW THERE
MODELING. AND THAT THEY'RE
HAVING DIFFICULTY CALLING IT.
BUT IT'S ONLY IN ENGLISH. WHEN
THEY'RE BEING TOLD TO- MAKE A
PUBLIC COMMENT. THANK YOU.
THANKS VERY MUCH. NEXT WITH
WITNESS. GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM
CHAIR MEMBERS PRESS RESPONSES
POLICY ADVOCATE WITH THE LESSONS
AND ALONG PARTY. RESPECTFULLY IN
OPPOSITION TO SB TWELVE NINETY.
WE WANT TO THANK THE COMMITTEE
STAFF AND THE MANAGER FOR
MEETING WITH- COMMITTEE
ORGANIZATIONS ARE DIRECTLY
REPRESENTS STREET VENDORS. AND
HEARING THE SERIOUS CONCERNS
THAT THEY HAVE WITH THE BILL-
TODAY'S THE BILL IMPRINT DOES
ONE THING. THIS IS THE ONLY
COUNTRY. MANY OF THEM AREN'T.
IMMIGRANTS OR WOMEN FURTHER INTO
POVERTY THE CYCLE OF DEBT. SB
TWELVE NINETY EAST ABOUT POLICY
PRESIDENT'S AS THERE'S NO OTHER
STATURE WHICH REMOVES THE
ABILITY TO PAY. AT ANYTIME EVEN
AFTER SOMEONE RECEIVE SEVERAL
FINES FOR THE SAME VIOLATION. IN
GENERAL WESTERN CENTER FINDS IT
THAT MANY COMMUNITY MEMBERS WE
REPRESENT HAVE A HARD TIME
PROVING. THE QUALIFY FOR REDUCED
FINE THROUGH ABILITY TO PAY
PROVISION. IN THE CASE OF STREET
VENDORS WE WILL EVER BE EVEN
MORE DIFFICULT GIVEN THAT. THAT
THEY'RE ABLE TO EASILY CHAU
VERIFIED INCOME- WE DO WANT TO
HIGHLIGHT SOME OF THE VOICES
FROM COMMITTEE MEMBERS. AS OUR
COMMUNITY PARTNERS. COLLECTIVE
HAD TO THE BRIEF SURVEY WITH
TWENTY OTHER MEMBERS- AND THEY
STATED. PROTECTION SHELTON FOR
VENDORS THAT THEY- HAVE THE
ABILITY TO REDUCE THE FINE WHICH
IS CURRENTLY REQUIRED BY LAW. IF
THEY'RE IN POVERTY. IN SOME
CASES VENDORS RECEIVE CITATIONS
IN THE MAIL AND HAD NO IDEA THAT
INSIDE IT. ANOTHER INSTANCES
VENDORS PAY THEIR FINES AND MANY
OF THEM. HAVE PAID OVER A
THOUSAND DOLLARS IN FINES. WHAT
STILL GOING TO BE TAKEN AWAY
THAT'S THE REAL NARRATIVE. THE
VENDORS HAVE MET. AT THE- THE
VENDORS THAT WE WITH A REAL
CONCERNS ABOUT THE FIVE THIRTY
GIVEN. ONE IT. PRESS UP FOR THE
- OUR BECAUSE FOR OF ALL REASONS
BEING THE- IF THEY WANT TO
ADDRESS THEM CONCERNS THE
FUTURE. THEY CAN HAVE
SIGNIFICANT FINDS SIGNIFICAN
CITATION. FROM CITY GOVERNMENTS
HAVE PLACED HIM OUT OF DEBT.
OWED TO GOVERNMENT IF THEY WANT
TO ADJUST THEIR STATUS. IF THEY
HAVE SIGNIFICANT CITATIONS TO BE
INTERPRETED. THAT THEY DON'T
HAVE GOOD MORAL CHARACTER. A
JUST. THIS LASTLY IN RECENT
YEARS I JUST AS MAY. SIGNIFICANT
TO. HIGH FINE. THAT TARGET LOW
INCOME. AND STRENGTH PROTECT FOR
IMMIGRANT. AND THIS BILL TAKES
UP BACK FROM OF THE WORK. IS THE
THREE WHY WE YOU TO STAND WITH
LOW INCOME STREAM RENDERS. AND
TO. TO VOTE NOW THANK YOU. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. IS THERE ANYONE
ELSE IN THE ROOM THAT WOULD LIKE
TO TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION TO SB
TWELVE. NINETY. READ A MEDINA
AND DEPUTY DIRECTOR OF STATE
POLICY AND ADVOCACY AT THE
COALITION FOR HUMANE IMMIGRANT
RIGHTS CHIRLA IN STRONG
OPPOSITION. H. MARIN PMB AFFLECK
OPEN AT THE ON CAMPUS YOU KNOW
THE CALIFORNIA IN OPPOSITION.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. WE SEEM NO
FURTHER OPPOSITION IN THE ROOM
WOULD LIKE TO MOVE ON TO THE
TELECONFERENCE LINE I HAVE A FEW
MINUTES LEFT SO IF YOU'D LIKE TO
TEST FOR IN OPPOSITION NOW IS
YOUR OPPORTUNITY. WELL I'D ONE
SIXTY NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI
LOVE THAT AND BOTH ARE WITHIN
ONE POLICEMAN FOR IMMIGRANT DOT
NET AND WE OPPOSE- AT THE FOOT
OF NINETY. THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
WELL I WANTED PLEASE GO AHEAD.
YOUR LINE IS OPEN ONE TICKET.
ALL I WANT ALL THREE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. BUT THE FACT YOU KNOW
BELIEVE IT. THE NUMBER OF THE
THING THAT YOU AGAIN THE FIRST
THAT IF IT IS OPEN UP A- DID NOT
ALMOST THERE THAT'S WHAT IT IS I
DON'T. WHICH INVESTS YES. NEXT
PLEASE. LIVE TO TWENTY PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HELLO FOR YOUR PLEASE GO
AHEAD. THANK MY NAME IS MERRY I
BEEN BANISHED OF. TWENTY FIVE WE
ARE NOT FINAL AND THEN IN EVERY
PART BY NOW SB I'M THRILLED
THERE ARE. THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
ALLIED ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD. BUT
MEANWHILE MAY FUNDING THAT THE
AMOUNT IS YEAH THANK YOU THE END
OF IS GOING THEY LACK IT IS
SEVEN. THEY'RE NOT MEANT. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH WHICH IS THE YES
YES YES YES. WHY TO SEVEN. I ME
A WEEK HEAR YOU YEAH. OKAY
PERFECT I- AFTERNOON NAME IS
JONATHAN NOT VERY I AM- I'M FROM
THE CENTER FOR FREE AFTER MY
MENTAL IT'S EIGHT. AND I'M
CALLING IN SO FORTH AT TWELVE
NINETY THANK YOU FOR. THANK YOU
NEXT PLACE. WHY THE ELEVENTH.
PLEASE GO AHEAD. THE NUMBER OF
THE FAILING OR EVEN ARTICLE
EXPLAINED TO HAVE A LOT IN
FAVORITE OR LEVINE AND THAT'LL I
YOU KNOW MY OPINION SAYS MEET
THE- I DON'T WHAT. IT DOES YES
IT WHICH IS A GOOD IDEA CONNECT
PLEASE. WHY TO. THREE PLEASE
AHEAD SIR THREE. HI UP BEING
USED AS THIRD I AM WITH THE IN
THE COALITION FOR IMMIGRANT IN
LIMA FOR AT BECAUSE NINETY THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. LARA TWO SIX
PLEASE GO AHEAD SINCE ZERO. IT
HI I'M NOT I'M NOT THAT OLD FROM
FROM YOUR IF I WOULD FORCEFUL
FEE ONE NINE ZERO THANK YOU
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. WHO ARE YOU
TO SAY PLEASE GOING. WHAT I WANT
ONE OF IN OF. ONE MORE LAY.
PLEASE WAIT LOS LOS INTO
TRANSACTION NUMBER. YES YES
ALIGNED WITH LINE FORTY THREE
GOING. THE NUMBER OF FEES THE
END OF THE WITH OTHER ME IN THE
- THIS IN CONCORD AND I AM.
SEVEN ONE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
BLIND ONE FORTY FOUR PLEASE GO
AHEAD. THERE ARE ANOTHER. AN IT
NEARLY THIRTY MINUTES ABOUT THAT
I'M IN A BLACK DAY YET YET BUT
THAT THEY LAY IN THE VAN BED
OKAY I WENT BACK NO MY FAMILY.
THIRTY ON GRASS YES. WHY TO SEE
TWENTY NINE. YOUR LIFE IS OPEN
TWENTY. HELLO MY NAME IS RON
JOHNSON CAL COMMUNITY BUILDERS
AND WE OPPOSE TWELVE NINETY.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. WHY. TWO
TWENTY SIX. HELLO AGAIN THANK
YOU FOR YOUR LARA I AM FROM
EUROPE BY LIFE AND- BECAUSE-
FALSELY THANK YOU VERY MUCH. WHY
TWO FIFTY EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD
. HI MY OF THE ALOHA CARE
SOMETHING MONDAY CALLING NOTHING
CHEN. RIGHT AT THE TOP NINETY
THANK YOU. WHY TWO SIX ONE. I
ESPECIALLY CURRENTLY MEETING
MEMBER OF THE L. THREE REDDING
CAMP AND WE ARE STRONG ENOUGH TO
SB TWELVE NINETY. EXTREMO WHY.
SEVENTY EIGHT. SEVENTY EIGHT
PLEASE GO AHEAD. WHY HI. HI THIS
IS QUALITY YOU KNOW SO I'M HERE
ON BEHALF OF PUBLIC AND
INVOLUNTARY WITH THOUSAND
VENDORS WHO OPPOSE AT THE TWELVE
NINETY THANK YOU VERY MUCH. WHY
TWO FORTY THREE PLEASE GO AHEAD
. HI MY NAME IS READY YET NO
THEY PREDICT THEY COULD RECORD
INCLUDES THE BACK. THE TICKET
LOS ANGELES A STRONG OPPOSITION
PRESS TWO AT TWELVE NINETY. THE
YOU. LIKE. TO FIFTY FOUR. RENDON
PAD IN STRONG OPPOSITION TO THE
SP TWELVE NINETY. THANK YOU.
BLIND ONE OH NINE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. ONE OH NINE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. YOU HEAR ME WE CAN HEAR
YOU. HI MY NAME IS MILAN THE NEW
YORK BEHALF BEFORE ON ECONOMIC
OPPORTUNITY CENTER CALLING OUT
DID KNOW SB NINETY THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. LINE TO TWENTY FIVE.
HI GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS
BRANDON STRONG OPPOSITION OF
BASKETBALL NINETY. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH ALIVE ONE NINETY
EIGHT. ONE NINE EIGHT. HI BUT
THERE'S ONE ON THERE AND THAT'S
A ALTHOUGH THAT ALONG ASSEMBLY
MEMBER. IF I IN OPPOSITION THE
LADDER THERE ARE REPORTS THAT A
LATE IT'S SEVEN TEN NOVEMBER NO
MY COMMUNITY SAID THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. WHY WHY FORTY SEVEN PLEASE
GO. WHY ONE FORTY SEVEN YOUR
LIFE IS A- HELLO. YOUR HONOR. I
KNOW WHAT. TO PLEASE GO. HELLO
HE DOES IT THE DIFFICULT JOB
MOST SEE IT THIS SUMMER THIS
COULD HANDLE. OKAY MINIMAL
EFFECT. IF I AM BETTER LAY IN
BED DOCTRINAL INTO MOVING AN SS
. NEXT PLEASE LINE TO LINE THE
WAY SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD. WHAT WE
HAVE A NUMBER OF ONE SIDED BUT I
EIGHT MILLION IT MONTHS BAN
REYES AND I THOUGHT YOU PLAYED
CONTROL I LAID IT SEVEN THAT
MOMENT FOUND AMONG IN THE LAST.
OF SILENCE IN MOST OTHER PUT THE
THAT THE SEVERAL HOW THE ENTIRE
I THOSE BUT- MUST SO AND KATO IS
LOOKING BY NOW THEY SAY. WHY
WAIT NINE PLEASE.
IT HI MY NAME IS ALYSSA QUAL AND
I'M CALLING IN OPPOSITION OF
FIFTY TWELVE NINETY THANK YOU.
THERE ARE NO FURTHER QUESTIONS
IN QUEUE MADAM CHAIR PLEASE
CONTINUE VERY GOOD- WE WERE ABLE
TO DO THAT AND SO I REALLY
APPRECIATE EVERYBODY'S
COOPERATION ANY COURT WHEN TO
BRING IT BACK TO THE- COMMITTEE
CENTER HERTZBERG. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH AND THANKS FOR ALL WHO
TESTIFIED ON. YOU KNOW I HAD TO
TWENTY A COUPLE OF ISSUES AND
CONCERNS I HAVE AND A COUPLE
ISSUE THOUGHT SOMEONE TO SHARE.
WITH THE PUBLIC AND WITH THE
AUTHOR- YOU I'D COMMITTED TO THE
CHAIR IF YOU TOOK THE AMENDMENTS
AND I'M SAYING YOU YOU ARE
TAKING AMENDMENTS GESTURE
PROPOSED COMMITTEE PROPOSED.
THAT WOULD VOTE FOR TODAY AND IT
SAID THE SAME THING TO YOU AND
MY WORD MATTERS. I AM IT YOU
KNOW BUT THAT DOESN'T MEAN I'M
GOING TO DO IT ON THE FORMIDABLE
IN THE FLOOR AND HERE'S THE
REASON AND I A AND IT'S MY FAULT
TO SOME EXTENT BECAUSE I DIDN'T
HAVE A CHANCE TO MEET WITH THE
OPPOSITION. I THINK IT WAS SEVEN
SEVEN BILLS THAT I DID WITH THE
WESTERN CENTER OF THE LAST
NUMBER OF YEARS IN WITH FEES AND
FINES IN THE UNINTENDED
CONSEQUENCES OF FEES AND FINES
AS A TOOL. NECESSARY TO ENFORCE
THE LAW AND HOW THESE FEES AND
FINES PRECLUDE TESTIMONY CREATES
SOME CHALLENGES- WANT TO TAKE
SOME TIME WITH THEM IF IT'S OKAY
TO THE COMMITTEE IT AFTER THIS
SUSPENSION TIMES COMMITTED THAT
I WOULD DO BECAUSE I HAVEN'T
DONE THAT. AND IT'S KIND OF A
FAUCET. BECAUSE WHEN PEOPLE ARE
. IN THE TURNS. THE BAR. AND IT
THEY WERE GETTING FROM THE- WE
ARE TO TALK. THAT AND SO WHEN I
LOOK AT WHOSE IMPACT WITH THAT
LOOKS LIKE A BLUE BOOK FOR
TODAY. I PROMISED MADE IT.
REALLY MATTERS USUAL WORD. AND A
AND THE DAY I JUST WANT TO SHARE
THE NUMBER OF FOLKS WHO THE
OPPOSITION DID COME BY MY OFFICE
AND TO TALK TO MY STAFF AND I
HAD THE CHANCE TO BE BRIEF. SO I
CERTAINLY TALK TO THE SIDE TALK
TO YOU IN A CERTAINLY TALK TO
THE CHAIR IN THAT REGARD SO I.
WANT TO SUPPORT TODAY BECAUSE MY
WORDS WORDS. BUT I WANT TO DRILL
INTO IT IF I COULD SPEAK TAKE A
LITTLE OF YOUR TIME- SENATORS.
AND ALSO I'D LIKE TO- YOU TO
FURTHER DISCUSS IT NOT NOW BUT
JUST. THE ID YOU MENTIONED IN
YOUR OPENING. ABOUT DOUBLE
JOINING THIS WITH CENTER
GONZALEZ IS SEVEN NINETY TWO. IN
TERMS OF THE PAST TOGETHER AS A
TEAM. RIGHT OR OR EVEN SINGLE
JOINT WHERE WHERE THOSE ARE
WHERE HER BILL WOULD BE
CONTINGENT ON THE PASSAGE OF OUR
OKAY SINGLE SHOW THAT WERE.
INITIALLY A WORKING TOGETHER I
DON'T ADDRESS THAT IS A
POSSIBILITY OF A SOLUTION TO
LET'S ALL CIRCLE BACK WITH YOU
GUYS OKAY. IT'S GOING TO MAKE
THAT CLEAR IT'S MY FAULT FOR.
NOTHING REALLY I PROCEED TO
COMMONSENSE CENTER AND I'VE BEEN
VERY SUPPORT OF ALL YOUR WORK
WITH WESTERN CENTER OTHERS. ON
IT. BINDS AND- YOU KNOW THIS IS.
THAT WE'RE STRUGGLING TO FIND A
PATH HERE THAT WILL ALLOW FOR
SOME SORT OF- YEAH
ACCOUNTABILITY ASSOCIATE WITH
THE PROBLEMS. RIGHT I'M YOU KNOW
THERE THE IMPOUNDMENT WAS NOT A
GOOD WENDY OF CERTAINLY NOT.
GONNA QUIT. AT WHAT YOU HAD.
FOLKS I DON'T THINK THEY'VE-
THAT THERE'S. I WAS WITH. IT
WITHOUT SOME OF. WANTED TO ALSO
. IF YOU IF YOU CAN HELP US TALK
ABOUT. I CAN HELP YOU OUT. YOU
EMAIL WILL BE SENT TO IT YEAH. I
FOR. A LITTLE. YEAH AND- SOME
TIME. GUYS CHIRLA I'M NOT. DOT
ABOUT. DETAILS OF THIS. I SURE
TRYING TO SOLVE. CENTER EYES OF
. YOU THANK YOU THANK YOU
SENATOR- ALLEN AND I APPRECIATE
THE COMMENTS SENATOR HERTZBERG-
I HOPE THE IT THE IS. A LIVE IN
LOS WITH THEIR MEN MANY. OF THE
CITY THE COUNTY WHERE WE HAVE.
WILL DE OR NOT THE- AREAS FOR
STREETS. BUT IT'S THEIR ONLY. OF
YEAH THIS ISN'T YOU KNOW. YOU
KNOW CREAM ON THE TOP HERE THIS
IS THEIR ONLY WAY TO SURVIVE.
AND THEY MANY OF THEM AS YOU
KNOW CENTER ALAN MANY OF THEM
ARE IMMIGRANTS WHO ARE NOT NOT
ELIGIBLE WE HAVE LAWS THAT WE
HAVE PASSED HERE IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA THAT MAKES THEM
INELIGIBLE FOR MOST OF. THE
SAFETY NET THAT OTHERS HAVE AND
AT THIS PARTICULAR TIME
ESPECIALLY IN THE PANDEMIC SO.
SO THAT'S THE REALITY THAT YOU
AND I AND EVERYBODY ARE FACING-
I DO KNOW THOUGH THAT THIS IS
THE WRONG DIRECTION IN MY
OPINION BECAUSE I YOU KNOW JUST
THIS MORNING. WE'RE TALKING
ABOUT THERE WERE THREE OR FOUR
BILLS ON THE CANNABIS INDUSTRY.
THE CANNABIS INDUSTRY THAT
SHOULD BE MUCH EASIER TO DEAL
WITH- IS NOT SUCCEEDING BECAUSE
OF ALL KINDS OF PROBLEMS. THAT
THE SOLUTION THAT THEY ARE BEING
PROPOSED ARE NOT COULD FIND
THOSE LISTED BUSINESSES IT'S TO
GIVE A BIGGER TAX BREAKS IT'S TO
CUT DOWN ON THE TAXES IT'S IT IS
NOT LET'S PENALIZE THEM BECAUSE
IT DOESN'T WORK. OTHER ISSUES
THAT HAVE COME BEFORE MY BUDGET
SUB COMMITTEE ARE.
ADMINISTRATIVE FEES CRIMINAL
FEES COURT FEES WERE ELIMINATING
THEM BECAUSE PEOPLE ARE TOO POOR
THEY'RE NOT PAYING THE BECAUSE I
DON'T WANT TO THEY JUST CAN'T.
SO I JUST ASK YOU TO USE THAT AS
THE STARTING POINT I KNOW YOU
CARE ABOUT THE IMMIGRANT
COMMUNITY I KNOW YOU CARE ABOUT
OUR POOR COMMUNITIES. THIS IS
NOT THE WAY TO GO AND SO WE HAVE
GOT TO DIG IN AND FURTHER AND
FURTHER AND FURTHER TO GET THE
RIGHT SOLUTIONS OF. THE- SERVES
SOLACE AS BE NICE SEVENTY TWO ON
A CO AUTHOR IT'S A LATINO CAUCUS
PRIORITY I DON'T KNOW FROM HER
POINT OF VIEW EXACTLY WHERE-
YOUR YOUR BILL WOULD END UP BUT
IT'S CERTAINLY. DIGGING IN. NOT
COMING UP WITH SOMETHING IS
GONNA FURTHER PENALIZED FURTHER-
IMPOVERISHED PEOPLE YOU'RE NOT
GOING TO PICK UP YOU'RE GOING TO
GET THE FINES ANYWAY SO IT DOES
NOT GET TO WORK THE SOLUTION
THAT PEOPLE ARE LOOKING FOR SO.
I CAN'T SUPPORT SOMETHING THAT'S
GOOD FURTHER IMPOVERISH PEOPLE
WHO ARE ONLY LOOKING TO MAKE A
LIST. AND WE HAVE TO FIND A MORE
OF A DIFFERENT ANSWER TO THIS-
AND YOU COULD SEE THIS IS THIS
IS NOT SOMETHING THAT THE
IMMIGRANT COMMUNITY. FOR THE FOR
THE MOST PART I KNOW THAT THEY
WERE ALL CALLERS AND I
UNDERSTAND THAT THERE WERE
OTHERS WHO TRIED TO COME IN. AND
IT DOES CREATE THIS- OF THIS
PROBLEM. BUT THIS IS NOT THE
RIGHT DIRECT AND HAVE GOT TO
FIND SOMETHING THAT IS MORE
SPECIFIC. THAT'S WHAT CENTER
GONZALEZ BILL IS IT'S A VERY
SPECIFIC BILL THAT'S NOT LOOKING
TO PENALIZE MORE BUT IS LOOKING
TO FIX THE ISSUES- SO THAT'S
WHAT I WOULD URGE YOU URGE YOU
TO DO. WHAT IF I MAY VENTURE I
MEAN IT. YEAH SENATOR IF I CAN
WE GET THROUGH ALL THE COMMENTS
AND THEN ALLOW YOU THE TIME TO
CLOSE- I'M TRYING TO IT WE NEED
TO FINISH IN THIS ROOM AND I'M-
AGAINST ALL ODDS TRYING TO GET
THIS FINISHED UP. SENATOR WIENER
WANTED TO SPEAK INSERTED
SENATORS OKAY. HI FEDERAL AND I
WOULD NORMALLY PASS BUT THIS FOR
THIS A KNOWN THIS IS IMPORTANT
AND I AND I AGREE I'M FROM A
LINE OF A LOT OF WITH CENTER
HEARD WAS SAYING AND I AGREE
WITH A LOT OF WHAT CENTER TO
ROSS SO- WAS SAYING- THAT I
SUPPORTED WHOLEHEARTEDLY OF-
PART OF LARA'S BUILD I'M FORTY
SIX AND I SUPPORTED- CENTER
SALAS- NOT CONTINUE TO DO SO-
AND I THINK- BUT- MUCH AS I.
HAVE SOME OF SUPPORTING TO
SUPPORT THOSE THOSE EFFORTS I
THINK THAT THERE IS AN ISSUE
THAT SOME CITIES ARE TRYING TO
ADDRESS AND ARE TELLING US THAT
THEY DON'T. TO PASS- AND I THINK
IT'S AND FOR US TO SAY. NO AND I
THINK I'M GONNA MOVING THIS OUT
OF. TO A BE ON A- THERE THE FIND
THE BILL MAKES YOUNG. AND YOU
AND I HAVE SPOKEN ABOUT THIS
BECAUSE I'VE ALSO BEEN VERY
ALIGNED WITH THE WORKERS CENTER
HERTZBERG AND OTHERS. TO TRY TO
GET RID OF A LOT OF THE FINES.
ON THE IT DOES MAKE ME FEEL
UNCOMFORTABLE AND I'M HOPING
THAT THERE CAN BE A DIFFERENT
APPROACH AND I KNOW YOU'VE BEEN
VERY CLEAR. THAT YOU ARE OPEN TO
DIFFERENT APPROACHES AND I'VE
SPOKEN TO SOME OF THE-
OPPONENTS. OF THE BILL WITH MY
NORMALLY MALIGNED AND WORK
CLOSELY AND I HAVE A LOT OF
RESPECT. THAT IT THAT. THAT IF
PEOPLE WANT TO SAY NO THEY'RE
ENTITLED TO THAT BUT JUST
ENCOURAGING PEOPLE TO SEE IF
THERE ARE OTHER- OTHER OPTIONS
ARE NOT PREPARED TO TRY TO. KILL
THIS BILL IN ITS FIRST POLICY
COMMITTEE BECAUSE I THINK YOU
ARE TRYING TO RESPOND. TO A REAL
ISSUE AND YOU'RE TAKING A GOOD
FIT STOP EVEN THOUGH I'LL BE
HONEST THIS PARTICULAR POST NO
DOES. MAKE ME UNCOMFORTABLE AND
I IT'S NOT SOMETHING I WOULD
NORMALLY SUPPORT BUT I DON'T
WANT TO GIVE YOU THE
OPPORTUNITY. TO CONTINUE IN THAT
GOOD FAITH EFFORTS ALTHOUGH I
KNOW THAT YOU'RE GOING TO ENGAGE
WITH THE OPPONENTS. WITH WITH
COMMUNITIES DURING. IN THE
CITIES. OF THE CITIES BUT SOME
OF THE GROUPS WHO ARE SUPPORTING
THE BILL AND- COMMENTS TO TRY
TO. INDUCE MORE CONVERSATION
ABOUT THIS- BUT I WILL- MOVE
THIS OUT OF COMMITTEE TODAY AND
I DO APPRECIATE. OUR WORK. SO I
MIGHT. I'M JUST GONNA DIE- WITH
ALL THE EVERYTHING THAT'S VINCE
BE FOR THE EXACT REASON- THE
SENATOR AND I. STRUCK OVER THIS.
BECAUSE I SUPPORTED- THE
ORIGINAL LOT OF BELL I'M 1100%
AND- IN MY COMMUNITY WE WE'VE
BEEN ABLE TO. AND THE COMMUNITY
THAT REPRESENT WOULD BEEN ABLE
TO FIGURE A WAY TO BE ABLE TO-
ALLOW VENDING AND TO PROTECT THE
BUSINESS. ENVIRONMENT AS WELL
BUT WE DON'T HAVE. MAJOR TOURIST
ATTRACTIONS. AND THE PEOPLE THAT
WE SPOKE WITH. WERE MANAGING
TRYING TO MANAGE. BIG TOURIST
ATTRACTIONS WITH- WITH AT SOME
CONDUCT IT'S PRETTY OUTRAGEOUS
FROM I'M SURE THE VENDORS THAT
WE DIDN'T HEAR FROM RIGHT-
DISPOSAL OF FOOD ISSUE DISPOSAL
OF- FUEL ISSUES- BLOCKING
SIDEWALKS INCLUDING BLOCKING
EMERGENCY ACCESS I'M JUST SOME
SOME SOME THINGS THAT ARE VERY
SERIOUS AND THAT YOU HAVE TO
TAKE SERIOUSLY SO- I CENTER I
KNOW YOU'RE GONNA WORK ON THIS
CONTINUE TO WORK ON IT- AND I
APPRECIATE THE OPPORTUNITY HAVE
THE CONVERSATIONS WITH
EVERYBODY. BECAUSE I THINK
EVERYBODY WOULD AGREE WHAT WE
WANT OUR VENDORS TO BE ABLE TO
SELL NUMBER ONE AND NUMBER TO.
BE ABLE TO DO IT IN A WAY THAT
RESPECTS RULES AND THAT'S PART
OF THE REASON THAT THERE'S
AMENDMENTS IN THIS BILL THAT
WOULD CREATE AN OPPORTUNITY FOR
THIS CITIES AND THE VENUES. TO
TO BE ABLE TO IDENTIFY WHERE IT
IS THAT YOU CAN YOU CAN BEND AND
HOW HOW YOU CAN BE YOUR SET UP
AND I THINK THE LICENSE THE
LICENSING. OR THE- ABILITY TO
GET PUBLIC HEALTH- LICENSES TO
SELL FOOD IS GOING TO BE REALLY
IMPORTANT WHICH IS THAT- I.
CENTER GONZALEZ'S BILL SOUGHT
APPRECIATE WHAT YOU'RE TRYING TO
DO HERE- I. IT'S NOT DONE YET
BUT I MINUTES I AM GOODNESS
FORTY TODAY AND I LOOK FORWARD
TO CONTINUING THE CONVERSATION
SO SENATOR YOU MAY CONCLUDE. I
ACTUALLY DID WE GET A MOTION ON
THIS. I NEED A MOTION DOT. I
NEED A MOTION- THE MOTION IS TO
PASS AS AMENDED BY FIRST AMEND
IN REVERSE REFER TO THE
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS
SENATOR YOU MAY CONCLUDE YEAH
THANK YOU THANK YOU EVERYONE FOR
THIS QUESTION THANK YOU FOR
EVERYONE WHO CALLED IN. TO
PARTICIPATE- ZERO THIS IS A THAT
THAT THE CHALLENGE WE'RE FACING
HERE AND IF YOU LOOK AT PAGE
FIVE OF THE COMMITTEE'S ANALYSIS
YOU'LL SEE THE LONG AND WINDING
ROAD THAT THIS BILL IS ENGAGED
IN. I'M SENATORS OFFICES BILL
AND IS SEEKING TO MAKE IT EASIER
TO GET PERMITS. OUT WHICH IS A
CONCEPT THAT I THROUGH THE
ETHICALLY INDOORS IN FACT
ORIGINALLY IDEA WAS THAT YES WE
SHOULD EXPAND ACCESS TO PERMITS.
AND OUT FOR THAT SMALL PORTION
THAT THAT THE THAT JUST REFUSES
TO COMPLY. ON REPEATED LOOK
BASED ON A REPEATED BASIS THERE
HAS TO BE SOME FORM OF
ACCOUNTABILITY. I'M HERE IF IT'S
NOT FIND LET'S THE OF WHAT WHAT
WHAT'S THE ALTERNATIVE WE WE'VE
TRIED A WHOLE BUNCH OF
DIFFERENT. I WE RUN UP FLAGPOLE
THE CHALLENGE WE RUN INTO QUITE
FRANKLY OVER AND OVER AGAIN IN
IN OUR IN OUR VERY RESPECTFUL
AND CORDIAL CONVERSATIONS. WITH
THE OPPOSITION WE STARTED EVEN A
YEAR AGO. R. AS BY THE END OF
THE DAY THEY JUST THE THEY'RE
JUST I THINK PHILOSOPHICALLY
OPPOSED. TO ANY TOOL. AREN'T
THAT THE CITY COULD UTILIZE THAT
WILL WILL ULTIMATELY HOLD FOLKS
ACCOUNTABLE AT THAT SMALL
PORTION OF POPULATION. THAT SIR.
YEAH SO THAT'S THE CHALLENGE I'M
RUNNING INTO HERE. AND YEAH WE
GOT THAT LIKE THE ISSUE THAT'S
BEEN DISCUSSED. OF THE THAT IT
FACES ARE VENDORS WHO ARE
ABSOLUTELY AND AT THE ARE AMONG
OUR MOST VULNERABLE. IS VERY
REAL AND THE ISSUES THAT IS
EXISTING AND THESE. ARE
DESTINATIONS IS VERY REAL AS
WELL I'M JUST TRYING TO GET THAT
ISSUE ADDRESSED IF THIS ISN'T
THE RIGHT WAY LET'S FIGURE OUT A
DIFFERENT WAY- BUT IT'S A REAL
PROBLEM THAT WE'RE TRYING TO
ADDRESS. WITH THIS BILL SO I
APPRECIATE. THE SUPPORT OF THE
COMMITTEE. RETURN TO KEEP
WORKING ON THIS. WITH EACH AND
EVERYONE OF YOU. THANK YOU
SENATOR- THE MOTION IS TO PASS
AS AMEND BUT FIRST DIMINISH RE
REFER TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL SENATORS CAMBIADO HI
CABALLERO HI NIELSEN. DURAZO
ROSEAU NO HERTZBERG HERTZBERG HI
WIENER WIENER HI THREE TWO ONE
THOSE OUT THREE TWO ONE. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. MEMBERS ARE GOING
TO SIT WITH THAT GO BACK ONCE
AGAIN THIS. OKAY WORK OKAY FOR
PS WE'RE GONNA WE'RE GONNA LOSE
SENATOR HERTZBERG WE'RE GONNA
START WE'RE GOING TO LOSE A
QUORUM PRETTY SOON. GUY SO- I'M
AN **** THAT AUTHORS TO BE AS
SUCCINCT AS POSSIBLE AND THEIR
WITNESSES AS WELL- BUT WE'RE
GONNA WE'RE GONNA OPEN THE ROLE
SO WE CAN. THE BILLS THAT. NEED
TO CENTER HERTZBERG TO VOTE. I
DON'T HAVE THAT LIST YET USED.
THE NEW YORK. WELL ACTUALLY.
FRIEDMAN SAYS WE'RE NOT GOING.
BUT ALL RIGHT WE'RE GONNA OPEN
THE ROLE ON THE FITNESS ITEM
NUMBER ONE WHICH IS S. B. EIGHT
SIX TWO PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS SENATOR WIENER. WIENER
HI FIVE ZERO BILLS OUT FIVE ZERO
MOVING ON TO FILE ITEM NUMBER
NINE SB TWELVE EIGHTY ONE BY
SENATOR BRADFORD IT'S CALLED THE
ABSENT MEMBERS SENATOR HERTZBERG
. HERTZBERG FIVE WINNER. WIENER
HI FORTY ONE FORTY ONE THAT BILL
IS OUT AS WELL. FILE ITEM NUMBER
TEN S. B. TWELVE NINETY THREE BY
SENATOR BRADFORD. SENATOR
HERTZBERG HERTZBERG. FIVE FORTY
ONE THAT BILL IS OUT FOUR TO ONE
. AND FINALLY A FILE AND MEMBER
NUMBER ELEVEN SB FOURTEEN
SEVENTY SIX BY SENATOR BRADFORD
SENATOR HERTZBERG. FIVE FIVE
ZERO FIVE ZERO THAT BILL IS OUT
. I WE DID SO WILL OPEN WILL
TAKE UP THE CONSENT AGAIN FOR
ANY ABSENT MEMBERS. SENATOR
WIENER WIENER HI. FIVE ZERO THAT
THAT THOSE BILLS ARE OUT FIVE
ZERO OKAY NOW WE'RE THAT WE'RE
WE'RE CAUGHT UP WE'RE READY FOR
SENATOR BAKER WHO HAS BEEN
WAITING HERE PATIENTLY- CENTER
STERN. WHO HASN'T BEEN HERE
WAITING PATIENTLY BUT THAT'S
OKAY WE'LL TAKE HIM UP FIRST
BECAUSE IT'S FILE ITEM NUMBER.
SEVEN TWELVE FORTY SIX. WELCOME
THANK YOU. THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR
AND NOT ALL TRY TO. STICK TO
YOUR DIRECTIVE ON BREVITY HERE
AND JUST SIMPLY SAY THAT- THIS
MEASURE IS ABOUT THE VICTIMS OF
BOTH THE WORLDS IN THOMAS FIRES
AND THAT TREATING THEIR- THEIR
SETTLEMENTS FROM- FROM POST FIRE
CLAIMS- NOT AS INCOME THERE'S A
LOT OF PEOPLE WHO HAVE BEEN HIT
TWICE IN OTHER WORDS BY THESE
FIRES THEY'VE LOST EVERYTHING
AND GONE THROUGH THEIR
LITIGATION AND SETTLEMENTS.
RECEIVED THAT SETTLEMENT OF AN
INTACT STARTED MANY PEOPLE ON
FIXED INCOME HURTING THERE'S A
PARALLEL MEASURE ALSO ON ON-
PARADISE AND THE PGT FIRES
TWENTY EIGHTEEN SO- WE'VE GOT
SOME I WANT TO LEAVE TIME
WITNESS LITERALLY HAS LIKE TWO
MINUTES LEFT I WANTED SEATS TO
MIKE- TO LET HER TELL HER STORY-
BUT HAPPY ANSWER ANY QUESTION
RESPECTFULLY ASK RIVAL VERY GOOD
SINCE YOU'RE WITH KAPPA MIGHT.
YES ABSOLUTELY- I COULD. HE'S A
SEE FIRE SERVICE AND SHE ON THE
PHONE. WELCOME HELLO YET THANK
YOU- THANK YOU TO THE COMMITTEE
FOR THIS OPPORTUNITY- AND- THE
ONGOING FINANCIAL CHALLENGES I
CAN SEND YOU GREAT WOULD BE MADE
SIGNIFICANTLY LESS. OF A PROBLEM
SHOULD HE WON TWO FOUR SIX A
LOT. OF TIMES WHEN I WANT
IMPLORE COMMITTEE IS THAT
LEAVING EVERYTHING MUCH OF WITH
I CAN NOT REPLACE THE HARDSHIP
OF REAL PROPORTIONS LET ALONE
FINDING AND SECURING. AFFORDABLE
HOUSING. SO I LOST MY FORTY OLD
UTILIZED VERY HEIRLOOMS AND
TREASURES THE TWO POLITICALLY-
REALLY IN THE MORNING ON
NOVEMBER EIGHTH EXACTLY WITH
LIKE DOG WITH ONLY THE CLOTHES I
WOULD WEARING. I HAD NO IDEA
THAT WOULD BE FOREVER I THOUGHT
IT COULD TURN HOME IN A FEW
DAYS- OR A FEW HOURS AND AS IT
TURNS OUT. EIGHT HOURS TO GET
OUT OF ALL OF THEM FIRED WARNING
IS LEAPING DOWN THE NOW. AT
LEAST WHO CRAFT ALONG PCH. THE
FINANCIAL HAS INSTRUMENT. THE MY. THANK YOU NEED INCLUDING
TRYING ASK WHERE'S MY EXCEPT I
I'M A FULL TIME YOU PROFESSOR IN
WALLACE THE WELL RESPECTED
PROFESSOR AND- INCREASE UNITS
FOR. I'M HONOR PROFESSION YOU
IT'S REGRET IT BECAUSE I LIVE A
SMALL HAS BEEN MALIBU NOW MALIBU
. TO BE ABLE KEEP AND LIVE OF.
AND THIS IS NO LONGER OF. IN IN
THE LAST ANGELES. IN FACT MY
INCREASE SIX HUNDRED DOLLAR MORE
PER. AND AS YOU KNOW IN HEALTH.
IT IT CONTINUED TO INCREASE- THE
PLAY I LIVE IN NOW IF I WERE TO
RENT IT AGAIN TO. WOULD BE FOUR
HUNDRED TO SIX HUNDRED DOLLARS
MORE PER MONTH THEREFORE I
FINANCIALLY STUFF IN MY CURRENT
APARTMENT I AM UNABLE TO SAVE
MONEY FOR. MY RETIREMENT AND I
HAVE TO COUNT EVERY LEAD YOU TO
THE FINANCIAL LOSS FROM THE WITH
THE. FIRE AND FURTHERMORE I'VE
BEEN OUT- MY AND INNER HOME. AND
I COULD NOT AFFORD HEALTH CARE
BECAUSE THEY BARELY MAKE MY THAT
. I'VE HAD TO TAKE A EXTRA. JOBS
AN ONLINE COURSE MAKE MEET. AND
YOU KNOW HE- NINE PLUS BECAUSE
EACH SEMESTER EXAM FAN AND I'M A
WORK SENDING MYSELF SO BE A
MOTIONAL HOLE OF THE FIRE AND
THE FINANCIAL REPUTATION. NEVER
LET UP EVEN. UP FOUR YEARS LATER
. HELLO I'M SURE THERE I LOT OF
THINGS LIKE RARE ANY RARE
ANYTHING LAW THE BOOK THAT I
USED. FROM ELECT IN RYE. AND I
CANNOT REPLACE THAT IS THERE NOT
A- KERN I'M CALLING THIS IS. AND
NOW I NEED FOR YOU TO WRAP UP I
HATE TO DO THIS BUT- WE'RE GOING
TO GET KICKED OUT OF THIS ROOM
RIGHT AFTER THIS OKAY SO WHAT
ONE MORE THING IF MY FELLOW.
YOUR TAX THE FULL REPEAL FIGHT
ELEMENT. INCLUDING THE LAWYER
FEES I EARNED EVERY PENNY PUT IN
MY HOME IN THE THINGS THAT
TURNED DOWN IN NOVEMBER TWENTY
EIGHTEEN I THINK CALIFORNIA
TAXPAYERS IN STATE TAX ABOUT IT.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MA'AM I
APPRECIATE IT BUT I I'M GETTING
TOLD THAT PUSHED OUT AND- I WANT
TO MAKE SURE WE HAVE AN
OPPORTUNITY TO CONCLUDE. AND
WHAT ARE DISEASE IN THE. WE'RE
GONNA MOVE ON TO. THANK YOU- I
AND WE DON'T NEED TO CHECK
WITNESS OKAY JUST VERY GOOD YEAH
SO WE'RE GONNA SEE IF ANYONE IN
THE IN THE ROOM THAT CAN TESTIFY
IN SUPPORT. SAYING NINE. WILL
MOVE ON TO THE TELECONFERENCE
LINE THOSE IN SUPPORT PLEASE.
THOSE IN FAVOR PLEASE TO PRESS
THE ONE ZERO.
EIGHTY NINE FIFTY EIGHT PLEASE
GO AHEAD. MISTER SMITH AND I'M A
RESIDENT AND I'M IN FAVOR THANK
YOU SO MUCH THANK YOU. NEXT
PLEASE THERE ARE NO FURTHER
THERE ARE NO FURTHER QUEUE AT
THIS TIME MEDICARE PLEASE
CONTINUE VERY GOOD- WILL MOVE ON
TO THE LEAD WITNESSES THERE ARE
NONE. IS THERE ANYONE IN THE
ROOM THAT WOULD LIKE TO THE
COMMITTEE ROOM. SAYING NINE WILL
MOVE TO THE TELECONFERENCE LINE. MISTER MODERATOR FREAKING Q.
ANYBODY ON THE TELECONFERENCING
. PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO AT THE
START. ONE ZERO. AND THERE ARE
NOT CUTE AT THIS TIME MADAM
CHAIR WE WANT IS JUST QUEUED UP
ONE MOMENT PLEASE. PERSONAGES
CUED UP YOUR LINE IS OPEN ONE
MOMENT. TWO NINETY OUT OF IT.
NINETY SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD AFTERNOON AFTER SEPARATING
ON BEHALF OF CONSUMER TRENDS OF
CALIFORNIANS TRANSPORT GREAT
THANK YOU. ANYONE ELSE MISTER
MODERATOR. THERE ARE NO FURTHER
LIED TO Q. THANK YOU SO MUCH SO
GOING TO BRING IT BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE THEE IS A MOTION BY A
SENATOR WIENER- NO QUESTIONS-
SENATOR STERN IF YOU'D LIKE TO
CONCLUDE YES AND JUST TWO THINGS
NOT MYCLOSED DEFINITELY SECOND
COMMITTEE MEN'S APPRECIATE THE
TECHNICAL FIX I WANT TO CLARIFY
THAT AND- WE WERE WE WERE TAKING
THIS OR SORT OF PARALLELING IS
THE OTHER- WELL MEASURE BUT VERY
OPEN TO- LOOKING AT INCOME
THRESHOLDS- SHOULD THE BILL
BEFORE SO BUT THAT RESPECTFULLY
ASK RIVAL. VERY GOOD. PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL SENATOR MOTION IS
TO PASS AS AMENDED BUT FIRST
AMEND AND RE REFER TO THE
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS.
SENATORS CAPITO HI CABALLERO HI
NIELSEN ALL RIGHT NIELSEN HI
DURAZO. DORADO HI HERTZBERG.
WIENER AYE WIENER HI FORTY ZERO
. THE MEASURE PASSES FORTY ZERO.
ALL RIGHT MEMBERS- MY APOLOGIES
TO EVERYBODY ON THE LINE INTO
AYE SENATOR BAKER WHO WAS SO
PEACEFUL AT THE- PATIENTLY
WAITING- THE ROOM IS BOOKED THIS
AFTERNOON AND SO OUR COMMITTEE
IS GOING TO BE. COMMITTEE
CONTINUED AND WE WILL BE BACK
THIS AFTERNOON AT A TIME THAT WE
HAVE TO DETERMINE. YEP SO I WISH
I COULD GIVE YOU A SPECIFIC TIME
BUT WE'RE GOING TO BE- WAITING
TO SEE HOW LONG THE ROOM IS USED
IN THEM WHETHER WE CAN GET A
CREW BACK. SO MY APOLOGIES. STAY
TUNED. WE HAVE THREE BILLS WE
HAVE THREE BILLS- SENATOR BAKER
SENATOR KAMLAGER AND SENATOR
WIENER- I RULES FOR WE'RE
GETTING KICKED OUT. IT WILL NOT
HONOR I DON'T HAVE.
S. TO RESUME WE CAN TELL IT'S
BEEN A TOUGH DAY- MY
UNDERSTANDING SENATOR STERN IS
THAT YOU'RE GOING TO BE TAKING
UP. S. B. THIRTEEN OH ONE WHICH
IS ITEM NUMBER THIRTEEN ON OUR
AGENDA FOR SENATOR BAKER SETS IT
VERY GOOD SO- THE FLOOR IS YOURS
SIR OKAY THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR.
HONOR TO PRESENT THIS BILL SB
THIRTY NO ONE WHICH WOULD CREATE
CALLOUS CALIFORNIA'S FIRST CLEAN
ENERGY MANUFACTURING TAX CREDIT
. LIKE THE FIRST OPENING THE
CHAIR THE COMMITTEE FOR THEIR%
WORK ON THE BILL EXCEPT TO
SUGGEST AMENDMENTS OUTLINED A
PAGE FOR. I WOULD JUST NOTED
WELL WELL WE'VE BEEN A LEADER IN
EFFORTS AGAINST CLIMATE CHANGE I
THINK THIS BILL WILL
SUPERCHARGER EFFORTS- IN
INVESTING ON THE TAX CREDIT SIDE
SPECIFICALLY AROUND CLEAN ENERGY
PROJECTS- SPECIFICALLY THE BILL
WOULD CREATE A TAX CREDIT EQUAL
210% OF THE COST INCURRED FOR
NEWLY INSTALLED. MANUFACTURING
EQUIPMENT USED TO PRODUCE CLEAN
ENERGY PRODUCTS. WE THINK IS
GONNA BE CRUCIAL TO ME OUR
CLIMATE GOALS- IN SPRING IN
STATE PRODUCTION. I'M SO WE
PRACTICE WHAT WE PREACH AND
DON'T JUST IMPORT THOSE
SOLUTIONS- THESE JOBS THE FUTURE
BELONG RIGHT HERE IN CALIFORNIA.
SO I'D LIKE TO THANK THE
COMMITTEE FOR HELPING- HELPING
WORK ON THE DRAFTING SO QUICKLY
ON BEHALF OF SENATOR BECKER-
ENGAGING WITH ADDITIONAL STAKE
HOLDERS- IN THE WEEKS AHEAD IS A
COMMITMENT THAT THE AUTHORS%
MAKING AND I'LL MAKE WITH HIM
I'LL BE RIGHT THERE. SO WITH ME
TODAY TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT BY
PHONE IS DAN JACOBSON WITH
ENVIRONMENT CALIFORNIA. AND
PRINCETON YOUNG WITH THE CHAMBER
WAS PLANETESIMAL FORTUNATELY
COULD NOT MAKE IT THIS AFTERNOON
SO- I THINK WE'LL JUST HAVE ONE
BIT OF THE TESTIMONY AND WITH
THAT A RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU VERY MUCH SO WE
WILL NOW TURN TO THE LEADS PER
WITH WITNESS STAND JACOBSON FROM
ENVIRONMENT CALIFORNIA. SIR THE
FLOOR IS YOURS. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE MY NAME IS DAN
JACOBSON A SENIOR ADVISER TO
ENVIRONMENT CALIFORNIA. FORTY
FIVE HAS TWENTY VERY SHORT. FORM
BECAUSE THERE'S NO OPPOSITION TO
THE BILL FOR HAPPY TO STAND WITH
SENATOR VECTOR WITH THE
CALIFORNIA CHAMBER OF COMMERCE.
ON THIS BILL THAT WILL BRING NOT
ONLY GOOD JOB BETWEEN
MANUFACTURING HERE TO THE STATE.
BUT ALL I WOULD NEED OUR CLEAN
ENERGY GOAL. FASTER AND- THE
WORK THAT NEEDS TO GET DONE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. AND
ENCOURAGE YOU KNOW VOTE. THANK
VERY MUCH. WE'RE GONNA MOVE ON
TO THOSE. MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC
IN THE IN THE COMMITTEE ROOM
THAT OULD LIKE TO TESTIFY TO
PLEASE COME FORWARD. SING NO ONE
COME FORWARD WILL MOVE ON TO OUR
TELECONFERENCE LINE. THOSE IN
SUPPORT THAT WOULD LIKE TO
TESTIFY IF YOU COULD PLEASE
QUEUE UP MISTER MODERATOR. OKAY
FOR SUPPORT PLEASE PRESS ONE
THEN. ZERO ONE ZERO. THEN WE
HAVE KNOWN IN QUEUE AT THIS TIME
. A GOOD WILL MOVE ON TO THE-
LEAD OPPOSITION WITNESSES THERE
ARE NONE LISTED SO WE'LL SEE IF
THERE'S ANYBODY IN THE COMMITTEE
ROOM THAT WOULD LIKE TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION. SEEING NONE IF WE
COULD MOVE ON TO THE
TELECONFERENCE LINE. MR OPERATOR
IF YOU COULD CHECK TO SEE IF
THERE'S ANYBODY ON THE LINE.
OKAY FOR OPPOSITION PLEASE PRESS
ONE NINE ZERO. ONE ZERO. AND WE
HAVE KNOWN IN QUEUE AT THIS TIME
VERY GOOD- WILL BRING THE BILL
BACK TO THAT COMMITTEE ANY
QUESTIONS. SEEING NO QUESTIONS-
I'M AFRAID WE LOST OUR- OUR NOT
ONLY ARE COMMITTEE MEMBERS PUT
KEEP THEM PEOPLE MEMBERS OF THE
PUBLIC THAT WERE PARTICIPATING-
SO IT'S KIND OF SAD BUT IN ANY
CASE- I WILL MAKE THE MOTION ON
THE BILL AND ALLOW YOU TO
CONCLUDE. THANKS APPRECIATE THE
MOTION- I THINK THIS IS A
CRITICAL- SUPPLEMENT- WHATEVER
THE STATE IS ALREADY CURRENTLY
DOING WHEN IT COMES TO. CLEAN
ENERGY MANUFACTURING- AND THAT
THIS WILL BE A REALLY IMPORTANT
PIECE OF OUR CLIMATE STRATEGY
GOING FORWARD FROM JOBS
PERSPECTIVE AND FROM A- FOR A
POLLUTION PERSPECTIVE SO WITH
THAT I WOULD RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR YOUR AYE VOTES. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH AND THANK YOU TO MISS
TO SENATOR BAKER HE WHAT HE DID
SPEND SOME TIME HERE TODAY WITH
US AND WE'RE SORRY HE COULDN'T
HE COULDN'T BE HERE- WE ARE ON
FILE ITEM NUMBER THIRTEEN WHICH
IS SB THIRTEEN OH ONE BY SENATOR
BAKER- THERE HAS BEEN A MOTION
SENATOR EYES IT WOULD YOU LIKE
TO MAKE THE MOTION YES. OKAY
WHAT WILL ACCEPT AN EMOTION FROM
CENTER DIRECTOR I SOMETHING IN
HERE. THANK YOU- ABOUT. PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL THE MOTION IS TO
PASS AS AMENDED THE FIRST
AMENDED AND RE REFER TO THE
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS
SENATORS CAPITO HI CAMBIADO- HI
NIELSEN NIELSEN HI TERRAZZO.
TERRAZZO HI HERTZBERG. WIENER.
THREE ZERO VERY GOOD- WE WILL
PUT THAT ON CALL AND ALLOW THE
ABSENT MEMBER TO JOIN IN- WERE
READY TO MOVE ON TO FILE ITEM
NUMBER FOURTEEN WHICH IS S. B.
THIRTEEN SEVENTY THREE BY
SENATOR COME LONGER. PERFECT
TIMING. CENTER COME UNDER THE
FLOOR IS YOURS OKAY GREAT WE
STILL BEING ASKED TO KEEP IT
SHORT. NO IT'S NOT IS AS URGENT
WE WERE TRYING TO GET THINGS
DONE BY BEFORE THE RULES
COMMITTEE NEEDED THE ROOM AND
NOW THAT THEY'VE HAD IT- I THINK
WE'RE WE'RE OKAY OKAY BUT I
WILL. THE GOOD AFTERNOON AT
CHAIR WOMAN AND MEMBERS I'M HERE
TODAY TO PRESENT SB THIRTEEN.
SEVENTY THREE. THIS IS A
DISTRICT BILL THAT GIVES AN
ADDITIONAL TWO YEARS TO
REMAINING PROPERTY OWNED BY A
FORMER. REDEVELOPMENT AGENCY TO
DEVELOP LARGE SCALE PROJECTS. IN
URBAN AND UNDER RESOURCE AREAS.
THE ADDITIONAL TIME IS REQUIRED
TO ENSURE. THAT THE PUBLICLY
OWNED PROPERTY PROVIDES PUBLIC
BENEFITS ALONG WITH THE HIGHEST
AND BEST USE FOR THE COMMUNITY
IN ORDER TO MEET THE CURRENT
LEGISLATIVE DEADLINES. FOR THE
SURPLUS LANDS ACT THE PROJECTS
OUTLINED IN SB THIRTEEN SEVENTY
THREE WOULD BE REQUIRED TO HAVE
MANY OUTSTANDING ISSUES RESOLVED
BY AUGUST FIRST TWENTY TWENTY
TWO. IN ORDER TO ENTER INTO THE
PROCESS OF REACHING FINAL
DECISION PRIOR TO DECEMBER
THIRTY ONE TWENTY TWENTY TWO.
AND SO HENCE THE URGENCY AND
REQUEST SENATE BILL THIRTEEN
SEVENTY THREE WOULD EXTEND THE
DATE BY WHICH THE DISPOSITION OF
PROPERTY OWNED BY A FORMER
REDEVELOPMENT AGENCY TO BE
COMPLETED BY DECEMBER. THIRTY
ONE TWENTY TWENTY FOUR. THE
EXTENSION WOULD ONLY APPLY TO
PROPERTIES ARE LOCATED IN A
LOCAL AGENCY WITH A POPULATION
OF OVER TWO MILLION PEOPLE IN
ADDITION THE LOCAL AGENCY HAS
EITHER AN OPTION AGREEMENT DULY
AUTHORIZED BY THE LOCAL AGENCIES
GOVERNING BODY TO PURCHASE THE
PROPERTY. FROM THE FORMER
REDEVELOPMENT AGENCY OR AN
EXCLUSIVE NEGOTIATION AGREEMENT
WITH A PRIVATE ENTITY TO DEVELOP
THE SUBJECT PROPERTY FOR
ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT OR HOUSING
PURPOSES. WITH ME IN SUPPORT
TODAY IS CAROLYN HALL THE
GENERAL MANAGER OF THE ECONOMIC
AND WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT
DEPARTMENT. AT THE LA GAP THE
CITY OF LOS ANGELES AND SCOTT
RANGERS THE PROJECT EXECUTIVE
FOR ANGELS LANDING PARTNERS AND
AT THE APPROPRIATE TIME I WOULD
RESPECTFULLY ASK. FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE. VERY GOOD WE'RE GONNA MOVE
ON TO THE- CAROLYN HALL WHO IS
ONE OF HE LEADS PER WITNESSES
FROM THE CITY OF LOS ANGELES
ECONOMIC AND WORKFORCE
DEVELOPMENT DEPARTMENT AFTER
WHICH WILL- ASCOT RENDERS TO.
TESTIFY FROM ANGELS LANDING
PARTNERS. GOOD AFTERNOON CAN
EVERYONE HEAR ME WE CAN. OKAY
I'M TELLING ALL THE DENTAL
MANAGER THE ECONOMIC WAR
QUIRK-SILVA DEPARTMENT COULD BE
POPPING UP WITH THANK YOU FOR
THE OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK WITH A
POINT AT. EIGHT THIRTEEN SEVENTY
THREE. CHALLENGES CREATE BY THE
CO NINETY PENCE. OTHER CALL
FACTORS THANK YOU TO DEVELOPING
LARGE SCALE PROJECTS. WE
APPRECIATE THE ASSISTANCE TO
EXPAND IT HI TERRY ALLOW FOR
THIS TYPE OF DEVELOPMENT. THEY
UNDERSTAND THE IF YOU KNOW WHAT
ABOUT QUITE HE ADDED AND WE HAVE
BEEN. WHERE THE HYBRID CLOUD AND
WE HAVE BEEN AND WILL CONTINUE
TO PRIORITIZE WITH PENSIONS AND
THE DEVELOPMENT OF AFFORDABLE
HOUSING. BUT WE HAVE OTHER
CHALLENGES THAT THE MARKET DROPS
I'M LOOKING TO CLICK. THANK YOU
FOR YOUR- JULY TWENTY TWENTY ONE
TALKING 70% OF THE CITY
RESIDENTS ARE LIVING BELOW THE
POVERTY LINE. AND I CAN ASSURE
YOU THAT THIS NUMBER IS MUCH
HIGHER IN UNDERSERVED
COMMUNITIES. WHAT THE HELL
CRISTINA YUBA CITY NOT CREATE
LIVING WAGE JOB FOR THE
RESIDENTS COUPLE OF THE LOS
ANGELES REGION. RECYCLABILITY
THE ABOUT ANGELES ARE COVERED BY
THE CONDITIONS AT THE THIRTEENTH
. ALL TRANSFORM TO BE DEFINITELY
COULD VISIT IN JOB CREATION
POTENTIAL. HI OF THE LACK OF
IMPACT FOR ONE OF THE PROJECT AB
ONE HUNDRED. IT LANDED AT THE
LOG DEVELOPMENT COULD BE FILLED
BY BLACK THE BALLOT FOR THE
UNITED STATES. MARKET MILESTONE
NOT ONLY FOR THE REAL ESTATE
INDUSTRY FOR THE FUTURE WHAT.
THE OUTLOOK IN THE COUNTRY AT
LARGE. OPENING TWENTY. WHAT WHAT
COMMITTEE. STUNT MEN ARE OWNED
WOMEN OWNED. OKAY ON THAT THE
PROJECT SPAN MORE THAN ONE TWO
MILLION FEET. ACROSS LABOR
AGREEMENTS IN ADDITION IT WILL
CREATE MORE THAN EIGHT THOUSAND
THREE HUNDRED. EIGHT THOUSAND
THREE HUNDRED NEW JOBS DURING
CONSTRUCTION. FIVE HUNDRED
ECONOMIST JOHN. THE COUNTY AND
THE ALL BETTER FROM INCREASED
WITH CHEN BY THE- EQUITIES.
THREE POINT EIGHT BILLION PER
YEAR THE TRANSIT OCCUPANCY TAX.
THE OTHER TWO PROJECTS ALL ALSO
PROVIDE SIGNIFICANT ECONOMIC
BENEFIT TO WHAT THE LOS ANGELES
REGION AND STATE. CLOVERDALE AT
H. WILL CALL DEMOCRATS PROBABLY
NOT OF DRAFTING THE BODY NAKIA.
THAT FOR ME TO WAS ALL
POPULATION THROUGHOUT BLACK
INDIGENOUS PEOPLE OF COLOR ABOUT
THEIR RESIDENT HAVE EQUITABLE
ACCESS TO WELL PAYING JOBS
ENTREPRENEURIAL OPPORTUNITY. TO
WORK WITH ME TO ACCOMMODATE THE
PROJECT THE JETS THAT ARE
CRITICAL FOR THE PREVIOUS
EMPLOYER THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME. MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS. THANK
YOU VERY. I'M A THE FLOORS YOURS
FOR SCOTT RANGERS. THANK YOU
UNSTRUT WRITER PATRICK
REPRESENTATIVE WILL INCLUDE
PLANTING PARTNERS THANK YOU FOR
THE OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK TODAY-
I. IT CAROLINE'S I THINK SHE
TOUCHED ON SOME VERY SIGNIFICANT
ELEMENTS OF THE PROPOSED PROJECT
I ALSO WANTED TO BE. REINFORCED
WE'VE BEEN WORKING DILIGENTLY
SINCE TWENTY SEVENTEEN TO PRETTY
MUCH PROJECT TO FRUITION AND YOU
KNOW WE'VE BEEN WORKING THROUGH
THE PANDEMIC ENVIRONMENT WE
RECEIVED A CERTIFIED
ENVIRONMENTAL IMPACT REPORT IN
FEBRUARY ALONG THE PROJECT
ENTITLEMENTS AND WE'VE BEEN
DILIGENTLY PURSUING ALL THE
DEFINITIVE AGREEMENTS WITH CITY
OF LOS ANGELES. CONSIDER A
COMPLETE THE TRANSACTION SO WE
REMAIN COMMITTED TO THE
DEVELOPMENT- YOU KNOW OBVIOUSLY
THERE'S A TIME PRESSURE. WHAT
SHE DID WITH THE KERN OPTION
PERIOD COMBINED AUGUST THE
FIRST. AND R. TWELVE THIRTY ONE.
GOT UNDER THE CURRENT
LEGISLATION SO WE APPRECIATE
YOUR SUPPORT AND CONSIDERATION
AND WHAT WE'RE DOING WITH URGENT
FIVE BUT- TO EXTEND THE
DEADLINE. FOR THE SURPLUS WINTER
. THANKS VERY MUCH WE'RE GONNA
MOVE ON TO SUPPORT IN ROOM
TWENTY TWO HUNDRED IS THERE
ANYBODY HERE WHO WOULD LIKE TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT. I'M SURE
MEMBERS MIKE WEST ON BEHALF OF
THE STATE BUILDING AND
CONSTRUCTION TRADES COUNCIL AND
SUPPORT. SEEING NO OTHER
TESTIMONY WILL MOVE ON TO THE
TELECONFERENCE LINE MISTER
MODERATOR IF YOU COULD PLEASE
QUEUE UP THOSE WHO WISH TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT. ONCE AGAIN
IF YOU'D LIKE TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN
ZERO. ONE ZERO. FIRST OVER THE
LINE THREE SEVENTEEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD YOUR LINE IS OPEN. GOOD
AFTERNOON COMMITTEE CHAIR-
COMMITTEE MEMBERS MY NAME IS
CHRIS HAND AND I'M AN EXECUTIVE
SECRETARY OF THE LOS ANGELES
ORANGE COUNTY'S BUILDING
CONSTRUCTION TRADES COUNCIL WE
STAND IN SOLIDARITY WITH THE
STATE BUILDING CONSTRUCTION
TRADES COUNCIL OF CALIFORNIA IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU. THANKS VERY
MUCH. NEXT WE'RE GOING TO MIND
THREE TWENTY NINE PLEASE GO
AHEAD YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HELLO
CAN YOU HEAR ME WE CAN HEAR YOU
. FIVE CHARLIE CARLO RESEARCH
ANALYST WITH UNITE HERE LOCAL
ELEVEN HOSPITALITY WORKERS UNION
AND WE STRONGLY SUPPORT THIS
LEGISLATION. THANK YOU VERY MUCH. NEXT ONE OF MINE THREE TWENTY
FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. GOOD AFTERNOON THAT THE
CLARA CARTER WITH CENTRAL CITY
ASSOCIATION OF LOS ANGELES AND
WE WANTED TO REGISTER A STRONG
SUPPORT FOR THE FELT THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. NEXT WE'LL
GO TO LINE THREE TWENTY TWO
PLEASE GO AHEAD. AFTERNOON MY
NAME IS KATE HALE AND CHAIRMAN
OF THE GREATER LOOKING BACK AT
THE CHAMBER OF COMMERCE AND WE
STAND IN SUPPORT OF THIS PROJECT
THANK YOU. AND THE FINAL ONE WE
HAVE IN QUEUE COMES FROM LINE
THREE THIRTY PLEASE GO AHEAD.
FIND THREE THIRTY YOU'RE OPEN.
THE. GOING ONCE GOING TWICE.
THAT WAS THE LAST ONE WE HAD YOU
VERY GOOD WE'RE GOING TO MOVE ON
TO OUR- UP OPPOSITION WITNESSES
THERE ARE NO LEAD OPPOSITION
WITNESSES SOMEONE ASK ANYONE IN
ROOM TWENTY TWO HUNDRED IF THEY
LIKE TO TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION.
SEEING NO ONE WILL MOVE ON TO
THE TELECONFERENCE LINE IS THERE
ANYONE THAT WOULD LIKE LIKE TO
TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION TO SB.
THIRTEEN SEVENTY THREE.
SACRAMENTO BY IN A POSITION
PLEASE PRESS ONE TO DETERMINE
TELEPHONE KEYPAD. WE HAVE NO
LINES INTO AT THIS TIME VERY
GOOD WILL BRING THIS BILL BACK
TO THE COMMITTEE ARE THERE ANY
QUESTIONS COMMENTS CONCERNS.
SENATOR THE BILL OKAY IT'S BEEN
MOVED BY SENATOR ALSO SAID
THIRTY NIELSEN NO CONCERNS AND I
CERTAINLY DO SUPPORT THE BILL I
WILL THOUGH WRITTEN TREAT THESE
PROPONENTS HERE WHO HAVE
TESTIFIED THIS IS FOR ONE VERY
pBIG COUNTY BUT WE HAVE A LOT OF
OTHER SMALLER COMMUNITIES
THROUGH THE FACT REMAINED ON SAN
JOAQUIN VALLEYS FOR EXAMPLE THE
WILL HAVE SIMILAR NEEDS IN THE
FUTURE. SO WE WOULD ASK THAT YOU
WOULD BE AS SUPPORTIVE OF US
THEN AS WE ARE OF YOU NOW THAT'S
ALL. THE GOOD POINT OTHER
COMMENTS OR QUESTIONS I AND I
SAY THAT BECAUSE I HAVE A
COMMUNITY THAT- APPROACHED ME
ABOUT A VERY VERY SIMILAR ISSUE-
THAT HAVE. MANY MULTIPLE PARKING
LOTS IN THE DOWNTOWN AREA AND
UNFORTUNATELY THAT DIDN'T FIT
THIS AND COULDN'T GET THEIR ACT
TOGETHER QUICK ENOUGH TO BE ABLE
TO ASK YOU IF YOU WOULD CONSIDER
THEM AS WELL- BUT- THE FACT THAT
YOU AYE. IT'S CENTER YOU NIELSEN
THERE THERE ARE SPECIAL
CIRCUMSTANCES IN IN IN SOME
CASES ONE SIZE DOESN'T ALWAYS
FIT ALL. OTHER COMMENTS FROM
COMMITTEE MEMBERS. OKAY WE DO
HAVE A MOTION THE MOTION IS DUE
PASSED TO THE SENATE FLOOR WOULD
YOU LIKE TO INCLUDE. I JUST I
SAID WE GET A LOT OF THOSE CALLS
MAYBE TO HAVE- I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR YOUR AYE VOTE. PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL SENATORS CABALLERO
HI CABALLERO HI NIELSEN. NIELSEN
HI DURAZO. ZERO ZERO FIVE
HERTZBERG. WIENER WIENER I FORTY
ZERO RELEASE OUT FORTY ZERO. AND
OUR FINAL BILL OF THE DAY. FILE
ITEM NUMBER FIFTEEN S. B.
THIRTEEN THIRTY SIX BY SENATOR
WIENER. THE WARS YEARS GREAT I
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR- FIRST OF
ALL I WON A- THANK YOU AND YOUR
COMMITTEE FOR WORKING WITH US ON
THIS LEGISLATION- AND I'M HAPPY
TO ACCEPT THE COMMITTEES
AMENDMENTS TO DO THE FOLLOWING-
SAID A SEVEN YEAR CARRY FORWARD
PERIOD- DEFINITIONS FOR FULL TO
THE FREEZE IS FULL TIME FIFTY
RELATED EQUIPMENT TRAINNG
SERVICES MINIMUM WAGE AND
WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT AND
DISALLOW. THIS EXPENSE DEDUCTION
OR A TAX CREDIT FOR THE SAME
COSTS THAT GENERATE B. S. B.
THIRTEEN THIRTY SIX CREDITS- SO
COLLEAGUES- AS YOU KNOW- JUST
LEGISLATION WILL ESTABLISH A
CARRY FORWARD CANNABIS TAX
CREDITS 25% OF THE FOLLOWING
QUALIFIED BUSINESS EXPENDITURES
PAID OR INCURRED IN A TAXABLE
YEAR EMPLOYEE EMPLOYMENT
COMPENSATION THAT'S EQUAL TO OR
ABOVE A 150% OF MINIMUM WAGE
INCLUDING BENEFITS- SAFETY
RELATED EQUIPMENT SERVICES.
WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT AND SAFETY
TRAINING FOR EMPLOYEES- IN THE
CASE FOR THE CREDIT- EXCEEDS IN
THE NET TAX WE CAN'T TAKE
ADVANTAGE OF THE FULL CREDIT
THAT YEAR THE ACCESS CAN BE
CARRIED FORWARD TO FUTURE YEARS-
FIRST THE MAXIMUM WILL BE THE
SEVEN YEAR PERIOD OF THE BILL-
THE CREDIT WILL NOT BE ABLE TO
EXCEED TWO HUNDRED FIFTY
THOUSAND DOLLARS IN A IN A
PARTICULAR YEAR. ARE ONLY BE
AGAIN APPLIED AGAINST TAXES
UNTIL TWENTY TWENTY EIGHT-
BECAUSE WE KNOW THAT- CANNABIS
BUSINESSES HAVE A REAL PROBLEM
DATE BECAUSE THEY CAN'T- BECAUSE
THEY ARE ILLEGAL UNDER FEDERAL
CANNABIS IS ILLEGAL UNDER
FEDERAL LAW I'M CANNABIS
BUSINESSES ARE OFTEN INELIGIBLE
FOR ANY KIND OF BUSINESS RELIEF
INCLUDING- TAX DEDUCTIONS- SO-
THEY TEND TO DOCTOR WAGES AND
SALARIES SOME OF THEIR NORMAL
OVERHEAD EXPENSES ADVERTISING.
TRAVEL ON ETCETERA THE THAT
OTHER BUSINESSES TAKE FOR
GRANTED- THEY CAN ONLY TALK TO
COST OF THEIR IN THE- WE KNOW
ALSO THAT CANNOT BUSINESSES
ACCOUNT. OR UNDER HUGE PRESSURE
FROM THE ILLICIT MARKET ALL
RIGHT. CONVERSATIONS TODAY ABOUT
HIGH TAX BURDENS AS WELL AS
REGULATORY IN LAND USE.
RESTRICTIONS AND- ALYSSA
MARKETING CALIFORNIA IS REALLY
THRIVING- AND WE NEED TO REALLY-
MAKE SURE THAT THAT STOPS
HAPPENING AND THAT WE SUPPORT
AND GROWOUR LEGAL- CANNABIS.
MARKET WE ALSO WANT TO MAKE SURE
THAT WE ARE- REALLY
INCENTIVIZING CANNABIS
BUSINESSES TO BE GOOD ACTORS
WITH RESPECT TO THEIR EMPLOYEES
AND THAT'S WHY. THE CREDITS AND
THIS BILL WILL ONLY APPLY TO
BUSINESSES THAT ARE DOING THE
RIGHT THING IN TERMS OF PAYING A
GOOD WAGE- YOU KNOW IN INVESTING
IN SAFETY- AND ALSO IN WORKFORCE
DEVELOPMENT AND SAFETY TRAINING.
FOR EMPLOYEES ALSO COLLEAGUES
THIS BILL ON THE SIZE OF A
BULLET BUT IT WILL HELP OUR
LEGAL CANNABIS INDUSTRY AND IT'S
DEREK AND BEEN PLEASE OF THAT
INDUSTRY. I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR I. BOATS I WAS WITH ME
TODAY TO TESTIFY- ALBERT'S RICOH
ON BEHALF OF OUR SPONSOR. UNITED
FOOD AND COMMERCIAL WORKERS- AND
THEN RATES- SIGN FROM OF CRAFT.
VERY GOOD WE WILL START WITH THE
IN PERSON WELCOME- FORMER
ASSEMBLYMEMBER TO RICO. ASSEMBLY
WHEN COLLEGE HERE SAY GOOD
MORNING. HELPFUL AND OUR
APOLOGIES. HAVING YOU STAY HERE
ALL DAY- I'M SURE YOU UNDERSTAND
HOW THAT ALL WORKS GOOD
AFTERNOON CHAIRMAN MR THE
TERMINALS PERCEIVES HER THIRD
ROWS OF- ABOUT A TRIP COMING UP
THE UNITED FOOD AND COMMERCIAL
WORKERS WESTERN STATES COUNCIL
SPONSORS OF ELEVEN OF THIRTY SIX
ONE BECAUSE- YOU MADAM CHAIR AND
YOUR STAFF FOR YOUR DILIGENCE
AND YOUR- ASSISTANCE AND REALLY
GETTING THE BILL TO PLACE FOR WE
THINK IT'S GONNA MAKE A
DIFFERENCE. AS CENTER WINDSCRIBE
YOU'VE SHE DOUBLES BUT INVOLVED
WITH THE CANNABIS INDUSTRY FROM
THE OUTSET OUR OBJECTIVE HAS
ALWAYS BEEN THAT THIS NOW MULTI
BILLION DOLLAR INDUSTRY CREATE
MIDDLE CLASS JOBS WITH LIVING
WAGES AND OTHER IMPORTANT
BENEFITS UNFORTUNATELY TWO MAJOR
IMPEDIMENTS THAT ARE DRIVING
WAGES AND BENEFITS DOWN IN THIS
INDUSTRY FIRST ILLICIT MARKET
WHICH MAKES UP ONE HALF OF THE
CANNABIS PRODUCTION AND SALES IN
THE STATE THESE ARE LICENSE
OPERATIVE A SIGNIFICANT ECONOMIC
ADVANTAGE AND UNDERCUTTING THE
LEGAL MARKET SECOND RELATED TO
THE FIRST POINT. IS AFFECTED
LICENSE OPERATORS ARE OVER
BURDENED BY HIGH TAXES AND FEES
WHAT'S UP WITH UNLICENSED
OPERATORS NOR SB THIRTEEN THIRTY
SIX SIX TO ALLEVIATE SOME OF
THIS ECONOMIC PRESSURE TO
TARGETED TAX CREDITS FOR HIGH
QUALITY LICENSE OPERATORS FOR
THE REASONS SET FORTH ABOVE AND
DISCUSSED BY CENTER WINNER
RESPECTFULLY ASK LEVEL I ALSO
WANT TO SEE MY TESTIMONY ON
BEHALF OF THE SAN DIEGO AND
IMPERIAL COUNTY'S JOINT LABOR
MANAGEMENT CANNABIS COMMITTEE.
THE ONLY ORGANIZATION
REPRESENTING THE INTERESTS OF
LABOR AND MANAGEMENT IN THE
CANNABIS INDUSTRY ALSO STRONG
SUPPORT THANK YOU VERY GOOD NOW-
FROM RACHEL SIGN. TO CAN I
CRAFTING CORPORATE IT. GOOD
AFTERNOON. TAPIO NINETEEN
COMMITTEE. CAN HAVE A THREE TO
TESTIFY AND SPEND A BILL THIRTY
THIRTY. I'VE BEEN INTO LEADER WE
TAKE PRIDE IN OUR HIGH. PRODUCTS
WELL BY SOME. IN A- AND
EXTENSIVE. IN THE COMMUNITIES
WHERE WE LIVE AND WORK. LAST
YEAR OUR COMPANY BY A COLLECTIVE
BARGAINING AGREEMENT WITH UFCW
LOCAL FIVE. MAKING IT ONE OF THE
FEW CANNABIS MANUFACTURERS TO
UNIONIZE. THE TAXES IMPOSED ON
THE CANNABIS INDUSTRY BY PROP
SIXTY FOUR COMBINED WITH HIGH
REGULATORY COSTS. INCENTIVIZE
CONSUMERS TO BUY CHEAPER
UNTESTED PRODUCTS FROM THE
ILLICIT MARKET. IN FACT AN
ESTIMATED EIGHT BILLION DOLLARS
BELT CURRENTLY FLOW THROUGH
CALIFORNIA ILLICIT CANNABIS
MARKET EACH YEAR WELL THE
STATE'S LEGAL MARKET BRINGS IN
ABOUT HALF THAT AMOUNT. SB
THIRTEEN THIRTY SIX LABEL COUNTY
PLAYERS LIKE CANNOT CROSS WITH
THE COMMITMENT TO ADVANCING THE
RIGHT WORKERS BETTER COMPETE
WITH THE ILLICIT MARKET. SB
THIRTEEN THIRTY SIX HELP GOOD
ACTORS ARE HIGH ROAD EMPLOYERS.
BY ENSURING THAT WE CAN AFFORD
TO DO RIGHT BY OUR WORKFORCE AND
PROVIDE WELL PAYING JOB. YOU
INCENTIVIZING TAX CREDITS THAT
WILL ULTIMATELY LOWER OUR
PRODUCTS RIGHT WE ARE PROUD TO
SUPPORT SB THIRTEEN THIRTY SIX.
AND URGE YOU. TO PLEASE WELL I'D
TODAY THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH WE MOVE ON TO. WITNESSES IN
ROOM TWO HIGH. THAT WOULD LIKE
TO. TESTIFYING IN SUPPORT OF S.
B. THIRTEEN THIRTY SIX. SEEING
NO FURTHER WITNESSES WILL MOVE
ON TO THE- TELECONFERENCE LINE.
MISTER MODERATOR COULD YOU P.
PLEASE PROMPT INDIVIDUALS WHO
WOULD LIKE TO TESTIFY. LADIES
AND GENTLEMEN TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN
THERE ON YOUR CELL PHONE KEYPAD
. ONE MOMENT PLEASE SO WE GET
THE LINE FOR THE FIRST
COMMENTERS. OVERLAND THREE
HUNDRED AND THIRTY SIX YOUR LINE
IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. AND I'M
SURE MEMBERS BRANCH MARTIN ON
BEHALF OF THE PARENT COMPANY IN
VERY STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. TOTALING THREE
HUNDRED AND THIRTY EIGHT PLEASE
GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM
CHAIR MOLLY BYNUM BEHALF OF
UNITED MAGIC WORKERS ASKING
LOCAL THIRTY NINE THIRTY CALLING
A STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. THANK THREE HUNDRED
AND THIRTY TWO PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD AFTERNOON LINDA ROBINSON ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
CANNABIS INDUSTRY ASSOCIATION
AND SUPPORT AND WE THINK THE
AUTHOR FOR HIS LEADERSHIP ON
THIS ISSUE THANK YOU. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. FRANK THREE HUNDRED
AND THIRTY SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD
. JAPANESE MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS CHILD DENTAL BEHALF OF
HEATED UP HERE OUT ME A LOCAL
THIRTY THIRTY IN UPDATE AT B.
THIRTEEN THIRTY SIX THANK YOU.
THE YOU VERY MUCH. THREE HUNDRED
AND THIRTY FIVE PLEASE GO AHEAD
. I CAN'T MEMBERS ONLY HAVE
CREATED- ON BEHALF OF EVA AND
ALSO EAT IN SUPPORT. NINE THREE
HUNDRED THIRTY NINE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. AUTHOR HELLO THREE
HUNDRED THIRTY NAME PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HELLO THIS IS A GOOD
EVENING MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS OF
RECOLLECT WILL BE ON BEHALF APEX
GROUP IN THE COURT AND- WE HAVE
SECURE A PERFECT UNION SUPPORT
EXCUSE ME. THANK YOU THANK YOU.
BRITAIN ADDITIONAL LINES AT THIS
TIME VERY GOOD WE'RE GOING TO
MOVE ON TO- WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION THERE ARE NO LEAD
OPPOSITION WITNESSES LISTED IS
THERE ANYBODY IN THE COMMITTEE
ROOM THAT WOULD LIKE TO TESTIFY
IN OPPOSITION. SEEING NONE WILL
MOVE ON TO THE TELECONFERENCE
LINE MISTER MODERATOR IS OR
ANYBODY ON THE TELECONFERENCE
LINE THAT WISHES TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION. LADIES AND GENTLEMEN
TO SPEAKING UP ELECTION PLEASE
PRESS ONE THEN ZERO ON YOUR
TELEPHONE KEYPAD. WE HAVE NO
LAND OF OPPOSITE AT THIS TIME
VERY GOOD WE'RE GOING TO BRING
THE- BILL BACK TO THE COMMITTEE
COMMENTS QUESTIONS MOTIONS.
MOTIONS THE BILL. THERE IS A
MOTION TO MOVE THE BELL. SEE NO
FURTHER DISCUSSION SENATOR YOU
MAY CONCLUDE RESPECTFULLY ASK
RIVAL VERY GOOD THE MOTION IS TO
PASS AS AMENDED BUT FIRST AMEND
AND RE REFER TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL SENATORS CAMBIADO HI
CABALLERO HI NIELSEN. NIELSEN HI
DURAZO. DRAWS OF HIGH HERTZBERG.
WIENER WIENER HI FORTY ZERO THAT
FEEL IS OUT. FORTY ZERO. THAT
CONCLUDES OUR- OKAY OH THAT'S
RIGHT THE THREE ITEM NUMBERS
THIRTEEN. OKAY SO- MEMBERS WE
HAVE A WE HAVE ONE ONE BILL I
NEED TO CALL. I HAVE ONE BILL ON
CALL WHICH IS FILE ITEM NUMBER
THIRTEEN S. B. THIRTEEN OH ONE
BY SENATOR BAKER PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS CURRENT VOTE IS
THREE TWO ZERO SENATOR HERTZBERG
. WIENER WIENER HI FOUR ZERO
THAT GOES OUT FORTY ZERO. THANK
YOU TO ALL THE INDIVIDUALS WHO
PARTICIPATED IN PUBLIC TESTIMONY
TODAY AND WE DO APOLOGIZE FOR
THOSE MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC THAT
WERE ON EARLIER TODAY AND SPEND
A LOT OF TIME ON THE PHONE WE
HAD TO RECESS AND COME BACK AND
WE MAY HAVE MISTER TEST. IF YOU
WERE IN IT THE TESTIFIED TODAY.
YOU CAN SUBMIT YOUR COMMENTS OR
SUGGESTIONS IN WRITING. TO THE
GOVERNANCE AND FINANCE COMMITTEE
OR YOU CAN VISIT THE WEB
WEBSITE. YOUR COMMENTS AND
SUGGESTIONS ARE IMPORTANT TO US
WE WANT TO INCLUDE YOUR
TESTIMONY IN THE OFFICIAL
HEARING RECORD. THANK YOU AND WE
REALLY APPRECIATE YOUR
PARTICIPATION. THANK YOU TO
EVERYONE FOR YOUR PATIENCE AND
COOPERATION. WE HAVE CONCLUDED
THE AGENDA THIS THE SENATE
COMMITTEE ON GOVERNANCE AND
FINANCE IS ADJOURNED.